the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club the conclusion of the 2023 Grand
chess tour is of and running at the
singfield cup in St Louis tour players
have gathered for one final battle to
decide a champion but world class wild
cards aim to cut into the points and the
prize fund current GCT points leader
Fabiano Carana followed up his St Louis
rapid and Blitz Victory with a fighting
draw to begin his final push for the
title Chasers look to press in hopes of
gaining some ground on the leader but
were met with stalwart defenses yielding
solid draws the field is undefeated
after one round who will strike first
and claim a victory round two of
incredible chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome to round two of the singfield
cup we have some of the best chess
players in the world competing here in
St Louis we are excited to see how the
tournament unfolds let's go back to the
studio and get
started welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the sinkfield cup
the granddaddy of them all and it starts
right
now hello and welcome and it's the
second day the second round of the sink
field Cup and the big question what will
the day bring will it bring precision
and accuracy or will the players come to
the board full of risk-taking and
swashbuckling play well we'll find out
I'm International master ianka housea
and it's a great pleasure to be here in
the studio calling all the action
alongside grandm yasa Saran and our
resident expert in the corner grandmas
Peter smidler nobody puts Peter in the
corner nobody but Peter in the card
pleasure to be with you Joey pleasure to
be with you too Peter hello everyone and
Welcome to our show indeed round two is
about to get underway round one was a
very quiet Affair which was marred by
the fact that four of the five games had
Bishops of opposite color and yes they
have drawing Tendencies so all the games
were draws the standings look pretty
much like they did at the start of the
event uh Joy me one thing yes everyone's
the winner as we take it's a hot
chocolate moment isn't it certainly is
nothing can separate our 10 players
after round one as everyone Drew but of
course this means that the tension is
just going to start increasing as more
and more rounds progress and uh let's
check out the format indeed let's do
exactly that and uh the players will be
playing very classical very leisurely
format and uh there we can see it is a
10 player round robin and the players do
play 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
and then 30 minutes for the rest of the
game but they do get a 30second Time
bonus or increment from move one and the
best part of all no draw offers allowed
and there we see the standing scoring
system one point for win half point for
draw fting chess is certainly assured
and our schedule joy we are now on to
round two and take a look at this the
players will be playing one game per day
they're playing through Thanksgiving and
also maybe more importantly Black Friday
sales but take a look at the rest day on
Sunday November 26th and the last day
Thursday November the 30th and there
will be a separate day for playoffs if
they are required wonderful and Peter
there is a potential that playoffs could
be required
includ two different sets of playoffs
available for us uh in in case people
tie and people could of course tie for
uh the singfield cup the strongest
classical tournament outside of the
world champion Championship cycle I
would say but there is also the grand CH
tour and this is the conclusion of it so
let's take a look at how things stand in
the grand chest tour uh currently
surprising nobody I think Fabby is very
much in the lead having won two out of
the three events he played so uh there
you see him up top on 33 points a full
11 points clear of Maxim Vash Graal
resua there lurking in the shadows
literally right this moment uh and Fabi
of course is in a very very dominant
position but things could still change
should have a really really poor event
because these are the points uh in play
and as you see an outright win uh
without tying for first Nets you 13
ground chest tore points and the 10th
Place only gets one point uh and the
math therefore is fairly straightforward
Maxim V gra who is the only player to
have ever won the grand uh the singfield
cup out tried more than once needs to
win and Fabby needs to finish dead last
and then mvl gets to 35 and Fabby ends
up with 34 and mvl wins uh the tour if
fabibi uh finishes ninth they will be
tied on 35th on 35 points in that
scenario and they will play uh the
playoff for the grand chest TOUR
Championship on the same evening of
December the
1st and with that I'm very very happy to
introduce woman Grand Master Anastasia
covich nice to take it
away thank you Peter hello everyone it's
nice to be here are not far away from
Grand chour from singfield cup happening
just nearby and I'm waiting for the
players for the interviews right after
they finish their games as well as I'm
taking care of social media accounts of
grand chur so don't forget to follow our
social media accounts on Facebook
Twitter Instagram and of course check
some videos on YouTube channel if they
you miss them um and I prepared a few
tweets for you today Magnus Carlson
former world champion celebrates 10th
anniversary of the the day when he
decided to go to swim fully dressed
after winning the world championship
title for the first time in 2013 in
Chennai of course we decided to
congratulate him on this important day
we couldn't miss this moment because
also we know that Magnus Carson was the
Wild Card of grand chur he won two
tournaments before in Croatia and Poland
uh was very impressive um results so the
next tweet is about the small boy who
came yesterday all the way from Chicago
to meet his favorite players and signed
some autographs and I mean he asked him
for some autographs after that and I
think he was very happy with that and um
you know first they they ask for the
autographs and then they become famous
grand Masters you never know what can
happen so we will just guess if if it's
going if he's going to be a future Grand
Master one day we may find find out in a
few years and the last tweet actually is
um is a funny one from Kevin winter who
is who is telling us that he is great to
see joy in the commentary keeping yaser
in check so on this note let me throw it
to the studio back to yaser Ander what
do you think about I like it I like it
thank you Joy keep me in check indeed
that sounds wonderful to me um Joy do
the honors tell our audience what they
can expect for for the pairings for this
the second round of the SRO cup and uh
there you can see the round two pairings
and uh seeo piai facing off against
Dominguez and but as you see there the
uh game between Duda and Report has been
faded out and that is because y Krist
Duda is on well and so the players will
be playing their game at a later date
Wesley so will face off against Maxim
Vash lra and it's an all American Derby
between Fabiano kowana and Levon Iranian
and for me my Marque matchup is between
ARA FIA and Anish G y that was going to
be exciting it sure does uh Grand chest
tour defending Grand chest tour play
peruja up against Anish that should be
fun and uh they're fighting hard
regardless of the fact that five 10
people are tied for first sorry five
draws uh what are they fighting for and
there we have it yeah and there you have
it first place in the single cup will
win
$100,000 as well as either 12 or 13
Grand chest points if one outright and
second place 65,000 thirdd place
$48,000 and there are prizes all the way
down to 10th place which walks away over
$105,000 impressive stuff as I'm looking
at these pairings as I am thinking about
the gem of Fabby and leavon and again
it's just been one of those years where
you just say Fab's been fantastic
everything is just Tom about roses he
winner the rapid and Blitz uh well last
week uh virtually secured for him the
grand chest tour standings and we're
expecting Fabby to continue what has
been once again a fabulous year JY yeah
absolutely Fabiano just playing better
and better you do feel that this is his
year he's in his element and it could
even have been better there we can see
the security checks that the players go
through they're getting scanned and
there we see Chris bird and Leonard utas
there in the
background yeah some somehow I can
imagine myself doing a security check at
the Players cash
jewelry hand it all
over perhaps you'll get it back at the
end ofer no guarantees no guarantees on
this as
[Laughter]
uh he's getting ready there to face off
against
and uh what is he signing okay and okay
so what there what what these chess hats
come from the house of ston mhm and
they're literally selling a piece of
History so if you would like to own a
chess set that was played in the second
round of the sinkfield cup between Yan
and lir they autograph a
certified uh certificate for the
Providence mhm of the set so that you
could probably display this set was
played in the sinkfield cup just as in
baseball this baseball was used in the
World Series in the playoffs and things
of that nature so you see Tony Rich Tony
Rich ringing the bell there to indicate
the start of play and uh already the
players are off we can
see start with bbby and after all Fabby
is our grand chest Tour Tournament
leader he may not be winning leading the
tournament I usually like to start with
the tournament leader but he is
certainly leading the grand chestor E4
E5 now for me I've always and I mean
full stop end of story uh associated
leavon with E5 like that has been his
number one and principal defense then
when he does some Sicilians and
something very very strange I think to
myself like am I living in a parallel
universe because I'm so used to Leon's
uh E5 he's the Marshall man yes exactly
and like everybody uh these days uh he's
also broaden his repertoire and added
the Berlin to his defenses D2 D3 uh
isoing the
um Berlin ending as well as those lines
with Rook E1 and Bishop takes C6 by
Fabby uh Peter it's the Berlin is the
bane of E4 uh players
uh but I I I feel like the players are
going more to D2 D3 these days yeah
there is very few people I think who are
still uh even relatively happy to accept
the the the pure Berlin end game I I
would say that uh mvl is maybe the
remaining one Alexander grishuk at some
point I think was the flag bearer of
people trying to find advantage in in
the Berlin end game proper and a still
does it and still wins very very nice
games occasionally I I think he beat uh
dyus schwi in the previous Edition or
maybe two years back with the white pie
in about 25 moves he occasionally wins
very very spectacular games in the
Berlin but people have uh tended to play
D3 for a while now and move four here
not allowing not allowing the end game
C3 is uh not the most natural move here
people tend to either Castle I think the
two main moves here would be Castle or
Knight bd2 but C3 is never entirely
illogical in any kind of a Spanish
because you're inting at D D3 D4 I
suspect the idea is uh let's say if if
the pawn gets protected Bishop D6
currently is the engine's first
suggestion it's not the only move but
it's a kind of a logical move these days
they often develop the bishop to G5
because on C1 it's often not doing very
much E3 is not a particularly good
Square for it whereas G3 surprisingly
once we push D4 and perhaps Force black
to take on D4 the bishop on G3 will look
quite nice so a kind of a logic
and these are not forced moves I I'm
just I just want to show the the
structure let's say we unpin ourselves
somehow once again I let's let's do it
slightly differently let's do it this
way and this is the kind of a structure
you see quite a bit uh in the lines
where white goes C3 Bishop G5 obviously
none of this is forced I just wanted to
show a kind of snapshot of what we could
be aiming
towards I like these positions for white
but I think objectively they're still
fine for black and I think uh black
players aren't really very afraid of
them but it is a way to get a game
against the Berlin it it allows you to
play a position where there will be no
forced variations people will be forced
to express themselves you know actually
move the chess pieces around and compete
in who does it better which is something
that I think most people dream of when
they're faced with with this opening it
feels these days like everybody's trying
to avoid making commitments so something
like queen7
to keep you know the option of Bishop G4
and Castle long alive uh what's uh
what's the latest and greatest in the
because C2 C3 is a move that really I'm
not it's rarer than the than
specifically I think the the nb2 and the
castle are much much more popular but we
we've already seen there was a very
spectacular game in uh in the rapid and
Blitz portion where Anish giri went for
this peace sacrifice against Wesley so
worked fabulously well for him it it
worked really really well for him so
castles allows all kinds of uh options
for black and 9b2 you're also somewhat
committing to to certain plans because
it's much harder now to develop this
Bishop from C1 to good squares and uh uh
it gives black options uh and an
additional layer to this I think is uh
trying to get leevon to play from as
early on as possible right because Leon
of course uh having chosen the Berlin
and I do want to say I'm somewhat
disappointed with here because at some
point I no longer count myself in in in
in those sentences but uh there was
definitely a point where Leon and myself
were the only two players who played the
sort of the quote unquote proper Ru
Lopez right we played the Marshall we
played the classical lines we played all
kinds of stuff and we never
touched the Berlin but now leevon has
gone over to the dark side which is uh
honestly honestly a bit regrettable yeah
I I disapprove well that means that you
have to Champion the calls all by
yourself and uh you know the Marshall
too Joy that's just been also one of
those openings that E4 players have been
breaking their head against I I and I
know it's just a Reams and reams of
theory and it all ends in a draw so you
know I I'm not surprised that uh that
has gone over to the dark side it does
have cookies after and by the way we
have seen a very early D3
D4 uh you know everybody's playing Joko
Pian everybody threatens to play D4
nobody ever really plays D4 what's going
on here do well after Bishop D6 I just I
can repeat the whole speech but I have I
have given the speech about where this
bishop belongs I am expecting Bishop G5
here because honestly I've seen in
positions like this the engines after
let's say if we Castle here the engines
do start suggesting the move H6 and just
what you just to keep it there what are
you doing because really even if you
develop it to to the E3 square and then
you know we get to some kind of position
like this it's a bit in a way uh you
would like to protect the pawn E4 to be
able to play Knight C4 and currently you
don't have the option so
it's it's a an actual thing you have to
consider if you don't play Bishop G5
here you may never get well it's like
Bishop E3 is not threatening anybody
exctly but there is a school of thoughts
in in the England that the bishop on C1
is perfectly fine on where it starts
because it after all you know it's a
long range piece it is it is it still
has a lot of potential you just leave it
back there you just leave it back there
and then the castles and you get on with
the most important thing which is just
uh supporting the center and going for
your N4 idea so we we do with do this
yeah and uh yeah black black can react
to this in a in a variety of ways you
can still uh give up the central control
because I think very often these days
they actually go for setups like this
and then you you have to start thinking
about meeting of seven five it's a
double-edged idea because obviously if
you if you get the 5 E5 in there will be
a protected passer but this gives the
Let's Make a Move yeah just yeah it's
better to show than to talk about this
uh yes white now has a nice looking a
protected pster in the center but this
bishop will come out to E6 there's a
very nice D5 Square for both the Knight
and also in some cases the bishop could
come there and the KN could be rerouted
to the E6 Square ideally if that ever
happens black will be better I would
suspect so
it's not such a such a bad deal for for
black anyway you could also sorry this
is not the position we're discussing
this is the position we're discussing
NOP finally you can also play something
like like F6 uh Knight C4 and just keep
this shape and ask white of exactly what
do you want out of life um I don't hate
it we'll see what uh what Faby thinks
about this and how do they match up in
their head thing head oh these are old
friends old rivals and there you can see
that Fabiana Carana with 13 wins to
Aron's 9 31 draws well Fabby doeses Edge
it out but these guys they know each
other so well they certainly do and of
course now they play on the same team
exactly well let's uh see uh the other
games as we're going to go to the game
of Wesley so versus mvl the player you
pointed out could potentially surpass
p on an spacular I figured it out by the
way I are you ready for this here it
comes okay so what I did is how do you
get MV to win the tournament well you
have one victory in the entire
tournament one Victory MBL wins against
Faby there's a massive eight-way tie for
second and that's how you and MBL wins
the tours the tour in that entirely
realistic scenario MBL wins theour
conclusively one one win in the entire
tournament uh taking us to the game of
Wesley so and mvl uh looks like a very
intriguing English n pardon me Sicilian
it's a Nar to which Wesley uh replied
with Bishop
D3 uh a move that has become quite
fashionable recently and uh mvel himself
an interesting bit about this is mvel
himself played this
against I want to say Jeffrey or Ray I
think it was against Jeffrey that game
in which he pushed five F6 and was
completely winning for most of it and
then didn't win a rook ending so mvl
will be intimately uh aware of this the
main reply here is E5 and it's supposed
to be fine this is what uh Jeffrey
played uh we're going with it being
Jeffrey and not Ray I apologize to Ray
Robson if if I'm mistaking his game for
Jeff Jeffrey's game but G6 is a logical
reply because Bishop D3 seems like a bit
of a strange move why are we developing
the bishop to this in a dragon uh kind
of a strange Square so early on and even
more interestingly white actually says
the dragon is so dubious that we're
going to be I will be playing playing a
dragon with the inclusion of the move
Bishop D3 which really feels like it's
if anything detrimental to our cause
right and black you know the dragon D
the dragon DWF is a very major opening
these days but F3 is the choice and ail
replies very very forcefully he goes
Queen B6 now very cute move here by
Wesley A2 A3 not only hinting well not
hinting pointing out that the Knight is
currently not hanging because Bishop B5
check followed by Queen takes D4 will
win the queen but also after Knight
C6 preparing to play Bishop B3 and this
is why A3 is useful black would normally
would like to take on on B2 whoops but
we've taken away the B4 Square by
playing A2 A3 and the A3 Square to go
with it and this just loses the queen
once again uh and andil very quickly
goes E5 now Knight F5 which looks like a
spectacular move but is in fact a very
normal move protecting the bishop on E3
the queen drops back and
now uh the choices between Knight H6 and
Knight G3 Knight H6 I would say is the
more uh ambitious choice because you
trying to make it awkward for black to
Castle King side this will obviously be
illegal as long as the Knight stays on
H6 but it's also quite clearly a bit
misplaced if if if black manages to I
don't know Play Bishop B6 and then D5
maybe even the immediate D6 D5 and you
don't get anything direct out of having
a knight on H6 it might look like you
know a fifth whe right or an umbrella on
a fish or
something uh so so so the Knight went
back to G3 and mvl played Bishop B6 so
mvl clearly showing that he is uh not
surprised by by Wesley slightly off bit
Choice what do we think about this
position well it's strange I I mean I
think think there's a disharmony in
White's position and for for me the
Knight on G3 and the bishop on D3 both
are not suboptimal I mean not not great
squares whereas the inclusion of G7 G6
an argument might be made yet you're
like yeah I would rather have the pawn
back on G7 but not so much so that I
wouldn't be very happy for the misplaced
pieces I like black I like I kind of
like white because because of this uh
big Square on D5 if you control that
breakout then I think White Knight has a
nice advantage and the Knight on G3 is
bad but you can see a situation where
the bishop will come to H6 and uh look
H4 H5 or maybe even a knight jumping
back into F5 so just to put it so let
let let's play a move here for mvl and
you can show uh Joie the audience what
your suggesting so Bishop G7 show we
Castle yeah going to be compliant shall
we yeah let's Castle Castle's castles
Bishop H6 what and this is where I like
to tickle you on the king site and start
here here you're about to point out that
the Knight on G3 is useful because you
can go H4 and you've got H5 coming
exactly and you're going to blast open
on the king site and if you're very
careless the KN can jump back into F5 so
for example I'll be careless I'll fall
for your nefarious
plan something of like this right so my
Knight's on
D4 and I'll play it in in true uh
dragon uh style Queen A5 you want to
take and take on G7 yeah okay and you
want to come in with Queen H6 as
well yeah I'm going to have to do
something like that but um like
something like this but you didn't play
ball by putting the Knight on D4 cuz I
wanted to put my knight on F5 oh oh oh
okay that's true that's true okay so I I
take it back so I'm going to play uh
B5 yeah sorry then I'm going to take
anyway my point is still that the night
K can come back to F5 because I mean if
you if you so I'm just going to make a
yeah I mean even now you can go Knight
to F5 with or without well I like
somehow you're going to you're going to
want all of this good stuff right yeah
and this is how you how you swing for
the fence and you go Checkmate me with
Knight F5 these types of ideas right yes
but also when the bishop is still on G7
you know the Knight on F5 cannot be
captured because of Queen G Queen G5 and
how do these uh two players match up I
suspect it's
even I was so close on this
one really really you felt it
right yeah wow absolutely I did not
expect that there we see maxi 12 leading
with six wins to Wesley's one they do
have 21 draws though they do indeed uh
that was perhaps why I actually chose
mvl as my pick uh the fact that he's won
it twice really uh the singfield cup
twice really had a lot to do with it but
this uh for me this Knight on G3 the
bishop on D3 again I feel like this
bishop on D3 is harmless you mentioned
in the British School of Chess you might
just have left the bishop on F1 and
played a more useful move than King B1
sort of like I've got a a backward Pawn
on D6 and the bishop really is in the
way uh but Peter it's unfair of you to
throw the ball in our Direction because
you yourself know the open Sicilian
positions a lot better than ourselves
Bishop on D3 Knight on G3 are
suboptimal but uh these these are very
unusual positions and also uh as it
often is the case you you get slightly
Jaded by reading the first line but
instinctively I think I'd be quite happy
with this with black I would feel that I
got a very fighting position where I'm
not entirely sure how I'm going to get
attacked and I have my own
counterplay uh in N this night on six is
kind of unusual it normally is on D7
leaving the C file easier to organize
counterplay uh but right even so this
feels this feels like this is decent for
black uh we're still following by the
way at least one very high profile game
I briefly cheated by looking at Yanka
screen as well I like looking at screens
we're still following we're still
following a game between Mickey Adams
playing against Bogdan deak from I think
2021 so if mcky has played this with
white this is a stamp of approval Micky
is one of the uh best players of the
nether of on the white side has been for
his entire career um but for black you
go Rook C8 I'm kind of curious I
understand Bishop G7 and castles is very
natural but having play E5 putting it on
G7 is perhaps not that great so I was
looking at ideas of let's say they
castle and we go like H5 here uh and
then we put the bishop on E7 perhaps we
go I understand this is very fanciful
but my idea was something like this with
like king of H7 to follow and then I
start playing on the queen side I
suspect I will get hit with Knight D5 at
some point though in uh in positions
like this or F3 F4 the engine really
hates it but uh my slightly Rusty night
of instincts would have been uh looking
at something like this very good oh one
thing I will say is that this is just a
very very interesting very unusual
position I'm very much looking forward
to seeing how uh two very strong players
are treating it so the way you're
looking at the position Knight on G3
Bishop on D3 suboptimal Knight on
C6 C6 you don't particularly want to
spend two temp you know putting it on A5
then putting it on C4 and trading it for
the one bad piece white has right uh
Knight D4 will be good in some positions
and less good in some others because
very often white will just be able to
take take it and yeah for me the big
question is where do I develop the
bishop on f8 because having play G6 it
looks very natural to put it on G7 but
was it doing on G7 is not entirely clear
so there are still things to think about
and yeah mvl has by this point just now
played Bishop bu G7 resolving at least
this mystery uh I'm very very curious
about this because um a very fresh
position even though we're still
following some high-profile games this
is a very very unusual constellation of
pieces for an idorf and
very interesting to see how it develops
thank you Peter uh turning toally we're
not following that high profile game
anymore Bishop G7 was a G4 was a new
move I think uh in that game like had
continued with Peter's idea of H7 H5
just asking the the night the question
uh Ali Raza versus Anish G I think Anish
was your pick it was my pick uh Ali Raza
uh Joko piano Bishop C4 Knight F6 the uh
two knights defense D2 D3 and again as a
kid I just have to say it once more
nobody and I mean nobody today ever
plays Knight G5 I mean you know but as a
kid it was the fried liver attack I
studied the fried liver attack I had
like a twoz
record I thank you very much because
everybody played Bishop C5 and didn't
allow the fried liver attack with Knight
G5 Knight F6 D3 Bishop C5 castles
castles this is everybody's playground
uh it's just all the top Grand Masters
in the world seem to be playing both
sides of this variation D7 D6 D2 C3 A5
now that move I actually really do get
because B2 B4 A2 A4 expanding on the
queen side is a usual go-to mechanism to
get some Edge over there rookie1 Bishop
B6 B3 now that's a pause that's a move
that I just have to stop and say say
Okay um they do just about everything
Peter but B2 B3 this is no longer this
is no longer breaking news this has been
kind of well established as as at least
one of the main replies if not the main
replies to black Plan Bish B6 in all
kinds of positions like this because uh
the argument goes if you take on E6
right there's a massive difference in
how people I think view these positions
uh comparing this one with let's say let
me just put something on the board we do
something very very similar right but we
allow white to play B4 here Bishop by 7
A4 so these types of positions with
white having gain some space on the
queen side potentially then playing with
B5 B6 if black is not careful and just
having very simply more space these are
considered to be at least slightly
better for white whereas these ones with
a Pawn on
A5 they're still playable but I'm pretty
sure they generally assumed to be very
very level and black is not really under
any pressure so having played A5 black
is very happily offering this trade as
you can see uh Anish here is not wasting
any time playing Rook E8 to prepare to
recapture with the Rook he is very happy
to enter the structure and also black
will be I think quite happily taking on
C4 if the recapture is available Knight
takes and D takes after B2 B3 you are
going to question your choices here if
if this is the recapture that you're
allowing because suddenly this Rook has
the B file open to it and also this uh
Feast of Pawns in in the center is going
to control so many squares that it's
going to be almost impossible for black
to achieve any breaks and as you can see
the engine immediately says you've done
something really really bad to your
position here right so B3 is uh a kind
of a useful semi waiting reply here you
we're not committing to anything for now
and we're asking the question do you
really want to trade these Bishops do
you want to play for D6 D5 which often
the answer is yes often what black
actually ends up doing is something like
let's say Rook E8 Bishop B2
G5 you have to think about Bishop B5 you
have to think about these positions but
they tend to be okay for black but this
has been a kind of a trendy uh topical
reply to Bishop B6 for at least maybe
three four years Joy we're going to
trade on my terms go no I was I was just
going to share with you a little bit of
rule of advice because I find these
positions very very difficult to play I
mean there's so many pieces on the board
there's so many subtleties and nuances
but I was treated to one piece of advice
actually coming from a fellow
commentator yeni M nenko and he got the
idea from Alexander grishuk and says
Alexander grishuk has an idea like when
you can play Bishop E6 and you can do it
in this position with a Pawn on A5 with
the pawn on A5 the bishop can go to E6
in one go you don't need to prepare it
so I just wanted to share that piece of
small advice a principal huh
yeah and by the way uh big uh
undercurrent to this specific game is
our candidates watch yes and uh what if
there are two candidate spots available
and one of them will go to the person
with the highest rating on January the
1st 2024 now fua has a live rating of
2762 but not far behind him is Anish
giri and Wesley so so if they manag to
put in good performances then maybe they
can overtake Ali Resa fuja and as we
know uh literally it's a 10-point swing
should fua win this game he would gain
five rating points Anish giri would lose
five rating points and that's good by
Anish as far as the uh the race the for
the rating goes but imagining Anish
winning this game and fua going that
would put uh Anan pole position and
Wesley so very very interested what's
going has a lot of stake uh in this this
event because not only is he in
contention for the rating spot but he's
also in contention for the spot that
will go to the Fay circuit leader and
he's currently in second place behind
Fabian Carana who's already qualified so
if Anish manages to put in a great
performance then he will I I don't quite
know exactly where he has to finish but
let's say you know for top three or
something then he should be getting that
Fay circuit spot crw in there so B2 B3
offering a trade but on my terms I like
what you said there
it seems to me that Ani should be
playing for that D6 D5 break the only
other thing that did actually uh cross
my mind it was a flicker is you know
you're playing for D5 Andor you're
playing for F5 after the move B2 B3 just
imagining that I do throw in a a trade
that the computer hates Bishop takes C4
B takes B3 takes C4 taking more control
of the D5 Square I have this move n to
G4 it's a kind of a you know it's a
cheeky move right you're eyeing up the
F2 po exactly but your real intention is
after I move the Rook up to E2 is
perhaps to go F5 that's exactly what it
is that was my real intention probably
it's not well timed I think the problem
that I have with this is that H2 H3 puts
a kabash on The Brak I don't really want
to take on e4 in that case but I don't
want go back to F6 I'm not really eager
to go back to E6 so this whole idea H6
here is the best move but both H3 and
somewhat surprisingly even e takes A5
Follow by Knight E4 yeah the engine
suggests that Knight on e4 and once
again this is why we were so happy about
having our B2 Pawn being on C4 here the
Knight on e4 now cannot really be
challenged by D6 D5 we're controlling
the D5 square that means that our F2
Pawn is very safe as long as this Knight
on e4 survives and we just go Rook B1 at
some point we chase this away with play
H3 and as you can see the engine really
dislikes this for black it says that
long term you've still done uh damage to
your position very interestingly by the
way Anish does go Knight G4 here uh but
after Rook E2 I have a feeling he is not
going to be taking on uh on C4 and
playing F5 he will be doing something
else the engine very mysteriously
suggests now playing H6 and then just H3
yeah and then just very quietly going
back this really begs the question why
we're not playing h six immediately uh
but uh the argument is Peter that The
Rook is is badly placed on E2 yeah I I
understand but I I can play Rook e one
here and we have just played H6 and H3
with the inclusion of the the the sort
of the pointless bouncing yeah but I
forced you to find the good move Rook E2
to E1 maybe you find something else uh
put the position Knight G4 on the board
and after the move Rook E2 uh I think
that that that this is a very difficult
thing for a lot of viewers to understand
a lot of chess players to understand uh
I'm going to play a move for black queen
D7 you're going to play H3 and I'm going
to play Knight takes F2 and I a lot of
Masters will recoil like oh you
shouldn't have played Knight F2 then
people will say Bishop F2 King but why
not I've traded six for six I got a pawn
and a rook for the two minor pieces but
master love the two minor pieces versus
The Rook why J oh why would you have
played Knight F2 maybe as a youngster
you would have but now you lot of
experience I I I would actually just
assess this in terms of the middle game
in terms of the middle game you know how
effective are the Rooks here Black's
Rooks they're not they don't have any
open lines until you play F5 until you
play F5 but even then it is just a half
open Target and you can use that extra
minor piece in order to generate a point
to attack so I would definitely not in
the position that the players have night
G4 and again we're we're just going down
this little bit of a rabbit hole here
Rook E2 defends the pawn queen D7 H3 and
there was a time in my career where I
would have assessed Knight takes F2 as a
perfectly playable standard move keeping
the material I didn't like going
backwards you know you're forcing me to
retreat Rook takes F2 and again Joy you
you would make the assessment how are
the Rooks doing exactly I would always
assess like the okay the potential of
the Rooks two minor pieces and the two
and then I would also when it comes to
two minor pieces I would see whether
they have a point of attack because if
you do have a point of of attack or
Target so to speak then you can use that
extra piece because mind a rook one
piece Bishop night two pieces I can
attack you twice okay and then uh you
would get to a position like this and
your judgment would be I would like the
two pieces and hence I am not going to
play night takes F2 I'm going uh to
retreat when did you make what rating
were you when you kind of felt that you
made that that understanding became
obvious because uh for the longest time
I I didn't get
it you yeah I think it was many many
many years
ago well I mean were you an expert were
you a master were you an a player a
class player I would say around about
the
2200 okay that's a master so it took you
a while to get kind of get there but I
mean I I would say that that these
positions there are no hard and fast
rules you do have to assess them
individually like you have to look at
the capabilities of the Rooks and you
have to again look at whether your
pieces can coordinate very well um but
there there was a case like I think it
was in 2009 where I had the opportunity
to get three pieces for a queen it took
me 45 minutes to come to that decision
to take the three pieces take the three
pieces and it was only because you know
then I was like okay well how are my
three pieces going to work together and
then I was like great I've got it right
then let's go is this something every
Russian school boy learned in high
school that you the two minor pieces are
better until that very very last bit I
wanted to say I agree with like every
single word Yanka is saying and the only
bit of disagreement came at the very end
because I love I love the three pieces
against that that always appealed to me
greatly and that would have taken like
if it doesn't lose on the spot I pretty
much always take the pieces against the
queen but as for as for pieces against
Rook uh I think the most important thing
to remember is uh you do have to assess
it Case by
case Rook rook and the pawn against two
pieces very much depends on King safety
how active the man pierces is are there
files for the Rooks and so on uh here I
don't particularly like it I sort of
understand the argument because uh if we
could somehow let me let me get a good
scenario here for black try to get a
good scenar it's it's a bit take on e4
it's a bit difficult take with a pawn
double the Rooks yeah something like
this and then white just sort of fffs
about fffs about side for for
and then maybe it becomes interesting
because we will take on C now with the
Rooks doubled on the file we do not want
to be allowing the sacrifice so we'll
have to ruin our structure and then the
Knight perhaps will start getting aimed
at the king's side but obviously uh
instead of all that white will actually
uh stabilize on the king side here
somehow MH and alternatively if if you
imagine something like you know we get
here right this Knight gets put on H2
the bishop comes out to E3 your
counterplay dies a is a slow death on
the king side because like this is so
solid you will never really attack these
pieces and then eventually something
that Yanka said is also extremely true
it's very simply Two Against One MH you
you shouldn't really care what they're
called you just have more of them on the
board so they do more work uh and it
just it just doesn't work very well but
obviously there will be positions where
the opposite is true where the Rooks are
roaming free where y light pieces don't
have good squares to occupy and it will
be very unclear and in the time rookie 2
has been followed by a blitzed out D6 D5
by Anish so Anish had a very specific
idea in mind here all right well let's
get to that because D6 rookie to D5 you
said okay D6 D5 and uh how do you like
them apples JY are we taking or we
playing Bishop B5 because those those
are the Alternatives right if we take
you're going to recapture with the
bishop and then I need to follow up
maybe I I will 57 looks very I think
we're oh that normally I play Bishop A4
to C2 but I put my on3 apologies here
def already played Bishop takes D5 mhm
and I am assuming we're putting our
Knight on e4 are we not no now we no no
no don't do that one yes a show show us
that's terrible takes my queen is no
longer defended my Rook is no longer on
E1 this loses the queen her
highness uh I think is what time yeah
said your highness uh and if I take with
the Rook then I'm leaving F2 unprotected
Rook takes E4 uh Knight takes F2 whoops
and I'm toast so in this particular
position I I suppose I have to start
with H3 stop by driving that night back
from and again we have that same
discussion and I think we'll come to a
different conclusion but for very
concrete reasons though after H3 I think
we're very happily taking on F2 then
taking on C4 the D3 Pawn is hanging you
kind of have to take with the Knight
because of that and you get and this is
the one window of opportunity here while
the D1 Queen is unprotected and the pin
exists you get to play E5 E4 here if the
Knight has to go somewhere black
instantly gets a lot of freedom to play
in the center and this is a very very
different scenario to the one we were
discussing where black didn't really
have much play for the light pieces so
much so that the engine is suggesting
kind of bailing out here with giving
back
protecting the the queen on D1 meaning
that you cannot really play Rook E8
because suddenly after G takes C4 you're
back to be much worse so the engine goes
e takes F3 uh Bishop takes f8 it's a
very curious Engine line because after
Queen H4 he just goes King G1 and says
I'm I'm I'm even going to allow this and
I'm still going to sort of equalize with
white but it really doesn't hate
allowing all of the doesn't like
allowing all of this so okay the main
move currently as I see it on my screen
is a move like Queen C2 MH which looks a
bit odd but does a pretty good job of
further reinforcing protection of the F2
Square also Sid spping those E5 E4
tactics because the is longer on D1 and
now we are thinking of playing perhaps
Knight E4 next move so H2 H3 is a bit
rushed more sedate move Queen C2
prepping Knight E4 prepping H3 and
really taking a sting out of F2 uh a
sting out of uh these captures on the F2
absolutely thank you Peter uh going to
our remaining again for those of you who
are joining us we one more dud
completely untouched yes I was about to
say dudes uh was not feeling well that
game got scratched today postponed We
Believe till the free day we will uh
double check on that but uh um going to
the I wanted to say Lanier's game well
we have uh yeah NPI against lenia
Dominguez by the way breaking news I
can't believe it I'm looking at the
clock times are we sure there's not an
error on the board
lanir has more time than his OPP lir is
well prepared
I it's a very unusual sting that because
L yeah he's a great player but he's a
great thinker he loves time trouble and
how do you get into time trouble well
you consume a lot of time in the opening
and that's what he's uh he's noted for
but he is actually up on the clock let's
see how they got here it looks like it
came out of an English Yan indeed play
the English symmetrical
C5 and the Four Knights English with D5
also becoming more and more topical
these whole lines with G7 G6 now that's
a little bit off the beaten path I think
everybody castles here Knight E4 I think
the main move in this position by 2023
can be guessed in one try instead of
Knight E4 I'll give you one try H4 of
course it
is yes uh it seems like uh Alpha zero B
bent Larson was before his time Ben
played H4 practically every position and
suddenly H4 has been the go-to move
against the Kings Indian defense the
grunfeld defense everybody's playing H4
and including in this English but Knight
E4 Peter that is a little bit off the
track and C4 Queen C2 B5 I don't know
this early development of the queen side
uh seems either very ambitious or simply
Reckless I don't know or possibly none
of those two things the well it does
seem this is this is a rare line but I
think C4 is the prescribed reply here
actually I mean it's hanging you don't
particularly want to play six because
you do eventually want to develop this
bishop to G7 so you would like to
disconnect this Bishop from the C5 Pawn
so that you develop it there uh normally
very often uh this Pawn gets just
abandoned there is a bunch of lines in
the English where black just leaves it
there and plays for for compensation but
this is not a particularly great case
for that it's I think it's more often uh
things like that happen as as an example
in in some line in some line like this
you can definitely consider doing
something like Knight db4 and after
Castle just leaving it there because the
queen will get bounced around we will
get a lot of tempul later in the game by
attacking this queen and attacking it
again and again and again but knight4 is
rare and I think four is completely fine
and also knowing lenier if he has yeah I
just going to add to that because lenier
has had this position before with the
black pieces but he did not play C4 what
did he do he played and he beat ding Len
with the black pieces he played Queen
B6 yeah another another very logical
continuation here we don't want to give
it up just yet if you want to really go
after it you need to make some PR
awkward moves like Queen C2 and perhaps
Yan had some kind of an improvement
against Queen B6 in mind I'm not irely
sure what it is but seems very playable
but yeah C4 is definitely the machine's
first suggestion I'm less sure about B7
B5 uh because currently my screen says
even the immediate F7 F5 perhaps forcing
the Knight back to C3 and now this Pawn
is not hanging and we can continue
developing but one one thing one thing
we know about ler is if he's playing
quickly it is because he's looked at
this in depth then he is prepared yeah
so B3 uh reply from Yan Bishop G7 very
logic Bishop B2 Knight db4 interesting
that uh ler felt he needs to include
this this is not that obvious to me for
instance why you can't just uh do this
why he felt it was better for him to
have the Knight on B4 rather than on on
D5 in this position but once again we
trust him he works on chess and if he if
he thinks this is a better version it
probably just is castles Rook a B8 also
very much the best move according to the
engine and he is finally thinking about
A2 A3 because I I don't think it's the
best move according to to my screen but
it's still perfectly uh perfectly okay
for for both sides currently the best
suggestion of the engine is Bishop F5
I'm a bit curious about this because I
would instantly reply to it with Knight
H4 but the engine says I don't really
care about this
bishop wow just does this and apparently
the pawn on C4 let's say if you create
this isolani on C4 the queen doesn't
have squares you want to play Queen C2
here but then shockingly after Knight A5
I thought you were going to play Knight
D4 no the engine the engine takes it
very slowly the engine just puts the
Knight on F6 and says eventually my
queen will come to D6 there will be a
rook on B8 in in in in
times uh ahead and A3 is a target D2 is
potentially a Target I have a B3 Square
for The Rook it just says I mean around
equal but black is playing for Advantage
here not even Advantage a slight
Advantage black Bishop F5 is not the
kind of move that I would but uh good
thing for ler is that if he goes Knight
D5 he's not in a lot of trouble but the
engine does does say that after both
Rook A1 and also weirdly move G2 G4
which probably wouldn't have occurred to
me because because I wouldn't want to do
this to to my structure but apparently
this is good because Rook Rook C1 Rook F
E1 this not will have the very nice C5
Square wow I I mean I just see these
positions as an English maybe a little
bit of a Catalan player I haven't
sacrificed a pawn in the Catalan my
Bishop on G2 G2 is working and I'm going
to play Rook C1 I'm thinking forget
about Bishop F5 for a moment if you go
Knight D5 and I go Rook C1 I'm just
thinking boy I can see a really nice
weakness in front of me I think I think
this is why Bishop 5 is so critical
because here you start seeing the
outlines of pretty well defined white
Advantage it's not a huge one but I can
I ask why is this such a big Advantage
because I mean like Bishop will come to
A6 you'll overprotect Knight to C5
there's such a nice Square C5 is on yeah
that's thing on the in fact the engine
here dislikes this KN so much that its
best option currently is a very ugly
looking move Knight of6 just to try and
trade it and why doesn't trade yeah
white still goes Knight C5 goes D2 D4
and actually this really does look like
a Catlin now now I'm happy and it's not
a pleasant one it really isn't a
pleasant one exactly and I'm very happy
uh with white and again uh this just
that I'm just amazed that you can play
Knight A5 and just uh take this isolated
C4 pawn and say okay I'm I'm perfectly
happy we've gone through our list of
games we have actually missing a game
for those of you who are joining as late
these are our pairings but we're going
to cross out we're scratching the game
between Duda and Report yes and that is
because unfortunately y Kristoff Duda is
on well so these two will have their
games
postponed so whether uh the the game is
post replayed unfortunately we're for us
we don't know the future of Yan uh Duda
whether he'll continue the event is a
little bit awkward but uh illness uh I
just oh that's all we have for the
moment we'll get Tony or Chris post on
any updates that we receive
absolutely wow uh breaking news there's
always something extremely interesting
going on in the sinkfield Cubs uh the
the game of uh MBL I think it was let's
let's go back that was I I was finding
it very exciting please a plan that we
didn't really consider but the one that
I think mvl was pushed into slightly by
the way Wesley treated the position
because Wesley here instead of for now
keeping his options open he could
definitely play something like long
castles or H4 first which is what we
were discussing he's gone with Bishop H6
to which MV just replied by taking and
playing Queen B6 which might look like a
blunder of a full piece here for one
second because Queen just attacking both
the rook and the Knight nope King E7
King E7 does a perfect job for black in
fact white is suddenly completely lost
the B2 Pawn is still hanging and we're
also threatening Queen E3 check taking
away the final like just just to just to
illustrate Queen E3 check and then hello
oops I'm used to the poison Pawn
positions where you go Queen takes B2
and you get your queen trapped Queen G7
getting the queen trapped that away
that's not a good move so Wesley castled
and mvl castled uh in reply Rook H1
played and uh mvl is thinking here
honestly this look pretty pretty healthy
for black Rook H E1 a move designed to
prevent D6 D5 in the future why am I
putting why AR I playing the Tidy moves
King B1 and uh you know you have time
for that I don't know I tuck my king in
you know is it D5 ever a possibility or
is it just it's already playable I I
think the bigger question is what is
more use ful against d65 because uh when
a king compared to positions where the
Knight is on D7 and The Rook is on C8
we're under no particular pressure on
the queen side here black needs three
Tempe to to start creating anything and
the 65 is the major major idea here uh
and also I wonder if maybe in some
positions Wesley is looking at playing
Queen E3 and offering a queen trade but
I think I think the answer is no uh as
for the three moves I mentioned for
black yes D5 is playable here but in
terms of I think the more ambitious
approach here it would be something
along the lines of King B8 right
dreaming once again against three passes
right this might
be already very very unpleasant for
white agre with ideas of
uh takes Knight maybe just Rook takes C3
Rook takes C3 or we can even improve our
position by uh lifting one and bringing
the second one into the attack as you
can see the engine starts really really
disliking this obious no nobody's going
to spend two t playing H4 H5 and there's
no King on G8 right uh so honestly my
feeling is if I had to pick a side snap
decision I pick black here okay I prefer
black I suspect also The Rook coming to
E1 might have something to do with the
Knight maybe relocating to F1 and to E3
slow yeah getting the Knight yeah well
you mentioned it long ago the D5 Square
it's about the D5 Square we can control
the D5 Square life could be good like
another thing was mentioning in a
different setting but still afterward
taking B8 here you can go toward Z3 by a
different Square as well uh using the
fact that the Knight on F6 is hanging
and Knight G8 seemingly you know trying
to pick up pick up the KN on F5 now
Queen G7 is playable but now you you
just have to calculate like does my
queen get out I take a rook here it does
yeah take a rook but uh say you can take
the H7 p and a good
point you had me at ag7 fun I liked it
okay uh double edged a little bit uh
again the current position um if you
don't mind uh uh we we
outlined this is it and we mentioned it
10 times already and haven't put it on
the board once it's got to play what
happens what happens if D5 happens we
have to take we cannot allow D5 D4 that
would be very very bad black recaptures
with a knight you get the feeling you
have to take black probably takes with
the Rook to introduce the idea of Rook
HDA now we now our Knight on G3 is
actually finally on a good Square yes it
gets to E4 and the engine suggest this
is fairly balanced white is in no
particular trouble because we can Sol uh
solidify on the king Side by bringing
the Knight on C3 to C3 if needed we can
bring the queen back to E3 as well it
goes King B8 it says None of the jumps
on like 9 G5 looks ATT attractive for a
second but it says 9 D4 and we don't
need to worry and also you know moving
all of our pieces to the king side and
allowing black to play Rook C8 with this
mass of pieces aimed at our King doesn't
seem like it's the safest you know the
the recipe for Success so something like
Queen E3 U the end game is around equal
even Queen C7 the engine is suggesting
is around equal with positions like this
potentially arising out of it these
types of positions I personally always
think are slightly better for white yeah
because the bishop the bishop and is
just going to be slightly stronger than
this night but not very much the Bobby
Fisher ending we would call it this uh
uh rook and Bishop versus Rook at Knight
by the way uh lanir did toss in that
move Bishop F5 and as you said Peter
your knee-jerk reaction would be to play
Knight H4 if and it has been it has been
played yes yes and Bishop takes uh E4
Bishop takes E4 Knight D5 on the board
the players of our analysis is this
still are we still in theory at all I
think we must be we must be because
there were so very logical we're we're
not in theory in that game but in terms
of whether we're in Lena's Theory I'm we
could be because of the time uh
difference and how does the engine
assess this position just equal just
equal just equal it goes Knight F3
doesn't even take on C4 it goes Knight
F3 and the same idea sort of reappears
you can actually even go Knight A5 here
because provoking before and going back
back the engine views quite sorry no not
not actually back it goes ah this is the
point very nice what using the fact that
the bishop is not on G2 we're very
specifically playing Knight F6 here to
force it to this rather stupid square
and only
then we return to C6 and then we start
counter playay with A7 A5 and it says
something like D3 A5 with relative
equality
wow and how do they match up against
themselves
let's take a look at the stats and wait
for it yasa it's quite close not many
games but we've been seeing 31 draws and
27 draws amongst the others they haven't
really played each other that often only
12 times in classical chess uh uh
certainly they've been playing uh
batting heads uh online in all of those
incredible events and all the world
rapid and blitzers L obviously a world
blit Champion he won the the tournament
in aana the one year it was played
Without increment and he was just
destroying people on like 10 seconds
left and he would be he would win games
where he had 10 against 20 no increment
yeah he was just so much faster than
everybody else in the tournament it was
there was no under dirad tricks no no no
no no he was playing before the
computers even became computers he was
playing he was playing pretty cleanly
and just just was faster mechanically
than than everybody else in the field
was
awesome to watch uh for me I just find
it so strange uh this position that it's
not favorable for white because if I if
I were black i' would rather have my
pawns on B6 and C5 rather than being
Advanced and potentially a weakness on
C4 but evens is what the I'm guessing
I'm guessing if we had here time for
white to move the bishop away from we4
as we as we've seen it's becoming a
Target in some of these positions so
imagine we play Bishop G2 and black
plays A7
A6 actually still fine I thought this
might be now better for white after
Knight F3 but no even after wasting a
whole Tempo on A7 A6 it says we're not
in trouble I guess we're just
misunderstanding this position and this
is why what ianga said about this still
being Line's theory is I think very much
on point because I think he would have
taken a very strong grandm like lineer
still the move Bishop a five and the
correct assessment of the position this
leads to would have taken him some time
but he spent like two minutes on it so
ah that brings me to an in uh very
intriguing topic uh you you you you're
playing with the engines you you you
have a look at one of your favorite
positions you just want to make sure
that your prep is all nice and you just
installed a new engine and it tells you
that your prep is no good it's now even
a position that you've been playing
favorably for so
long what do you do when your chess
engine tells you your preparation only
gives you I'm very much used to having
preparation being
0.0 or whatever so long as you're happy
what I do is I actually switch roles so
I get the engine to play what I have
prepared okay and uh then I do know see
how it goes and if the position isn't
that easy for me to play against my own
repertoire I'm happy okay and in fact
these days again like this goes to show
I I don't think everyone needs to have a
supercomputer as well we have all these
like supercomputers in our phones and so
we can just get out the phone we can
test out our own preparation but I would
never ever Advocate that you test out
your own lines against the engine
because the engine is just going to
squash you but depressing exactly get
you play your opponent and have your the
engine play your lines uh Peter I'm
showing my clear Prejudice that the
pawns on B5 and C4 uh make me eager to
play White's position and the engine
laughs at me it you're the engine has
how do you say tweet your prejudices as
well what happens when something like
that happens and you get shocked well
you you get used to it but what Yanka is
saying is absolutely correct you you
have to either learn to leave with the
engine sort of disagreeing with your
person like you it doesn't care about
your feelings is what I'm trying yeah
whether they're hurt or otherwise right
it really doesn't care about your
feelings so you learn to live with it
and actually the the Life Hack That
Yanka just described should sounds very
very useful to me uh because that way
you you're much less depressed about
your chances because you see that like
you've made two normal moves against I
mean the engine says you've got no
Advantage with white and then you turn
it around you make two moves with black
you're suddenly seriously worse okay
okay okay this is not that easy not so
easy uh I wanted to turn our attention
is to the game between Ali Raza and
Anish because guess what we did see the
move rookie too Bishop takes yeah Queen
C2 and in this moment you might be
thinking okay I will just play a move
like Rook to E8 is black on each just re
refortify the pawn on E5 get ready to
meet move like H3 with a retreat Knight
F6 uhuh Anish said I'm doubling down I
played Knight G4 with purpose
I really do want to play Knight takes F2
what's your take on uh this move F7 F5
it's a big challenge now it looks good
it looks good whether it is good okay is
another matter but we' have to do a deep
dive into this position invate ask well
first of all what's going to happen if
you yeah exactly you read my mind well
here we go uh Knight takes F2 Rook takes
F2 we're gonna get Peter to bring way in
there with us uh at E4 immediately Peter
or do we do something it Tak on F2 and
then goes B5 uh in general yeah in
general it likes this idea of throwing
in B7 B5 somewhere very much because you
cannot really push E5 E4 so easily when
the bishop is still on C4 but once it
departs this diagonal e54 grows in
strength exponentially so it plays B5
here that was radar way I want to be
clear I was not going in that direction
54 you already have to actually return
material Machin says best line is to
enter this sorry no worries yeah and I
mean the line continues but wow it's
very playable for black so uh perhaps
you have to take on D5 here okay
apologies no worries but then there is a
weakness on D3 let's let's there
potentially a
make the
P I was actually enjoying this JY just
you can keep me in check let me help
Peter on this one uh Bishop takes D5
Queen takes D5 right yeah and now we're
now we are facing this E4 uh stuff
should I do you like Bishop A3 I kind of
like to throw that in right let's get
that into the board okay because I I am
going to encourage inviting before maybe
there's one was one rule in life that I
I try to abide by and that's always look
after the king so tuck your king away
I've lost quite a few games by not doing
that yeah so uh you like to take your
king away but then again now we're
talking about the two minor pieces
versus The Rook but now what my Rooks
are doing they're working they're just
going to pounce on the D3 Pawn exactly
Rook to d8 hit doubling up uh against
the D D3 Pawn if I provoke Knight
E1 uh it doesn't doesn't Inspire no but
you can can you simplify the position in
order just to get some clarity Bishop A3
again yeah Bishop A3 Bishop B2 something
like this I here's what I have in mind
is I I don't like the retreating move 91
so I'm actually on a completely
different uh
tangent C for the idea is if you take
then I was going to trade Queens with
Queen takes C4 and recapture with the
Knight and I was thinking that okay I've
got you know whatever I've got I'm going
to be a pawn uh I'm losing the D3 Pawn
but I'm kind of messing up the structure
a little there for for black but this
line uh that Anish is is playing is
showing to my mind a lot of ambition
we talked about that coming into Studio
like Anish um he plays along with it
this idea that he's this drawing Master
and that's so unfair but it is right
because he's fighting he's fighting very
hard and it seems to me with this whole
F5 concept that he's come with great
ambition with the I don't think I've
ever seen Anish like have a 15 move
draw and he's always fighting it out
always having these kind of very
critical battles and just so unfair that
he's got this reputation just because of
this one tournament candidates where he
had like three winning positions and he
drew Drew those winning positions we've
been looking at this position uh after
F7 F5 Peter and welcome back thank you
have you I apologize nothing to nothing
but uh H2 H3 has been our but Knight
takes F2 is worked out okay for black
it's fine I will also point out that the
engine suggests you can go Bishop takes
C4 Knight takes C4 best move and E5 E4
immediately this one sadly is uh a
little bit more equal I think this one
uh lends itself to uh simplifications uh
more than the other one actually D D4 F4
is already quite good for black but
after 91 uh regrettably for black you
have to go back white will probably get
rid of that
Troublesome Bishop right uh and uh
positions become very very interesting
here as well for instance black
continues ignoring the fact that the
pawn on e4 is sort of hanging the only
move here not to be worse here for white
is 9 D2 wow and the engine suggests this
is around equal but I will say that
Bishop takes E4 follow by4 is definitely
a very legitimate way to play apart from
Knight takes F2 so both of those are
open I'm not sure H3 in view of all that
I'm not sure H3 is the best move you
could spend a Tempo on Bishop B2 just to
bring more pieces into play perhaps hint
at playing D3 D4 in some positions to
stop right the black pieces eyeing our
F2 pawn and an idea I mentioned earlier
reintroduces itself here as well because
black really is very very interested in
getting this bishop away from from this
diagonal Bishop takes B5 E4 is trouble
for white maybe not a lot of trouble but
definitely you you suddenly have to be
very very careful but how how
like realistic is it to see moves like
B5 I wanted to come back to that because
I think and watching him in the rapid
and Blitz even which is normally not a
tournament where people show a lot of
very in-depth opening prep I think Anish
is it's not a novel idea but he is
definitely fighting for the the the
title of the best prepared player for
this particular tournament and it's a
bit inconclusive with him having uh
spent about I would say 20 minutes on
the clock including the increment
getting to this position but Knight G4
follow up by D5 follow up by F5 is so
specific right that I really wouldn't
rule out him actually knowing all this
and if he knows then he probably knows
B5 exists as well finding B5 over the
board is not impossible but is
definitely not easy but specifically in
the case of Anish would not Shock Me in
the slightest if this was still book and
he was just because the move order that
ala chose is not the most popular one
just took him some time to sort of
remember the exact page of his analysis
but Anish is incredibly well booked up
for me the move B7 B5 truly it really
wasn't on my uh radar and I I do find
that a remarkable move uh if we were to
just look at the most forcing lines
could you just take that away
from for us Peter H3 Knight takes F2
Rook takes F2 we're playing E5 E4 we're
taking on F2 first we're drawing the
king out yeah Bishop F2 King F2 and then
and then we play B5 as uh as I as
pointed out before B5 this is this is
best play if you don't play B5 here
you're probably at least a little bit
worse uh the second best move is I think
uh it's not significantly worse
according to the evaluation but I really
don't like this idea of taking and play
Queen D5 which the engine suggests is
still playable but you're selling
yourself short it feels like right you
you're giving up on the dream of
creating something immediate on the king
side so I like much more right and uh
Bishop D5 Queen D5 the engine says is
completely fine for black in fact it
actually goes down this rabbit hole and
suggests uh towards the end of that very
very long forested line we have with
Bishop C4 and Knight G5 it gives white a
slight Edge because of this move Knight
E6 eventually probably picking up the
pawn on C7 right how realistic any of
this isn't practical play I would not
want to to venture an opinion on that
right right wow uh that is really even
if white did get to that position they'd
be like I'm exchange
down like what's going on that line
right like I I purposefully did that
what what's going on uh we're getting to
that point of our broadcast where uh
we're going to be taking a break but we
did want to tell you before we go on
break that we have a very special guest
uh coming uh to to join uh uh
uh later in the show Brian is going is
going to be on board he's one of our
musical directors there at the World
Chess Hall of Fame have you been to some
of the concerts that hosted have been to
they're really brilliant they're very
good and you can see them on stream uh
you can go to the YouTube channel and uh
just do a World Chess Hall of Fame uh
music series And subscribe because it's
really definitely
worthwhile and again for those of you
who are join is late well Duda yeah we
do have some news um well the game
between y Kristoff Duda and Richard
report will not be happening today
because Yan Krist Duda is on well on
well and we will keep you updated with
more news as soon as we get it yeah we
just don't know how serious it is we're
hoping it's just going to cause a a
postponement in the
games well in my days when we had such
situations we just postponed them until
the free day so it's hopefully uh that
game forfeit that I mean that's the
alternative for SP that just so spoils
the tournament right a forfeit because
yes yeah but sometimes you know such is
the price you have to pay you must
sacrifice your health El thises uh do
occur uh Peter in your uh tournament
experience I mean we both played in
tournaments where people unfortunately
have fallen out of the event but mainly
they got rescheduled the games yeah
obviously you hope that it's nothing uh
too serious and then you can use the
free day to play to play the one game
you miss and if it is then yeah the
choices become very uh difficult because
playing a tournament which you have
defaulted on one or maybe even two games
it becomes uh an exercise in futility to
to a large degree and it's really not
doing any good to the field either
because some people get a free point and
some don't so perhap perhaps at that
point the question of just completely
withdrawing starts becoming a much more
serious option we really hope none of
this will will need to be discussed and
we we wish younger stuff the the uh
speediest recovery of course sadly uh I
remember here in this year's Karen's cup
one of the ladies had to drop out and it
was Alexandria Alexandria had
defeated uh and her and they took away
her point and Alexandria was Furious I I
won when she was healthy I I want my
whole point but sorry Alexandria she was
very upset about it but we did have a a
withdrawal during the Ken cup uh that
marred uh that uh fantastic event uh I
was going to say uh where's the action
Peter let's return to our game of uh the
two local local matadors as laal Matador
they call it in German press yeah uh the
game between lean Ronan and Fabiano
Carana and eventually we got the
position very close to the one I was
describing v a completely different move
order uh Bishop coming to G3 after D4 uh
fabit tsuk and then gave this check on
before which I thought was an
interesting little touch because uh
Knight C3 is playable but I think very
logical move here is Bishop D2 because I
think white would very much welcome the
idea of these Bishops coming off the
board and then developing this Knight
not to D2 but to C3 and then eventually
let's just briefly I want to show you
something structurally the issue for
black here is that if you imagine this
bishop and let's say this Knight getting
traded off it's not that bad right but
white will very often immediately play
H2 H3 to make sure it doesn't happen and
then you don't really have any work for
this bishop of the foreseeable future
and this type of structure with uh black
not having the bishop pair I think is
very nice for white it's not spectacular
but you always always pick white here
because of the uh Center but after
Bishop D2 of course black is not
compliant here Black Goes A7 A5 and says
you want to trade this bishop do
activate my Rook please take away your
own C3 Square from your knight this is
Unthinkable you're instantly slightly
worse of course this wasn't played uh
Leon castled Fabi also castled and then
the maneuver I was harping on about for
like half an
hour G finally did happened the bishop
started on its way uh towards the G3
Square black put the Knight on uh the B5
Square the bishop got chased away to put
the Knight on C3 eventually it's not
there yet but I'm pretty sure eventually
it will be on C3 and this is the current
position where white still has the same
trumps that we were
discussing the very nice Pawn Center uh
Knights generally want to be on C3 and
F3 I think the reason he hasn't played
Knight C3 yet if you look here is I
think it would have invited Bishop G4
right attacking the uh the F3 Knight and
indirectly the pawn on D4 so after Rook
E1 if left goes Bishop G4 here you can
play Knight bg2 and connect your Knights
and sort of solve this problem uh but
ideally it will go to C3 but black now
with the inclusion of A5 and A3 has
potential counterplay let's say after
Knight C3 I can play A4 exactly put the
bishop on B3 perhaps play Knight C4 put
some pressure on the B2 Pawn nice and
this is a picturesque looking Center but
what do you do with it right whereas for
black there is I think pretty pretty
clear cut count to play on the queen
side well Bish yeah Bishop B3 Knight C4
makes a very compelling argument which
kind of I also wanted to say is why
wasn't Fabby anxious to play A4 because
you are giving your opponent the
possibility of playing A3 A4 or even B2
B3 but instead of Bishop E6 like why
didn't he just start with the move A4 I
think it's it's not going to be taken
away I don't think A3 A4 is such a great
idea because let's say we play A4 here
for white I think it just creates a
Target because this bishop will be on
before before instantly and in all of
your end games you will be really
worried about this Pawn because you
don't have a light Square bishop and if
you imagine in some position black
eventually attacking it attacking it
with anything else it might just fall
off so uh if in white shoes if you're
choosing which Square to give up B3 or
B4 I think you'd much rather give up the
the B3 square and Fabi actually played
Knight bd2 I kept on saying the Knight
belongs on C3 but he he feels that
giving up the B3 square is very
important so he's keeping it under
control for now the big question there
for white what is the plan I mean you
got to have an idea of improvements well
first of all the scheme of development
you know I'm assuming Queen C2 Rook D1
H3 Bishop G3 but then then we've put all
of our pieces nicely but are we going
side are we going to the center this is
the issue with the structure where the
pawns on C6 and F6 they create this kind
of a a barrier to our advance in the
center and it's not quite clear how
we're going to break through I thought
maybe what what you're describing a kind
of a plan where which involves putting
the queen on C2 Rook ad D1 H3 Bishop G3
for sure it's really not doing anything
on H4 at all right but then what to do
another way to go would be perhaps to do
something like let me try the arrows
this one goes here this one goes here
nice then it goes here good this one
goes here and then maybe you hope to
play D4 D5 at some point but D5 is
incredibly well
fortified so I am not not sure we we can
start hinting at d45 maybe in some
positions but I don't know if we're
actually ever lending it against an
opponent who is aware of what's going on
and uh Leon will be aware uh I think
this is probably just completely fine
for black to be honest yeah and I I see
these positions and I see black also
kind of doing a carp off shuffle he goes
Queen D7 King h8 moves his Bishops out
of the way puts them on F7 and f8 and
maybe even all the way back G
another way to go and the way to go I
like very much I think this Rook belongs
on E8 yeah and then this bishop can drop
back to f8 to and this one to f s maybe
as well right to uh generate some
pressure against the White Center nice
thank you Peter we have reached that
point in our show we're going to go on
break but before we do we always check
in uh with our friends at Q Boutique
stl.com to see what they have as a
special and here it is the 2023 Grand
chest t t-shirt to show off your support
for the 2023 Grand chest tour with this
amazing t-shirt the blend of polyester
and cotton will keep you comfortable in
the back features the tournament
locations for the grand chest tour
Bucharest Warsaw Zagreb and St Louis
they are available at Q Boutique stl.com
and don't forget we are running a
holidays special instead of our usual 5%
family discount no sir
20% on all of our uh shopping items so
do your holiday shopping at qbt stl.com
and we will take a break and be back
with more coverage of round two of the
sink spell cup see you
[Music]
shortly
uh so today's Community Day all the
parents of the US Championship are going
to schools around St Louis and you know
teaching kids um openings and games uh
tactics doing some fun stuff like hand
and brain some simos and uh we just
finished our first class and it was
really fun I see kids taking the um
skills that they're learning in chess
whether that be critical thinking
decision-making skills planning skills
and I see them applying that throughout
the rest of their school day whether
it's in class or sports or even just how
they interact with one another and with
their teachers I play with my auntie
myom my sisters sometimes on the
weekends like we go to the park and we
play they be begging me to teach them I
like show them like new stuff like new
openings I show them that and so I'm
trying to see them get better and try to
beat me what I like about Chess is just
trying to have fun and learn new things
and maybe I'll get more into it and
it'll maybe be my SCH career I heard
that if you play chess you make bad
decisions in life so I always want to
make bad decisions in life I can tell
you that they've engaged more in uh
critical thinking they are looking
analytically at moves and trying to
think ahead I like the um complexity of
Chess how you have to think about every
single move you make like every move you
make whether it's going to put your king
in check whether it's going to put put
your anything in danger whether it's
just a move that you make everything
counts in the long run I like um how it
makes me use my critical thinking makes
me look at the whole board I think it's
teaching them to be persistent you know
we have a lot of students who it takes
them like it may take a few weeks or
even months in chess club to master a
particular strategy or skill um and what
I think that teaches kids is even if
they don't get it the first time around
or even if it's difficult the first time
around um it's worth sticking to it well
one thing's for certain without the St
Louis chess club we would not have chess
instructors because I don't know if you
all know this but there is a critical
shortage of teachers and Educators and
especially those in areas that are not
core content area and because of the St
Louis chess club collaboration we have
people who come in here working with
students who want to work with them
today with the experience of The
Grandmaster community outreach day I
came up and I'm like well what's a
grandm and they like oh you don't know
what a grandm is and they were able to
explain that and they recognize the
importance and the seriousness I mean
it's a sport it's a profession and so
they're able to see things outside of
the sports that we typically promote in
school makes me feel good because like
learning stuff like this will help me
learn help me build my problem solving
skills help me build strategy and like
you know helping my brain
[Music]
hello I'm women's Grand Master bjan I
will be creating content for Grand chest
stour follow us on social media and
catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping around schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chess in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr J singfield
and Rex
singfield I would say that St luia Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it send a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
AF flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess's intrigued people around the
world for nearly 1,500 years stop by and
learn about the impact of Chess from our
three floors showcasing the art culture
and history of the game the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's Grand Master
R to janova I will take you behind the
scenes of the grand chest tour follow us
on social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr jeie Karen singfield and
Rex singfield the St Louis chess club is
a nonprofit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken's cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also to include
over 2,000 chess lectures for anyone to
enjoy become a member and enjoy perks
such as free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chest
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
family-friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess
a partnership with the St Louis Police
Department looking to improve
relationships between atrisk kids and
police officers in the St Louis area
with over 600 students playing chess
over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Genie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St lisess club.org
[Music]
seducation hello chess fans I'm
Anastasia Carlovich women Grandmaster
and I'm here in St Louis to bring more
insights from the grand chest tour
please follow us on social media of St
Louis chair club and Grand chest
[Music]
tour welcome back to the second round of
the sinkfield cup and we have a very
special guest here with us musical
director and creative in Residence Brian
Owens pleased to have you you here on I
know everybody's like who is this guy no
no no no you've been on before Brian you
were the guy who did the Bobby Fisher
song I was there yeah I had a beard
didn't know I looked like a totally
different person you did but you but for
me that was one of the most creative
songs I've ever heard in my life no no
that was absolutely extraordinary every
time I try to create a song I can't do
anything every time I tried
to we're all in you managed to link the
two right
I think there are a lot of correlations
between chess and music that I found
over the years and specifically since I
started working at the World Chess Hall
of Fame I mean they're both Universal
languages they both you know have a you
it requires both creative uh and you
know a certain level of intelligence to
do both of them and so I mean I I have a
deep appreciation for chess though I'm
not a great chess player what I'm
finding is a lot of the folks who play
our music series they are chess players
yeah it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
yeah yeah yeah how cool is that and
recently we had coming to St Louis the
musical chess which I went it was so
good it was it was magical the nights
were fantastic yeah and I went into it
you know I've been going to the mun a
long time it was actually the best show
that I've seen at the mun wow in all my
in all my years of coming and um I go
every year on a date with my choir
teacher from high school really yeah and
so she was said well let's go see chess
and we went to go see it and we were
both kind of like we'll see what happens
and by the end we're like this is
probably the best music we've seen here
yeah yeah the story Line's great and and
the music is great I love the song
Anthem just this expression of of
country and it's really cool man I like
it One Night in Bangkok man yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I was just as we were
coming on show I was just saying to
Brian that I actually was in Morano in
1980 and my guy Victor kcho I was
working with Victor kchoi and in the bar
uh I spent you know 3 hours talking to a
guy who was doing a musical on chest I
just thought it was the dumbest idea I
ever heard in my life I mean you know
imagine a business venture Brian I say
come Brian I need you to do a musical on
chess you go to a tournament like this
silence silence no talk no talking no no
talking a lot it's in the rules you
can't talk till the end of the night and
you find out that it's Tim Rice exactly
you just casually Dro that man know Tim
Rice I was like wait a minute Andrew
Lloyd Weber Jesus
Superstar I can't believe we tried to
sabotage one of the greatest musical of
all
time and what about Chess no l out of
principle you should have been like yeah
yeah that's good that's good you got
this what's coming up um at the World
Chess Hall of Fame in the musical series
we got a great season next year with a
lot of uh you know locally based talent
that you know has a world renown and
Clan and we're really excited about that
really excited about the diversity that
we're bringing into the Hall of Fame and
the chess really excited about the Gayla
this year myself CU myself and Brian
Woods who's the other musical director
we're going to be hosting and again I
think you know the the world has now
come to St Louis for chess right um but
I think we forget that you know a lot of
the music that's in the world came from
stou Lou and so now being able to make
that correlation of Excellence on the
campus of world just Hall of Fame which
we feel like is is a place of Excellence
I think it's really cool yeah well St
Louis the home of the Blues but you also
you don't just create perform
sometimes I'm tell you you're great
let's take a look look at Brian per me
[Music]
oh can you
make broken
heart how can you stop the rain from
falling
down tell
me can you
stop I got to say Brian that bearded
look is very very different from Studio
shout out to Al Green 1972 that's why we
did that cuz it was the same year as the
spasky Fisher so that's why we um did
that song and uh Ryan so tell us about
your role as a music director and
creative in residence for the World
Chess Hall of Fame like yeah like I was
saying ear I love what I get to do I get
to find these correlations between the
world of Chess and the world of Music we
try to help a lot of young creatives
with this idea of strategizing their
lives strategizing their careers and
chess is a perfect backdrop for that um
and again just the way we're we're
getting to integrate a lot more
diversity into people who are sometimes
coming to the campus for the first time
through the music series but then you
know are able to find find out all of
the other many wonderful things that we
offer at the chess club and you know
through the Galleries at the hall of
fame so it's really cool you mentioned
the wild Chess Hall of Fame music series
what makes it so special I think what
makes it special is the level of
Excellence right the and the place that
we're providing for folks not only who
are in St Louis but from around the
world to come um be treated with with
the respect that their talent deserves
and for audiences to be up close and
personally intimate it's like like the
chess tournaments that you have right
like you get you get to be almost like
you're you're there with them in the
game and I think you know from a
creative standpoint it's really cool for
audience to get that experience well the
intimacy between the musician and the
audience is right there it's fantastic
and uh I when I go to the uh series uh
the ones that I've gone through uh quite
a number of people from Symphony uh
perform as well AB it's great well I
mean and just like you know you know the
World Chess Hall of Fame and the in the
chess club has brought so many amazing
talented chess ambassadors to to the
city who now call the city home and I
think the same is true for musicians and
and active artists and creatives in our
city I mean they they perform all over
the world so to get them in a room of 75
of our closest friends right cuz that's
what it feels like too right yeah and to
to to play music at the highest level to
play original music that they that they
made it's special yeah and uh your Cur
mcing strategy across the board on
December 2nd what can we look forward
to you got to get your tickets
ticket it's it's going to be it's going
to be a lot of fun with myself and Brian
Woods and I mean just celebrating the
the the tenure of of this great
organization in the community the work
that's been done uh scholastically with
chess and what we hope to do moving
forward with with music and and bridging
those things and marrying them together
I think this year's Gayla is going to
really shine beautiful light on that and
this is the Gayla coming up it's our big
fundraiser it's our annual fundraiser
strategy cost board Marina will be there
of course as a special guest and that
all take place December 2nd and we're
going to combine also the closing
ceremony so we're going to get a lot of
the chess Grand Masters uh with this the
other Brian I wanted to put it like that
the other Brian that uh works at the
World Chess Hall of Fame the music
series he was telling me about getting a
performer and was crazy the performer
was going to New York and and it was
like there was only one date that he
could perform in St Louis and he said
book me book me I want it it was like
the musicians now want to meet the chess
players too right because he plays chess
he was from Russia yeah uh
yeah petroi uh they had done so never
mind sorry but yeah he's a really good
musician it was really great it was
really great and
I think that's cool that the musicians
want to come and be a part of the chess
scene as well but if you look at if you
look at the exhibit that that we have
now I mean you see so many musicians who
you know back in the day you you know
Neil Diamond on the cover of a magazine
he's playing chess or Ray Charles was
apparently an amazing not just Avid
chess but a really good chess player so
I I I don't think that we we can look at
the and and see some kind of cognitive
distance but it's like it's really not
it actually makes a lot of sense for
people who are high level musicians and
creatives to also be lovers and engag in
chess yours truly not not that
number yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah when I
can beat my 5-year-old daughter then I'm
like good I'm good but I remember Ray
Charles with a braille set Brian thank
you so much
for it's brilliant I'm looking forward
to the Gaya night it's going to be
absolutely I may make you sing with me
no don't you
dare we have people leaving the show
early this gentleman has a fine
voice uh we're gonna take a look at our
standings right
now as up to round one and there you can
see that after yesterday's very peaceful
day not a single person is in the lead
instead we have 10 players and all on
half a point and when it comes to the
pairings well today's pairings well they
are incredible and as always Nashi plays
off against Dominguez and you just saw
the game between Yan Kristoff Duda and
Richard rort be grayed out and that is
because Yan Krish Duda is on well we
will update you with news on that as
soon as we get it so that game has
either been postponed and we definitely
wish Duda a speedy recovery absolutely
and uh we're back to the playing Hall
where we see the players deep in
concentration we have four games
underway Peter uh tell us where the
action is I think we should return uh at
first to to this game betweena fi and
Nish giri where uh H3 has actually been
played I was arguing that perhaps white
could wait for a move but uh after I
think a reasonably lengthy pause uh
decided to force the action here to ask
Kish what what he wants to do with this
night on G4 and anus chose the second of
the two options which are entirely
playable Knight takes F2 as we've
discussed at length
is a decent move but Bishop takes C4
arguably maybe is even a slightly better
one and the path to equality for white
here is somewhat narrow because
currently my engine is saying this isn't
bad for white but honestly I'd be very
scared because if you if you allow Rook
A8 and PN takes D3 this Rook is gone you
can forget about this Rook So eventually
it will get picked up and your PA on D3
is very weak you constantly have to
watch out for E5 E4 and if you don't
control these things properly your your
king side will get blasted open and you
will lose currently it says this is fine
because Rook ad8 uh it actually gives up
on D3 but it plans I suspect to uh try
and capture this Rook on D3 after Knight
D5 The Rook currently has no squares and
honestly to my shock because there's for
instance Rook D1 here I wouldn't at all
be like immediately uh sure that this is
bad for black but this is apparently
already pushing it in White's Direction
probably because Knight E1 is very
and then king2 will actually capture
this Rook because we cannot we cannot
open up squares for it but these are all
very high level calculations the more
natural move is to take on C4 with a
knight and by the way Ali Raza has been
thinking for a good 20 minutes because
capturing on with the Knight is is what
we want to do Peter absolutely but he
realizes of course black isn't doing
this with the intention of now dropping
anything back abandoning abandoning the5
E4 we can Absol E4 comes in and now your
choices are quite limited uh a very
naive play like taking the Knight taking
the pawn you're instantly pretty much
lost to to this this looks completely
lost we are getting M it for just one
Pawn this is unplayable we're getting
made it for one Pawn Yeah doesn't sound
like a fair deal abely it doesn't you
you can go in here and this is honestly
a bit shocking just what kinds of
positions engine defends the engine
suggest this is actually better because
you get to meet F takes G2 with Bishop
E3 and when the and when the queen comes
to H4 we just take this pawn and we
somehow survive but I don't think
anybody plays this one position we're
getting for unless unless somehow that's
what you end unless unless everything
else loses I think right and the move
that probably does equalize reasonably
comfortably for the given value of
comfortably is this move Knight E1 now
everything is secure the Knight finally
has to go back it needs to be taken off
the board to be able to eventually take
on e4 as we say all this Knight has
finally taken on C4 so we headed in this
direction I'm sure right Bishop G5 and
after something like H6 as we've
discussed in this position the only move
that equalizes is a move 92 not obvious
not obvious now with the night2 we're
finally threatening to take on e4 and
recapture with the Knight covering the
F2 Square so Knight to D2 you know they
say in chess that the hardest moves to
find are the backward moves yeah nobody
wants to retreat exactly and we I'm
99.9% sure e54 will happen as soon as an
gets back to the board I'm sure the only
reason it's not on the board yet is that
he's just not there I see the clock
times are decisively in favor of uh only
30 minutes Jo for ear Razer so he's been
taking his time but the position is very
complicated and again it's one of those
positions where the price of an error is
going to be quite costly E5 E4 automatic
and uh I I would think so yeah I would
think so so this is a very sharp
position another game that is uh going
very much along the lines that we were
uh discussing is the game between Yan
pishi and uh ler Dominguez uh we talked
about this position at length suggesting
that it's Maybe not immediately obvious
why black is doing fine but black is
doing fine and in fact after uh ler also
found Knight A5 and Yan played Rook A1
Knight F6 and Bishop G2 for a while
there the engine was actually suggesting
black is significantly better after Rook
B3 but then it drops then it drops
just goes back to F3 we do lose the A3
Pawn but then after Rook A1 we have a
decent amount of counterplay against all
of this awkward placed pieces and C4 is
weak A7 is weak it's probably closer to
a draw than to anything else uh laner
preferred Queen D6 the Knight still came
back to F3 and he actually catched this
in he took on B1 and uh took on A3
here black is clearly completely fine
the question is whether you can actually
be seriously better my suspicion is the
answer is no no because still the night5
is not an oil painting and after
something like currently I very much
like this approach just playing Knight
E5 attacking the pawn on C4 and then
just offering this queen trade and
saying recognize this Catan motives look
at my beautiful Bishop look at my Rook
on the open file look at this look at
this idiot on A5 that does nothing yeah
and yeah it's very difficult to imagine
white actually loses this right but
black is a reasonably healthy porn up
for for the moment so no reason to be
upset either MH remarkable I you'd
almost start to favor white if you could
get in a a a move or two uh a game I
must say that uh I found fascinating was
the game between Wesley so and mvl that
was that uh nidorf Sicilian that looked
like uh pieces misplaced Knight on G3
Bishop on D3 uh we did see D5 they they
followed your analysis Peter to here but
not not from that moment onwards uh we
were making the argument here for
recapturing with the Rook because it
allows the other Rook to come into the
game and V went with I think the
slightly more conservative to capture
with the bishop uh Wesley played bishop4
offering this trade it was possible to
accept it the engine suggested trading
on e4 and then immediately trading one
pair of Rooks and bringing the other one
in is fine but Knight D4 is a very
understandable response as well King B1
Bishop
B6 it feels like black is making more of
the running here the KN on D4 is a very
nice looking piece you pretty much never
want to play something like C2 C3
because you immediately have to start
worrying about getting mated Maybe not
immediately but in the reasonably near
future uh so uh Wesley played Bishop D3
attacking the pawn on E5 Queen C7
knight2 has been played and mvl
recaptured on
E2 this is fairly equal the one uh thing
that perhaps unbalances these types of
positions is the Pawn on E5 sometimes
becomes a Target right let's say Rook
takes E2 and a very illustrative line is
shown by the computer here after King B8
white goes Queen G7 and suddenly it's
impossible to defend it but you do have
e54 Follow by taking on H2 can you just
pile up for instance on the pile up like
a
rook but then I'll play I think I think
if I play F6 here it will be much much
harder G yeah four there will be some
jumps okay yeah there will be some jumps
but yeah outside of trying to put some
pressure on the E5 Pawn there is really
nothing that would suggest white is even
remotely better so um this is probably
quite balanced if we continue the line
of the queen G7 I suspect something like
this happens and then white probably
gives this check from five and it's very
very level mhm uh so this one after a
very very promising start where by move
12 we thought this is a very unusual
very very unbalanced position with
pieces in very strange spots uh with a
lot of Trades this is now looking like a
perfectly uh legitimate Sicilian of some
description this guys I have to say this
is what happened to his in day one of uh
round one the level of accuracy of the
players was just so extraordinarily High
the imbalances and the position all got
ironed out and that was why we saw five
draws in the first uh round of play that
looks like another one of those games
that you know just great accuracy uh
it's a little frustrating for us as
commentators because we can say aha
blunder you know a player is winning but
on the other hand obviously you you you
can't really criticize very well played
games and this one is is another one
which seems quite finely balanced
although I will say I was a bit
surprised both by the move and also by
the reaction of my screen to it because
after KN bg2 we left it here with Fabby
choosing to develop the KN 2 G2 to
control both the B3 B3 and the C C4
square and Leon instantly traded the
pair of uh the pair of knights here on
on C4 and the engine actually disagrees
with this quite a bit uh which I thought
was interesting and perhaps instructive
if we if we want to think about it
because because it seems logical this KN
on B6 doesn't really look like it does
very much exactly but but I think the
bigger uh Factor here
is white really doesn't know what to do
with the second Knight here as well the
superus Knight yes exactly the concept
of the superflous Knight here I think
it's more important for white to offload
one pair of knights here here than it is
for black because here as you can see
both the move A5 A4 which is very
logical and the old plan of like going
Rook E8 Bishop f8 Queen D7 uh the was
suggesting there is not a single problem
to to be seen anywhere for black after
Knight C4 it jumps into a a reasonably
big lead it suggests that uh this
position after Bishop
G3 it's not panic stations yet for black
but it definitely is uh now
significantly more pleasant to play for
white is the idea D5 I I would very much
like to at least consider playing D4 D5
here now that once again leevon decided
to just complete ignore it not react to
uh the fact that the pawn on C7 here is
hanging it might not work out all that
great but you can see like right yeah
some position like this if black doesn't
have a very good reaction straight away
you can see uh even even after the
correct
moves like we get here and then black is
slow to establish some sort of
counterplay and these bishops get traded
and white let me let me make a bad move
somewhere Bishop G6 yeah yeah I don't
know
something we get here apparently even
this is fine but I would be very worried
here with black because I would feel
that most end games are really risky
good night vers and uh in Middle games
as well my counterplay probably is
connected with Rook C8 C4 but that
leaves the king side unattended and if
you can imagine white let's say you you
make a couple of waiting moves here and
I get my Rook over to F3 and it starts
feeling like I might be able to organize
something on the king side the engine
while I say all these words just laugh
just laughing I think you disregard the
engine because this looks scary as
anything you know you can see the Knight
coming into F5 um I mean as human beings
we have our prejudices and we've lost
enough of the good good night versus bad
Bishop endings that we want to avoid
them exactly and also you have to
remember two humans are playing the game
of chess current position though I hear
everything you said about the superus
knights and stuff like that but from
Black's point of view he just played the
move A5 A4 maybe he's looking at Rook A5
Rook B5 this this Rook lift uh trying to
get it over to B5 is very sensible I
would still very much like to actually
do something in the center along the
lines of rukie bish Buffet just to
sidestep all the play that we've just
described right uh and it's also a very
interesting uh dilemma for Fabby because
you can definitely Shuffle here you you
have a lot of improving moves you can
play H3 you can play Rook C3 Queen C2 I
don't know think about maybe doubling on
the E file and preparing E5 or something
and there is also this immediate option
of playing D4 D5 so he is weighing it
but I think we have to go back to ala's
game because ala didn't play Knight E1
he he actually he actually took on e4 we
we expected E4 to happen and it did
happen and we expected Knight E1 yeah
and ala more or less instantly replied
to it with d takes E4 and now now after
F takes E4
it seems like he actually needs to play
these moves mhm or he is in tremendous
amount of
trouble uh and this appears to actually
equalize looking at my screen but I
would not be confident of that at all if
I had to play them over the board if if
we disregard the computer I mean how
easy is it to hold it so um let's let's
take ftes G2 and let's just uh move by
move I think okay so yeah Bishop E3 is a
force because there's too much pressure
on F2 so that's you need to pay
attention exctly and then you take on G2
and the big issue for black here is this
Knight on C6 is just completely
incapable of joining the attack quickly
enough like you need it already on G6
it'll take you two moves by that point
uh White will will actually consolidate
right uh if if ala sort of correctly
recognizes that this is fine it's very
very impressive and there's also moves
like Queen F6 which maintain uh maintain
pressure once again B B3 three I mean
four this is always the best move right
and then there is Knight B4 oh now
that's a kick and you you actually
seemingly have to allow Knight D3 as
well because you cannot really put the
queen on the D file allowing Rook takes
Rook ad d8 with Tempo this is maybe
still salvageable but very risky right
so the engine goes either Queen B2 or
queen C1 actually allowing the Knight to
land on D3 and and says this is still
fine
and that's
I don't know how to react to that
right yeah I guess the Knight can't
maintain itself on D3 I guess that's the
big yeah I I think that's that's the
point that uh that the engine is making
there Queen B2 KN D3 it goes Queen C2
and if we go let's say Rook ad d8 uh it
goes Rook D1 and starts suggesting we're
now ahead yeah because it's just not
stable enough have to overcome every
single Prejudice that we have as a CH
player you know to with the temp you
know allow allow all
thise allow your king to be opened up
allow the Knight to come into B4
attacking the queen at Tempo then it
comes into D3 at Tempo and it's like
come on welcoming the pond to the G2
Square perhaps just just to briefly
perhaps clarify we seem to be blundering
a night here but the Queen x-raying the
pawn on C3 makes this move possible so I
just wanted to to put this on the record
oh my gosh so uh I mean it it really is
a a fierce battle uh going on here and
you know I'm looking at the position
Peter with the pawn on F4 and I I
desperately want to look at the lines
with Knight takes F2 and F takes E4 but
the engine's not suggesting any of this
stuff this is uh oh my God please like
Rook F2 apparently is playable because
after Rook F2 F4 you can still play
Bishop E3 here everything else loses uh
because if you take on e4 que D1 that
was the one I wanted que D1 check uh
wins on the spot but Bishop B3 is uh
still somehow fine because in this
position you have Rook A1 very very
importantly using the pin along the
F1 I was so happy I was a pawn up and uh
let me let me ruin your day some more do
it this apparently is even even cleaner
just
go ahead give me your wor yeah giving
you the entire the entire choice of
takes age
three check exactly and you are now
supposedly slightly worse because it has
no squares I can I can put it back on
yeah but now I will now I will be taking
it now I will be taking it and then Rook
takes F5 and the king is the king is
reasonably safe on H2 and it it makes
some precise I'm sure you you still have
to play precisely but would you would
you like instinctively say the king is
I think I think I would would be making
an argument that this well without the
H3 Pawn you know you're always aware
that something could go wrong but Bishop
to D2 yeah something like Bishop because
my my first s was I very much wanted to
play Queen G3 but then unfortunately I'm
one them for sure because this is very
annoying where it goes wrong yeah so so
you play something like Bishop G2 you
want this Knight here you want to BR The
Rook in the king will drop back and I
think if we've learned something the
most famous line where black takes on F2
and gives up the two pieces for The Rook
is comes from the open Spanish yes and
in those
positions I'm so bad with with English
names for openings that should not be
consulted on
this we recently learned that everything
was the morphe defense the morphe
defense yes exactly but my point was in
those positions and if we uh while Anish
is still considering his options let's
not be uh showing talking about things
that perhaps our viewers uh don't know
so the most the most famous line where
this happens is in the open is is here
how does so C3 yeah Bishop C Bishop C5
Knight B2 castles Bishop C2 Knight F2
Rook F2 and F6 for instance this is a
this has been known for 70 years 80
years this is a very very uh align with
very very long standing and the current
main line is this I believe yeah and if
we've learned something from this is
that
the pieces are very good at defending
this King you can take quite a lot of
Liberties and black doesn't actually
give mate almost anywhere it's just that
in this particular line the central
pawns are very nice black has two
instead of one as in the game that we're
discussing Anish will only have one and
there is two here but the pieces around
this King they do their job very very
well so I think if we return to our game
and by the way to our audience the
textbook example of that position that
Peter's talking about is the game
between vasel smav versus Sammy rashki
that was like one of the great Classics
absolutely yeah but uh if we return to
here uh Anish thinking I think indicates
to me that he is very seriously choosing
between F4 and Knight F2 yeah because F4
is a very obvious move it's there uh but
Knight F2 is is also playable and yeah
sadly for Anish it seems like with
precise play neither of those two things
actually win if you don't mind I'm still
I'm still in awe of Knight F2 H okay
Knight F2 F takes E4 takes F5 you two
Joy you're like no I I was laughing at
the this line this particular that white
just calmly goes after Knight takes F2
your worst the E takes F5 give me your
check further further depressing news
about this position we count the best
move in this position no no no no no no
no I'm I'm going to continue
disappointing you and making you
disbelieve everything you know about
life I'm allowing Queen H1 check no yes
get out of here yes apparently it's not
me you know he's just a messenger will
US shoot him because this is actually
quite Pleasant for black if King H2
Knight takes E3 you are legitimately
worse with white You've Won back the
pawn the best move here the best move
here is Bishop B3 and this is holdable
but once again this is Pleasant for
white can you wi win the pawn back
immediately maybe we're not better but
we're definitely not wor I was thinking
include Rook E8 and then take on F5 and
you're you're kind of happy I suppose
with with with black aren't you it's
it's still very very level because it's
like I will just start offering trades
along the E file pretty much next move
you're you're never going to have time
to play Knight E5 but yeah but the
engine just goes King H2 here and
doesn't give a check on H1 it takes on
C2 in reply it's uh uh chess is hard JY
I mean this is that's just so unfair I
think it's unfair y you wow I mean I I
was looking at discovered checks winning
material can also check on H1 draw the
white king out into the open and just
thinking it's not enough you see I would
have been scared as white to play D3
takes F4 D3 takes E4 and allow F5 takes
E4 opening up The Rook that was
I thought the move Knight E1 was the
most sens was the most practical
sensible D3 takes E4 really throws Down
The Gauntlet to Anish Anish now thinking
for what quite some time I I I I believe
right yeah but he must be also thinking
how chess is unfair right right 28
minutes to 49 I think thinking about
this position and thinking man you know
his POS his pieces are so
active yeah 20 minute there's no
clearcut way to get an advantage joy in
this position capturing on e4 capturing
on F2 both very very forcing both very
practical uh how do you break this down
I mean you look at the forcing captures
first right Knight takes F2 because
that's the one closer to the king so you
go down that rabbit hole you make a
discovery I'll tell you what it depends
on my mood your mood definitely because
position well you know everyone is
influenced by their move okay so first
off if you're feeling gungho you just
think okay Knight takes porn let's go
let's go and uh there you know you don't
need to think about so much about how
risky it is you're just feeling in an
aggressive mood Al but if you're feeling
a bit more kind of cautious about it
then you're going to go porn takes porn
because then the the imbalances are not
there anymore so let's just go porn
taste porn and then just play and play
with the active pieces so but really
where I'm getting at is you're you're
you're supposed to actually be
calculating two very forcing lines
you're supposed to be calculating E4 and
you're supposed to be calculating of
them are the same and you can't make a
that's my question yeah if both of them
are the same and you can't make a choice
then it's going to depend on you know
tournament situation your mood you know
your personality as well because there
are players who just don't want to take
that risk right there was a a game that
was played uh between perua and Wesley
so in the rapid and Blitz and I
absolutely absolutely loved the
sacrifice that Peruan made Queen takes
F5 uh two knight uh two two minors for
the queen and it was a brilliant
brilliant decision but it it was
especially brilliant against Wesley so
yeah because Wesley he's one of those
players he gets into a comfort zone
you're not going to beat him you're just
not going to beat him in certain kinds
of positions so so by by mixing it up
and getting him out of his comfort zone
I thought it was great the game did end
in the draw by the way but in this
particular case you know I couldn't
resist myself I would be playing the
move Knight takes F2 here because I
would see that I'm following it up with
F5 takes E4 and I thinking you know like
my my my my pieces are
harmonizing really this this idea that
you could play E4
F5 that's just that's just crazy I mean
I don't think any human of sane mind is
going to be doing that but but you know
I was just thinking more about the
imbalance like if you do have like these
two two pieces and against the rook and
if the Rooks are not working and you
know as Peter's highlighted the knights
and the bishop are protecting the king
then you can see that that when things
go wrong well white will have the
advantage well this is the problem
though Rook takes F2 does run into that
variation where you have to pay
attention to Queen D1 check you can't
move the Knight I mean because this
bishop on uh C5 and The Rook on f8 are
killing it so this is where you have to
play Bishop E3 return the peace and for
me Peter it's just extraordinary that uh
White equalizes after returning the pece
because of
this you know perfectly time move want
F1 and you know we don't have time for
95 or something and Advantage I just
thought I had Advantage I I I will
disagree with you slightly but from a
very practical uh point of view I think
first of all of course your first move
here as black is to try and calculate
both and see uh if one is just clearly
stronger than the other right and I
don't know if he's already passed that
point if he's established that against
best play it's not very much or not uh
but the second layer is if you at some
point come to the realization that with
perfect play your opponent will probably
survive this if he play if he defends
really really well and then you start
thinking which one will be the
easiest 28 minutes for 25 moves by the
way there is increment but ala is not
doing that well on the clock so where
are you going to ask the the most
questions and here the problem for me is
I think we can disregard EF5 knowing
alira he will play E5 instantly will
show us King H2 and everything but from
a purely human perspective you're
calculating this exactly Bishop B3 or
resigns so he will play Bishop B3 in
this position he will play Rook F1
because everything else like allowing
you takes F3 you will lose with so you
go Rook F1 if you allow Rook takes F3
and Rook takes F3 it will just be a draw
and after Knight E5 both Queen E4 and
even the immediate Knight G4 just
driving this Knight away and then taking
on F3 next move I think very comfortable
equalizing Maneuvers which are okay
imminently fundable it's just not
difficult right so by playing Knight F2
uh you you give your opponent here a
fairly straightforward and yeah he's
reaching to remove something yeah it
looked like he was making a move but
there was there some lint on the board
yeah lint removal yeah uh as a snooker
player by the way as snooker viewer
don't you love it when they reach in and
they remove something on or they they
ask they ask their to clean the CU yeah
and they get the white gloves to the
Arbiter in the white gloves yeah so the
the issue the issue here is that I think
Knight of two yes uh gives ala yeah
gives alza a sequence of five six moves
all of which are very easily defined as
the best moves in the position resulting
in a positiona will not lose whereas if
we if we go back to if we go back to
this
position uh first of I want to say it
would take me a long time to believe I'm
not better here with black true I have a
pollen of three of course I have a
bishop on C5 or Rook on f8 the H G4 has
been played and it's myve and it's my
move even right it would take me a long
time to convince myself I not better
here point but secondly uh if you
continue some of these variations let's
say we go Queen F6 BB3 strictly only
move we take on E3 you have to take on
E3 with the Knight because uh if you
take with the Rook after F takes G4 B7
B5 is a massive thr King G2 you
basically lost to both B5 and Knight B4
coming over to D5 then4 so you have to
take with the Knight we go let's say
Knight before here Queen C1 strictly on
move F takes G4 Knight F5 strictly only
move my God we get the Knight over to D5
and in this position uh you know if we
imagine that we get enough time to play
G6 and land the Knight on F4 we probably
we probably win of okay I understand
nothing I understand nothing about
nothing don't ask me anything anymore
for the pet but by the way what you've
just that final position what you
just sign me up F5 that was my chall
Anish disagrees and I think yeah I mean
if he goes E5 here we should all just
like yeah like just take off our hat
just shower out res with some golden
coins Co and say Well done young man but
Knight takes F2 on the board Jo so we
were we were looking at PA takes the
variations with f takes E4 but it is
also possible after Rook takes Knight to
actually
grab sorry H grab grab the the yeah
sorry and that one that one bad that
doesn't that doesn't work you need to
have Queen D1 check there here white
stabilizes very very comfortably because
after F4 Queen takes C4 you don't have a
check from H4 this is no long check B5
just dri the KN to a good Square so no
you absolutely have to go F4 after the r
of right but we do have uh F5 takes E4
on the board I think we've exhausted
this game a little bit uh let's go to
our I think up top maybe Yan versus m
lanir pardon me we when we left it we
saw the move Queen takes A3 Knight a D4
okay makes a lot of sense we're ready to
uh well uh Rook
Rook B5 ideas uh Rook C8 H3 not much has
happened Peter Well actually there's a
bit of a subplot here because first of
all Yan chose the D4 square and not the
E5 Square it's a matter of taste both
are fine to in that white will still be
slightly worse but it's within very
manageable margins but it kind of has to
be followed up with this move Queen C3
both Knight E5 and queen D4 the engine
is very insistent that that uh and here
it even drops it back to C2 and then to
E3 and says yes I'm a pawn down but
eventually I will have let's say n B3 I
go Knight E3 and I am more or less
snapping snapping on C4 next move
otherwise maybe we like if this Pawn
lands on A4 we resign right but we are
just in time to play Knight takes C4 and
the engine says this is just just a draw
basically instead he played H3 and now
after let's say the possible E5 Knight
B5 Queen C5 this will no longer be on
offer and the engine suggests this is
somehow still fine it goes Queen A6 and
after let's say queen king G7 it goes
Knight D6 Rook d8 Knight C4 Knight D2 it
takes and plays Rook A1 and says we're
still sort of keeping things under
control but honestly I say these words I
don't understand these words right I say
them because I can see on my screen but
I see an extra Pawn Yeah I don't know I
would be desperately unhappy with this
with white because generally this Knight
on F6 with the King on G7 again
specifically the light Square Bishop
means that the king will forever be
completely safe right I guess the
argument is there's just no way to smoke
out the queen from A6 so the extra Pawn
is never moving and after something like
Rook D7 we just go I don't know E3 and
we chill but we are chilling in a
position where we're down a very healthy
outside passer I'm shocked it's not
worse than it seems to be EF5 by the way
played
confounding just retire all of us I mean
we already
retired1 but hang on here's the Moment
of Truth Queen to D1 we're going back to
the game of Anish Gary and Ali Raza for
a moment because we did see Ali Raza
play e takes F5 a move that just is a
remarkable move from the from the
perspective of like go ahead do your
worst make a double check if you want I
grab the pawn right away Knight takes H3
check thinking exactly give me the goods
and I would actually look at my opponent
like what are you doing and Peter said
don't grab the pawn play Queen D1 check
guess what that's exactly what he did
now again the moment of truth if you
play King H2 you have ice water about to
make a move and ice water thinking so I
mean I mean there's no other alternative
right well no that was that was slight
worst yeah that was slightly worse
ending but this idea that we can go King
H2 inviting Queen H1 check I don't think
we were supposed to play Queen H1 check
I think the computer wants you to trade
Queens it trades it trades on C2 goes
Rook takes F5 and the position is very
very equal and I wanted to say this
position is absolutely there we go takes
him a minute to play King H2 fantastic
uh this position is absolutely the
difference between engines and humans
because the engine says no Checkmate the
human says what am I doing are you crazy
my king is out there in the middle of
the board I could easily get you know I
could if I miss something this is going
to be in the books and all my friends
are going to be laughing the next ice
age uh so Queen H1 check King G3 we we
don't like and the uh generations of
today say I've been working with the
engines a lot I was I was going to bring
that up I think and it's it's you know
the the Trope that is very tired and I
don't like bringing this up the fact
that the the the people of let's say l
resa's generation the all the young
Indian talents and they've not really
not worked with the engine at any point
in their career so they will be very
used to this idea that you can take a
lot of Liberties if you calculate
cleanly but still this looks you got to
overcome kind of stunning one thing I
wanted to to ask my my screen about is
this move which will not be played Anish
has already taken yeah because my my
point was if you play King G1 here
Knight takes H3 is actually quite strong
but the engine suggests that G2 G3 is
borderline winning for White Knight on
F2 is a yeah this is very complicated
but it does look like we are going to
see a result between Wesley so and Maxim
Vash lra it is a draw between these two
players and uh there we see the Arbiter
Chris bird put the kings in the middle
of the board and
a well played game it was uh an
imbalance of uh onean majority on the
center King side versus the the uh
majority on the queen side and the
players just uh found a repetition and a
very balanced and intriguing wellplayed
game only the result is disappointing
the result is disappointing and also we
feels like we were promised something
the opening was so unusual and the
position looked so open to all kinds of
potential shenanigans that we feel
slightly undersold but very very nicely
played game and the final repetition I
think is quite logical if white wanted
to pretend here something like H4 with
the intention of playing H5 would have
been maybe interesting but the engine
suggest you can maybe even start
immediate count to play with a threat
ofan mate which makes basically an
immediate drw exactly and our King feels
a little bit uh unsteady there on so
very understandable to return to uh our
main dish of the day uh the Queens have
come off so Anish is not shocked by King
H2 I'm pretty sure he realized it's
playable uh the Queens have come off
Rook takes A5 Bishop B3 uh and the
Knight will go to either E4 or D3 after
both of which actually you kind of have
to go Knight D4 because Knight D3 Knight
D3 Rook D1 it doesn't quite yeah 94 it
starts it starts getting a bit awkward
looks safe but 94 is yeah completely
fine here for black that looks very
balanced let's go to the game of uh
Fabby and leavon and uh we've got to we
got to spread the love here we got to
keep me in check uh Joy what what do you
have for us in the leavon game uh pretty
much it was a
caroan rook C3 no d5s Rook E8 as
prescribed Bishop f8 love it love it and
uh Queen C1 Queen
D7 uh we admired the play of anat karpov
uh the uh world champion during his
Reign he had this innate ability of
putting his Pieces away from you so like
his his his pieces were always uh doubly
protected uh very very safe very classic
and he just simply outplayed you from
these very even positions it feels to me
like leavon with his two Bishops is
going to be pleased with the outcome of
the opening I mean but there is a slow
position I mean is there time for some
like lengthy maneuvering so I'm thinking
the piece that's not doing anything is
the bishop on G3 okay what would you
like to do I would like to take it on
Odyssey and put it on C3 C3 yeah I feel
like that's the best Square for it at
least it's like looking at its own porn
and then it frees up the Rooks to come
ac across to come across cuz I really
want to be putting a knight on
F5 and then D5 and then King attack okay
I can see that this this fan has got no
fans It's A Hard
Sell it's funny you got the Central Pawn
Duo as is white probob is looking at
that he's kind of
chuffed uh over there you have Peter
saying yeah but I've got these pawns on
C6 and F6 and I'm kind of keeping an eye
if you try to play D5 I've got one hook
if you try to play E5 I've got one hook
if you put on your Bishop on C3 it's
like okay it's kind of nicely defending
everybody but are you really ever GNA
Play Bishop takes F6 okay yes with G G4
G5 yeah kind of but you know what mood
are you in
today you
gotam did you did you see the Tender
Love Story uh the Norseman no what I've
had is good yeah uh well that that there
you would really need to go berserk the
problem is is if you look at Black's
King seriously it's not one of those
jokes Black's King is probably one of
the safest at this exact moment if you
took a picture you say Okay kids
everybody pay attention this is the safe
King you want if you start throwing all
your forces against my king you're
probably going to come up empty-handed
that's what I'm going to say I
understand that but uh one of the big
problems I had with this position is
that unless you're going D D5 right then
what else are you doing you can't move
your Rook from E1 without uh you know
having some protection on e4 you can't
move your knight from F3 because of the
Pawn on D4 so either you're going D4 D5
right or you're that was a m slip sorry
I was just trying to clear the clear the
arrows uh Peter wait in on this because
I Joy you're making a really funny uh
point from the barbar Northwest Seattle
we had a fellow his name was Robert zuk
now Robert zuk was this incredibly
strong 2400 master from Canada we he
came down to Seattle he had the winter
of zuk I think he went 116 games
undefeated it was it was incredible he
was beating everybody what he did was
fantastic he reached what was called the
zuk point he put all of his pieces on
the best squares like Fano hasis and
then he didn't know what to do yeah
because all your pces are optimized
exactly
all of fabby's pieces feel optimized and
here's Joy saying well now I want to do
something I I started by being intensely
skeptical and then the more Yanka
Contin speaking the more the more I kind
of I yeah I I'm I'm I'm growing in I'm
growing in appreciation for my coaster
here because Yanka is absolutely the
woman after my own heart an influencer I
just don't think we have time but if we
could sort of you know say abracadabra
here and this is a rook and this is a
bishop yeah I think I'd be quite happy
it's just that it takes about 75
minutes uh but for for the time being
Let's uh uh go back to our studio
because Anastasia Carlovich has a guest
Abracadabra exactly I have a guest I
have Maxim VRA here with me Maxim
welcome to the show you just made a draw
against wesle so with black pieces are
you happy with was your result first of
all yeah I'm happy but at the same time
when the opening came on one end I was
uh happy because uh I knew I was going
to play G6 and it's very uh double-edged
but also probably uh decent for black
but at the same time I was kicking
myself a bit cuz I did recheck it this
morning but I didn't pay as much
attention as I should have and um DET
yes played it with white so how is it
sometimes to play the same position with
some black and white pieces you know
yeah with n of it happens uh all the
time all the time but uh yeah I didn't
mind I played with white a lot of times
but this G6 and queen B6 is uh I
wouldn't say new but uh it's still
relatively unexplored compared to the
main movie five mhm I see so let's say I
mean the game was developing quite log
ially of course you never can take on B2
no I just can showare one detail so
after Queen B6 if white goes A4 okay so
now you don't go Knight C6 because take
on C6 but you go Bishop G7 and if white
goes A5 no you can take you can take
Bishop B5 ah and then you defend your
queen yes that's a trick yes okay so A4
was not good A3 he played I mean it's
not that A4 is not good but like you
don't need to play A5 is definitely not
good uh uh so yeah of course Knight H6
is another option but Knight G3 uh is
very
principled and yeah that's see I didn't
remember if I should go Bishop B6 or if
I should start Bishop G7 Castle um but
in the end I decided this position was
um quite playable once I get D5 I
assumed I'm not
worse um I was wondering somewhere here
let's say instead of Bishop H6 there was
so many options like what do you
normally do you Castle on you Castle
short you will do you H4 H5 this yes
also was possible yes but H4 I go H5 uh
if C King s and I'm up just castle and
if Castle I think this was critical uh
Castle short side okay and then maybe it
can be some yeah but you go b54 some KN
D4 so play yeah I couldn't remember the
details which is why I was not happy
with myself but okay uh no this I
remember after Bishop P2 you you don't
care you give the
pawn something
like maybe B5 B5 yes and if Queen D6 you
just que A5 could say sorry of course
yes something like this I I'm not really
sure but uh I knew this should be okay
this it could be completely different
game yes if he would have played this
long castle with opposite cast but even
here I felt there's lots of play uh but
maybe I'm the one who bailed out with D5
like I can go King B8 Knight to D4 Rook
C8 or even here start with Knight D4 and
Rook C8 but I
felt I don't know I felt it shouldn't be
better for
me and so I just decided to go for D5
and I mean there's still some things
going on here I thought uh can become
very tricky for white but Bishop D
Knight E2 was nice especially Knight E2
I did see yeah so he's may maybe
F5 but here I don't have time and for
instance F6 would be ill advised up take
oh Bishop G6 yes looks scary but mhm uh
Pawn is a pawn yeah we don't like to
give them I was thinking maybe you could
have avoided this uh Night Exchange and
go with your knight back to C6 or yeah I
didn't want to but but I understand it's
something is no I mean of course Knight
F5 was first my idea but Bishop takes
yes um Pawn takes I assum I'm slightly
worse and Bishop takes Knight
C3 the queen on H6 especially is
unpleasant now because I always eating
at H7 maybe Queen G7 sometimes sometimes
G4 and this Knight is not worse than the
bishop for sure yeah so at the end let's
say there was just repetition and the
game finish the draw what do you think
about actually this rule which okay was
long for long I'm here no draw offers I
don't mind uh I mean we play until
natural conclusion and anywhere in anal
position we are very creative in finding
more repetitions exactly I was I was
wondering because I didn't see you after
this rapid and blit championship of
course I mean this crazy last game like
um let's say what were your emotions
after and what did you do after the end
of the
tournament well I mean first I had toar
Fabian who told me that he didn't tell
me that he didn't see me weing that
famous Rook move yes so I went back to
my hotel room
actually uh because of the delay I I I
arrived around the moment that I did
Drop The Rook yes so at least you know
like you knew that this is what really
happen like I I knew because uh I lost
connection let's say yeah some so I drop
the work I take it back immediately and
then in my brain it's like for one
second did I did I release it and was
pretty sure I released yes anyways the
bit saw me released so like Chris bir so
even if I liked all sense of fair play
uh I would have been you know brought
brought back to reason but of course uh
it was pretty sad end but I don't think
this was a game that cost me the the
tournament for sure uh I did get this
opportunity of course but I think of
course the first two ones which I lost
were not great MH and then there were
many games where I was uh better SL
winning that I didn't win with white
against Ray actually this yes of course
yes against Jeffrey especially these two
and I mean this could have ch change
things uh quite a bit in any case I mean
still it was great event you know just
finished two days three days ago and now
we have sful cup all the best of luck
for you Maxim we just started only two
rounds uh we have and all the best of
luck for you tomorrow yeah thank you
thank you thank you Anastasia thank you
Maxine I just wanted to explain a little
bit to our viewers what Maxim was
speaking about there so it was the last
round of the St Louis rapid and Blitz
Fabiano is leading by half a point over
Maxim if Maxine can win MBL will be the
tournament winner mvl is winning he's
got a position where he's winning he
moved the Rook he touched the Rook so
he's going to move the Rook he touched
the rook and put it on a square which
was a blunder Stone Cold
blunder and when you
release the Rook then the move is fixed
so it's okay that he touched the Rook he
could have moved the Rook to another
Square he would have been obliged to
move the rook and if he could have moved
it to another Square he would have
likely won the game instead he realized
that he he had dropped the Rook he'd
released The Rook he let it sit on the
Square and uh fair play a good
sportsmanship if you will and uh fabbi
drew the game famously the Gary Kasparov
versus Judith Polgar where Gary released
the Knight then moved the Knight to
another Square And Judith's expression
was
like if a picture could say a thousand
words uh but let's move on uh we do have
some moves in the game between Fabby and
leavon and we did see the move D5 a move
that you had kind of been looking at
there Peter I I liked it in pretty much
every single position and as as we were
discussing other things I was checking
why this is this isn't being played and
black can play Rook A6 annoyingly uh
keeping the T and no my larger Point
here is that this allows a complete
ruination of the black structure on the
queen side but the Bishops are so strong
and the structure on the queen side
potentially so weak that the engine
quite happily not only goes into this
end game but also goes into the S game a
full P down and says yeah I'm just going
to play H5 I'm completely fine doesn't
really give white anything at all here
despite the bishop for instance
returning to C3 and protecting
everything the Bishops the Bishops are
just so strong in these end games that
it's completely fine but Lev is not
interested in defending a slightly worse
10 game worst end game he goes C5 Five
played Rook C3 perhaps hinting at some
e45 breaks somewhere in the future left
played uh Rook A6 very useful Rook lift
because in case of E4 E5 it's very very
good to have this Rook patrolling the
six Rank and if I played Rook D1 perhaps
a kind of a nod towards a potential
counterplay with C7 C6 although we can
play D6 anyway so he didn't need that
for for C6 specifically maybe in some
positions we are now threatening uh or
at least kind of hinting at E4 A5 let's
make some kind of a stupid passive move
E5 here seems to work yeah Bishop D5 we
have a very important move Rook E3 G3
which will cut off that Rook from from
the very important to provoke C6
suddenly this Rook looks very very
stupid and then we take on F6 and we
play something like Knight H4 or Bishop
F4 and yes we're a pawn down but we have
managed to create a play I think ianka
should be quite happy about this we are
now going to start giving M abely and
it's maybe defendable but it's
defendable in very computer terms yeah
you don't want to yeah it's extremely
annoying for black so I think leevon
needs to realize that if he does nothing
here uh E4 E5 might come so he needs to
choose a move which does something about
B5 exactly that's very ambitious stuff
and now if you go E5 I'll take you go
for that same variation uh I got to go C
6 you take on F6 but now there's a big
difference after your knight H4 G6 is
not a terrible weakness actually yeah
the move the move I was making there as
a pass is actively detrimental to
Black's Health yeah exact having it on
H7 is significant significantly better
and Bishop H5 chosen in the meantime
which was one of the engine suggestions
it I think takes all the sting out of
the e45 play first of all currently
maybe we even want to take on F3 uh an
interesting discussion would be and this
is is one of the engine's main lines
here after Rook D2 there is this option
of taking on F3 which forces gf3 we are
not going to give up very very important
Central Pawn here so you have to take
with the pawn and black can take on H3
give up on C7 and we get already you
know this is suddenly a wild position I
mean we do have D5 D6 we don't actually
get M but it gets close Okay I felt a
little I don't know it feels very scary
the r is coming to E6 and thank
you I'm with you there I mean I mean I
think it's much more logical to kind of
go King H2 King H2 is a is a very clear
clear second option here right and and
the game continues you generally don't
want to give up this bishop if you don't
win something for it you can still Force
G takes F3 here but I I would probably
not play this I think strengthening the
White Center matters more than somewhat
spoiling the structure yeah and the two
Bishops after all are useful uh and uh
let's just review uh round two exactly
and we'll take a look at the results
before we go on break what do you have
for us and uh as we see there there was
a draw between wesle so against Maxim
Vash lra and just a reminder to everyone
or to anyone who's just catching up with
the program well y Kristof Duda is on
well so that is why the game between
Duda and Report has not being played and
we will keep you updated with any news
as we have them and it's time time for
us to take our second break but don't go
anywhere because we have a video lined
up for you to all enjoy so earlier
before the tournament began Anastasia
did speak to Wesley so and you can enjoy
that video and we will see you after the
[Music]
break wesle welcome to St Louis welcome
for granch T I was wondering if it's the
city you have been traveling the most
except your hometown in your life yeah
for sure uh St Louis is like our second
home it's only an hour away from where I
live Minnesota uh you know I was living
here before and you know I would
definitely consider moving here except
my family has a job Minnesota but uh
there are a ton of grand Masters living
here in Missouri so it attracts Grand
masters from all around the
world and uh I definitely am very
excited coming back here every time
because I know a lot people a lot of
people here and uh you know I'm kind in
good relationships with everyone here
and it's the home of Chess in the US I
was expecting to see you in a of man not
that I was there but I mean one of I
thought you would try to fight fight for
the spot in the candidates but now now I
understood your approach a little bit
more yeah for also I think as a if
you're like a professional player you
have to on any sport I think you have to
spend at least half your time training
and resting and then half the time
playing so let's say in 2021 it was a
very successful year for you in GCT as
well as 22 where you were second at the
end let's say what can be let's say the
goal kind of a goal for this one you
said to qualify but let's say speaking
about your chances now real chances in
the tour um what what what exactly you
need to do how well you should play in
both events well I think if I finish on
the upper half on both events then I
should be in a good spot to at least
secure third place I think unless
someone just keeps is winning it
all because I think uh Maxim is doing
well sabii is doing well okay Fabby will
probably win leading yes let's say yeah
Fabby will probably win the grand chest
tour it seems like with his current form
and also his number one spot but the
next the second and third spots are
really up for grabs uh what do you think
let's say about the prospects of grand
stour I mean especially now that it's 10
year university of sing Club as well
let's say do you think it's going to
happen we have this same event in 10
years and who do you think will play
from the new generation there yeah for
sure I I mean I hope it will still be
around 10 years from now uh but uh it's
uh not up to me obviously need private
sponsors for that that's why I'm very
grateful to Rex and Genie because
they've done so much not only for me but
for us chess and also many other chess
players in in general and and uh it's
not so easy to find corporate sponsors
for for chess you can't have to rely on
private people and other people are
afficionados but uh I hope grandest
store will will still be around but it's
uh 10 years is a long time really let's
see what we happen in 10 years hopefully
and all the best of luck for your
wrestling the tournament thank you yeah
I really need
that
[Music]
hello I'm women's Grand Master V Jan I
will be creating content for grandest
store follow us on social media and
catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping gr schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr juny
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that s Lou chess
club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
sense a hope that the game of chess will
always stay Float by the mere fact of
its existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's grandmas
ranoa I will take you behind the scenes
of the gr chest store follow us on
social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
past sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
family-friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
we are back with our coverage of the
second round of the sink field cup and
well we've already started the day with
a result and also some news as well and
let's take a look at the results so far
and you can see it was a draw between
Maxim bash and Wesley so and there you
also see that Duda against report that
has been grayed out and that is because
once again to remind everyone that Duda
is on while suffering from ill health so
that match will has been scratched out
and will keep you a breast of any
developments there but in the other
games everything to play for absolutely
I feel like we lost something in that
game between mvl and Wesley there it was
more it was
more going on
there was something in the air right
right out of the opening that really had
me very excited and mvl was showing some
lines when he gave this interview to
Anastasia which were looked wild and and
exciting and exactly the thing I was
hoping for and then everything got
traded off it was a correctly played
game but still it could have gone in a
vly different direction it fizzled uh in
the game between Yan and and lanir Yan
sacrificed upon some time ago for what
we think was completely sufficient
compensation now I'm less sure but as we
were coming on air you were very
reassuring that nothing unto has
happened uh the move Knight B5 A3 and
you were saying Peter just at this
moment that the move Rook B8 was
actually ill ill advised yeah there were
there were better options for for lineer
uh King G7 is a very natural one and it
probably was the best the best option in
in in in the position and as we
discussed when we when this was still
theoretical possibility sometime in the
future uh the game very likely would
have led towards this position which
honestly is just shocking that black
isn't better but somehow it's not very
much it's uh seems to be a manageable
Pawn down position with white having to
defend it so uh let's actually apologies
apologies for interrupting you but looks
like a repetition is in store quickly
and uh there well they entertained us
with a brief display of fireworks but it
does look like the players have repeated
the position three times and a peaceful
outcome there as the players share the
point a harving of the point isn't it
and uh for for for me this uh this this
is also another one of those games that
so much was behind the curtain I was
going to say exactly the same thing uh
very much applies to what we said about
the game between Wesley and MBL perhaps
applies even more so to uh to the game
between uh alira and Anish because this
whole sequence starting from E4 D takes
E4 we we were looking at so much fun
stuff right and it seems like once again
no mistakes were made black doesn't
actually have an advantage here if white
plays perfectly but uh it's a bit
regrettable that 5 mes later from this
position we had a very very level end
game which ended in a draw very
logically I think okay and that leaves
us with two games remaining leavon uh
versus fappy let's jump into that one oh
I got the laner game there and I no and
uh Leon has done something that I think
Fabby very consciously provoked here
because we left it after Rook D1 uh
Bishop H5 was reacted to by Fabby
putting the Rook back on Ean it just
came from we the move before so leevon
said draw Fabby said No Such Thing
played Queen C2 Leon played B7 B5 which
I wasn't sure exactly why why you would
play B7 B5 because I don't think we're
threatening before in some cases maybe
you would consider putting the pawn on
C4 but that also gives a very very
pleasant Square for the White Knight so
I wasn't sure what what was intended
here and then Fab made this move Rook D1
again uh and here Leon couldn't really
resist the temptation of playing C7 C6
which is generally a move you would like
to play unless it allows D6 but with the
Rook on D1 Leon is clearly intending to
meet this with B3 but the engine
suggests this is very very risky for
black for black the engine suggests that
the pawn on D6 survives Bishop on f8
will not have any moves for quite some
time and perhaps what was missed is this
very slow seemingly idea uh of playing
KN D4 with the intention of very simply
taking on B3 and it's not just the pawn
that we're picking up we're also
creating this idea of dropping the queen
back and then putting the Knight on this
square and if that Knight lands on C5
white is probably going to be in a
dominant dominant position gge G6 hasn't
been played yet because Fabi clearly
it's a committal decision he's down to
12 minutes uh so uh he needs to make
sure he understands what's happening
there but really playing Rook D1 with
the intention of not playing D6 doesn't
really make any sense whatsoever second
best move by the engine is let's say
queen C3 but then after cd55 you start
thinking maybe play can be better yeah
the two Bishops the Bishops are still
there we've broken up the White Center
The Pawn on D5 could become a Target
there's B5 B4 play now which makes a lot
more sense with the position more open
so I feel like he will play D6 he just
needs to uh make sure he understands
exactly what's happening yeah that is a
lovely uh Pawn uh pardon me exchange
sacrifice again let me just follow this
up uh with what Peter was just saying so
with the move Rook D1 we are being we
are walking in uh to this uh trap Bishop
to B3 uh skewering an exchange but what
Peter was mentioning is Rook takes B3 D6
on the board by the way D6 on the board
so the players may be following our
analysis you start to think Queen takes
B3 check C4 I'm super happy yeah I'm
super happy as black but then you stop
and you go okay I'm not going to take
the pawn on B3 I'm going to take the
pawn on
C5 and and uh Bishop B3 on the board so
here we go they're going right down this
uh Primrose path Rook takes E4 now again
from Black from Leon's point of
view he's a happy camper he's just won
an exchange the pawn on D6 is uh firmly
blockaded everything's really looking
okay what's what's the problem and as
Peter is saying it's very easy to
underestimate the power of Knight D4
what is it it feels like you're doing
nothing but you're doing something very
concrete you want to take the pawn move
your queen and then play Knight by the
way which is took on B3 which is a whole
other direction to take and I'm sure I
didn't expect that at all I thought E4
C4 pardon me and you shut down well that
is okay explain that one to me Peter
because that one is a surise for I as
well it's Maybe not immediately and I
just want to make sure that uh 94 is the
more aesthetically pleasing move so to
speak but Knight D2 is just as strong
with the absolutely same idea of picking
up on B3 and stopping Rook C4 but his
point is slightly different he wants to
take on B3 and now he will not be giving
up his other Central Pawn and it will be
joining the play with E4 E5 so he's
preserving his Central pair and he wants
to continue opening the position up once
he play E5 black will be faced with some
unpleasant decision let's say you go C5
white goes E5 if you ignore it white
will perhaps take on F6 and then go
Knight H4 Knight F5
if you do take it white lands a very
very strong Knight on E5 D7 next move
this is still entirely playable it's not
like the bad yeah everything was thrown
away and as I look at the computer
suggestion here it seems to say that
unless you play Queen E6 you are still
worse yeah but queen6 is a logical move
yeah I don't think it's that hard to
find no we'll see we we'll see what what
comes out of this but it does feel like
quote unquote objectively speaking Fab
may have missed a trick there exactly
does it make I mean I find the move C5
C4 very compelling you but because
you've just made the move Queen E6 maybe
I'm making an argument with myself for
Queen F7 Peter yeah we should show why
not to play Queen E6 yes Queen E6 yeah
step by step this is just bad because
counterintuitively we actually trade
Queens but we also win a full piece for
the for the D passer exactly Queen F7 is
playable but then after Queen C2 you're
still going to play C4 because it's
hanging and then it's basically the same
position but you made the move Queen F7
which is not great so you'd much rather
spend it on something else and the only
difference I could add to that was Queen
F7 Queen C2 Queen
C4 it's it's horrible but I am looking
to trade Queens aren't I no there's
Bishop C7 remember this bishop is still
alive Bishop C7 that clears the cop good
morning St
Louis
it's a good move it's a good move yeah
that D7 and Bishop C7 it was your
Abracadabra you supposed to put the
bishop on C3 and not not not not not not
fall for Bishop C7 okay that's a very
exciting position there but we're going
to go over to St Louis with Anastasia
who is there with a
guest yes indeed I'm here with sanish
giri who just finished his game in a
draw what a game it was Anish I me it's
I mean I wonder what you were thinking
during many times and how many times you
calculated Knight F2 and all this on
each move probably yeah well I knew this
stuff I don't play like this when I'm
prepared I'm not this kind of
guy I don't go Knight G4 F5 Knight F2 if
I'm not prepared so uh I knew that um
this there's Knight G4 D5 uh and F5 and
frankly here uh the line I recollected
is Bishop
B2 and there is this very forcing line
black has options but this is like the
why am am I showing okay it's too late
I'm already showed it but uh there is
this uh forced um Knight D4 and now you
can take Rook E2 but I think Knight C5
is also there uh and I think there this
end game I was analyzing this end game
little bit if white can be a bit better
here after Knight F2 Bishop A5 C6 but I
think surprisingly it's it's quite
drowish even though it looks like a bit
better fight but also there was um Rook
yeah Bishop D4 C Rook e
to and when I was analyzing it I was
checking which one is the easier draw I
think I cluded that this is probably the
cleaner one but uh anyway Bishop B2 is
the the force line black can also play
more ambitiously than that it was sort
of a a forced payout but I'm sorry it
was forced and was clear for you was it
wasn't so clear probably for ala who was
spending quite a lot of time what do you
think well I don't know afterwards he
told me that when I send him to line he
said that maybe he had seen it before
but he somehow didn't quite uh recollect
details of course Knight G4 D5 is the is
a weird way to play uh black can play
many different ways like usually they go
like Bishop A7 I mean I had games with
white like that as well it's kind of
slow play H6 but sometimes you go for D5
sometimes not but in this particular
case white hasn't gone H3 so I have this
I prepared this Force line yeah I mean
it was sort of an attempt to uh to try
and just completely Force um Force the
draw I'm I'm curious actually P was
mentioning that he will not be surprised
if you know everything until you know
yeah no I'm surprised this engine here
gives some number mine was giving a
smaller number I guess this is not a
very deep deep one cuz I think this
position if I remember correctly it was
completely nothing but um it looks of
course a bit better I think yeah I was
kind of thinking maybe this is a little
something but I think I kept analyzing
it and it was okay but yeah H3 is um is
the other way but I I didn't recollect
because I thought H3 was not the most
principled way and I was frankly kind of
mostly calculating it looks logical yes
what happens if you take yeah I didn't
see here yeah the point is that I I want
to to take first here so that if BC then
I go Knight F2 mhm Rook F2 by the way I
was thinking Queen D6 first more precise
than taking because yeah8 so this I
liked and if uh KN C4 now I'm not taking
on F2 anymore I'm going now E4 that's
why I take on C4 first yeah but there
was some interesting lines you know if
uh you take immediately and then there
is some crazy move like B5 yeah maybe
next time yeah next time Peter saying
maybe you have seen it no Bishop C4
first I'm pretty sure C4 E4 um but was
fascinating in the game yeah actually 91
yeah he should have played I think this
is the the correct zero D4 here was very
interesting because I had uh is saw
night F2 is forc equality so it was hard
to uh I mean it was little hard to
refuse it because it was very easy uh
Force line but of course I felt that he
might have already pushed it too far so
I was trying to find Advantage here okay
the reason I didn't do this is because
in the worst case you can even go a g
mhm EF and something like this and
Bishop E3 whatever I don't buy this is
big Advantage for for black um but of
course this was not the main reason I
didn't play the main reason is that I
missed the amazing line here after
Bishop yeah Rook D1 is uh Bishop Queen
D5 Rook D1 that is uh good for white I
think Queen D3 is I think at least equal
for white but the principal line is EF
and here I missed an amazing he also
missed it and that's the pity because
okay I don't know if he would have seen
it at some point uh
but we were going to he was going to
lose it here actually he was going to go
Bishop H4 this is the reason why I
didn't play it as well but this this
absolutely unbelievable line this only
move Rook F2 take and I mean I I saw
Rook F2 with the engine after the game
there and then as I was walking towards
here I realized the point and why I
didn't see it of course it's amazing you
go Rook E8 here h g and then you go
Bishop G3 and you oh my God is
unbelievable m i mean there were there
were there was a chance he would have
fallen for this e won there is no def
chance though of course he's he had I
mean ag ag is there but AG is not why I
refuse it I think I can even go Bishop
F2 oh no this is not nice yeah E1 is not
nice sorry yeah so maybe I should go
Rook
F2 yeah I don't know I mean uh yeah okay
one is the threat right there's so yeah
you go here for example he goes here
because it's really Pleasant
yes take he goes Bishop
[Music]
H4 yeah I mean such things the thing is
that my knight is a bit dumb on C6 so
maybe white has some attacking potential
anyway I I frankly the thing is that it
was just um it was just not smart to do
this I felt because I thought that I
allow this bishop G5 after which I
didn't see frankly okay I mean I missed
this actually this was my issue I just
didn't make this work because what I
calculated here is uh no R8 is AG
there's nothing to to even calculate
right yeah this is just bad so I thought
of course about Knight F2 yeah but I
think there was just no even Queen E2
there's just no this good discovery
so um what else did I see yeah there's
not much else I just didn't see the I
mean I I missed R of two Al together but
I I guess even if I had seen Rook F2 it
just doesn't make much sense here
because you see E1 take take a g and
Rook H E1 take Taking H2 when you have
to see this Rook E8 AG is amazing uh Inc
res like like Queen C1 no here already
I'm the queen yeah it's just amazing
it's in uh uh but yeah I I suspect that
white is still okay here um with
something precise but it would have been
curious because um at least the line we
both saw is the is losing for him so
it's not like I missed to win and it was
a classical game so he had a lot of time
but maybe he would have fallen for it
but okay he's of course a great
tactician maybe he could have find
something later it's always to be honest
though I was not even yeah yeah but I
was not even I was not really close to
find this I mean this is just such a
Next Level Cheapo that I mean I don't
think I'm um capable of this kind of
thing
uh really I mean in a practical game
where I don't know that there is a
solution like of course if you tell me
here F Bishop G5 you say okay black to
play and whatever win yeah yeah then I
can find it for sure because by
elimination but when you don't know the
final outcome absolutely then you see
the normal options you're not looking
for something insane when you don't know
it's there so I just yeah and also
frankly I maybe I misjudged but I just
thought that this like even GF like I
thought like what's going on here maybe
it's so about respect to your opponent
that he will find all the best moves he
will not do the mistake no respect no
respect this no don't don't you know put
words in my mouth zero respect to
opponent it's just that I'm calculating
also okay I mean I have time I can play
Knight F2 any time and make the EF que
D1 EAS easy draw but frankly from afar I
missed EF um like I thought this is also
actually thought I'm better then I
realized after EF there's no good
discoveries and after Queen D1 I
realized here that I don't have any
Queen H1 business but you checked it a
little bit there's nothing right no yeah
so I have this Knight of two in the in
the back so I spent like I know that you
shouldn't be like you know it's waste
not to think about Fe when you have time
so I was thinking about Fe I was like
diligently thinking about it but I um I
knew that I'm not missing much because
there is AG but simply there's Bishop G5
I just didn't see that amazing resource
and it's very very one of the more
beautiful things I had seen that could
have occurred in my own game so okay my
last question can you agree on this
statement that you are the best prepared
player in this tournament there is very
good uh no no I'm not I mean here
especially uh the tournament is spe with
people who would definitely debate that
uh I'm trying um I'm really trying to be
the best prepared player but I think the
same is about Fabiano and Yan I think
they both also have Ambitions to to be
the best prepared player in the world I
I think um
Maxim Leon and
Wesley uh are less ambitious about it
right now I mean Leon used to be at some
point the best prepared in the world but
the problem is that even if you
are like better prepared pred overall in
a particular game you can still get
totally um um shocked by I mean and I
once played a game against opponent who
is not known to be an opening player
when he uncored some incredible Noel
against me so in particular game it
won't matter and I really don't think
that in this tournament you can say that
I'm the best but I'm of course trying
and there's a funny video of Hikaru uh
you know Hikaru yeah heard interesting
clear Hikaru and um so Hikaru at some
point there's a video where he talks uh
he talks about me and U there's actually
nice edit of that there's like Niche
counter so the number of times hearo
says my name and I think it's like 15 in
the end okay he says my name 15 times in
the video so it's yeah it's a nice video
and he there says that he thinks I'm the
best prepared player in the world said
okay Fabiano most maybe at some point um
but yeah I honestly don't think so
especially nowadays if I don't work for
three weeks I think in a row on chess
then I'm already behind Fabiano and um
Yan and yeah ala is also very
interesting um because he I have a
feeling he works sort of in you know in
the spurts um sometimes he's full of
ideas and then he starts to he also has
a different approach sometimes he plays
more um more of the slow things where he
relies on um practical skills rather
than prep so he has a different approach
uh and also of course we for we
shouldn't forget the Carlson who is not
playing here but he is also uh still
trying to be really well prepared
absolutely and okay the Fight Continues
about everything about who is the winner
of sill Cup who is better prepared all
the best of luck for you Anish and uh
see you tomorrow I hope I hope I
hope well have to do now it is a hope
isn't it there no absolutely I mean but
some fantastic lines that that's well
his preparation that's one of the things
sometimes I I feel that maybe in this
particular case it was a case of Anish
being overly prepared he was looking for
those forcing equalizing lines he had he
worked out draws and other variations so
he was actually trying to force a draw
said well maybe I could be a little bit
better but sometimes too much
preparation and just not enough in I
don't know how that one thing I
regretted having listened to this
interview is uh I feel like I was sort
of too influenced by by what by what the
engine was telling me because this whole
bunch of absolutely spectacular
variations he showed after with Bishop
G5 went completely past us because I
sort of realized it wasn't good I was
concentrating on the moves that were
good but Bishop G5 is obviously the
human Choice there and we should have I
feel like it's on me to to at least
mention it and to try to explain why
it's likely players are very seriously
calculating it so yeah I feel I've uh
let our viewership down there a little
bit returning to the game still Al this
is the position in the game between Fabi
and Leon Fabby chose the E3 Square for
the queen not C2 which is uh interesting
to me because yes you are controlling
the c65 break toward degree but you're
also kind of self-pinning along the eile
I'm not sure I love it okay so how would
uh things develop from at this point um
I guess his his argument here is if the
queen goes to C2 C6 C5 is a very logical
response and he's trying to stop it and
he is just generally saying to Black do
you do you even have useful moves and
apparently no because the the bestest
line by far appears to be for the time
being H7 H6 wow which is not a move
think that comes to mind immediately I
think yeah you can sort of imag like I
can construct an argument for why this
is useful but I will I myself will be
very doubtful the argument holds water I
think it's just the most useful pass you
have because white still can play E4 E5
and you need to play C6 C5 here so if we
try to uh kind of reconstruct it from
here going backwards uh we need to be
able to meet E5 with C5 okay and after
E5 and C5 gets played onto the board you
have a suspicion that The Rook actually
still needs to be on A6 so a move like
Rook A6 A8 which I otherwise would maybe
be seriously be advising because I want
it on d8 I want to be able to play Queen
E6 without having to worry about the D
Pawn promoting agreed but this is a
problem now because after Rook A8 the
engine goes uh for instance Queen B6 is
a very annoying move apparently it's so
it's a little bit mystifying I have to
say but uh there are some issues so if
the Rook if this Rook needs to stay here
the queen clearly cannot comfortably
leave the blockading square on D7 Bishop
has
no uh the The Rook on E8 is correctly
positioned you come to H6 just by
realization that you don't really have
anything that is much smarter than that
but it's not an easy solution at all
forgive me Peter I still don't
understand
H6 C H6 C
E5 C Queen takes C5 I think the point is
we take on E5 and if you take with the
Knight I have Rook takes D6 I'm pretty
sure this is the point this is the idea
behind that it's a veryy rook takes R
yeah right continuing the variation we
have B we have Bishop Tak C5 in the end
so it all hinges on a very very specific
little tactic that you need to see from
afar and you also need to correctly
assess yes that after Bishop takes E5
Rook d8 the pawn on D6 will uh
eventually fall because we're attacking
it with everything but
can cly not intive at all but one thing
that you can do though as white is not
rush with E5 cuz if H6 is the
only good way to move can you not just
make a move
like I'm thinking Rook to
D2 just you know there's no Rook takes
D1 check in in one of those variations
um once again the way you sometimes
actually get to understand these
positions is you see suddenly that with
the inclusion of H6 and Rook D2 the
engine says Queen E6 is playable and
then you go back and you ask the engine
why aren't you playing Queen E6 right
away yeah and it says now I'm very
worried about E5 and uh after let's say
F E5 D7 rook d8 and Knight takes C5 is
very strong and then you go you can go
back and ask it why aren't you playing
E5 here and it for some reason says in
the exact same POS sorry yeah D7 D7
first d8 yeah Knight E5 Bishop B7 it
seems to suggest this is for some reason
fine and the absolutely is not uh and
honestly I thought it would bring more
clarity but it really it really doesn't
actually the confusion is growing but
wait one second it really means that on
a practical level leavon is in big
trouble oh yeah I was I was going to say
exactly the same thing yeah um for me I
hate the queen on D7 I would much rather
TR trade my Rook on A7 and the Queen on
D7 spot so I want to get the queen to a
better Square
mhm I'm overlooking something Peter is
it again just D7 if I go Queen A7 Queen
A7 I want to trade queens and go Rook d8
what am I missing it goes It goes Queen
F4 it doesn't let you uh get your queen
trade for now and now E4 E5 is probably
gaining and strength so
C5 E5 go E5 is strong but five is even
stronger apparently and now your
position starts looking like it's full
of holes and queen F5 is way too
sophisticated I thought I was putting my
Rook on d8 and getting my queen out of
the way so I could win the so rook d8
and how am I losing I'm sure I think
here you start seeing sort of exactly
how you're going to get mated and Reon
bad things are happening to me so let's
look at ponte's porn just I think 95
probably just made right yeah now with
26 coming in very importantly taking
away the because you would like to play
you would like to play Queen E6 check
first and then Knight takes E5 but that
allows Queen F7 which is why Knight G5
is so important not only attacking H7
but also taking away the all important
F7 Square from the queen and we just
break through this ishm no this is an
incredibly complicated position one good
thing Leon has going for him is it's
only 10 moves to the time control
because I think uh if it if it were 15 I
think the difference between 10 and 15
here is massive because he is down to 11
minutes on our on our screens and the
more we analyze this the more we realize
uh that confused yeah you you you need
to be playing very very precise machine
moves which even when you sort of dig
down and try to discern what the
difference is between what is supposedly
a good move and a bad
move both of them look playable but one
is good and one really really isn't so
navigating this for for one will not be
very very difficult cope I wanted to say
that laner is down to uh six minutes I'm
not sure eight eight moves it looks like
they've just made move 32 and that
position lanir had been nursing an extra
pwn that's no longer the case that we
did see a knight take C4 Rook B4 we're
catching up with the players E4 Queen A3
Queen B6
D3 and it feels like whatever was in the
position for lineer is gone now the
question
is my question is where is Yan
where question this position has been on
on the board for a bit and there is like
no other legal move than E2 takes
G3 so where is he oh we do have E4 takes
D3 on the board sorry I just let me
update my board E4 takes D3 where is Yan
we are going to recapture as soon as he
returns by the way at the opening
ceremony opening ceremony dinner Yan was
actually absent Anastasia told us that
he was the one nursing a cold yeah and
then it turns out that Duda ends up
scratching today's match for his uh
because he wasn't uh feeling fit e takes
D3 he's
back A5 yeah we've been told that uh
lenia is now in only move territory
A5 I think it's it's a findable move
though because white has a very very
well defined threat here of just play
Knight C4 and then the various bins we
have going here on the queen side will
end up posting black material even after
A5 Knight C4 I have a feeling that yeah
second only move in a row Queen B5
specifically to to be able to meet
Knight takes A5 with Rook A4 also not so
and then you will have to defend this
but this is defendable right uh even
with this Pawn already on D5 I think
it's more likely a draw than not and
with a Pawn on D3 you will establish
some sort of a dark squared control
control uh the big question and I would
address it to the pawn Grabbers no not
the pawn Graber but I think you you I I
would trust you about end games more
than I would trust myself imagine this
position Pawn gets to D4 all the heavy
Pieces come off is this winning or Draw
still draw I thought so as well uh the
one that shocked me was when you had the
queen on A6 and the healthy extra Pawn
on A7 and the engine was laughing Never
Smoke smoke us out so I don't know if
we're going to see A7 A5 but it sure
looks like
he has he's played A5 and he will play
Queen B5 because everything else is
basically resigns because you need to
have a reply to uh Knight takes A5 and
leevon has done something which I
suspect the engine will uh dramatically
disagree with because C4 C3 he he
thought for quite some time and played
C4 C3 and the reason I was so confident
in saying that the engine will not like
it is he is forcing Fabby to find that
that plan of Knight to C5 and uh the
this is sort of exactly the position we
were aiming for earlier mhm and Fab will
not he he didn't go for it when he had
the option on move 30 but now he's
already taken with the queen Rook takes
E4 on the board on the board and it's
quite clear that we have one bad piece
on the board Knight on F3 is not doing
anything anything at all our other
piecers are all looking very good played
yeah and we need to improve this uh and
now it lands on B3 and black will be in
uh uh a very tough spot well indeed as
as we see there Knight D2 and leavon
suddenly getting do you're unravel with
black because okay you have to move the
Rook from E okay The Rook on presumably
the well well if you put it on E6
then DOD
noing for sure we're we're dropping The
Rook back we're going to imagine that
the Knight is going to go to B3 from
where it will be forking the queen and
the Rook and then we Imagine The Rook
back it starts it starts by playing
Queen F5 waiting for you to play Knight
C5 and then Rook A7 and establishing
okay so I'll do it in a different move I
was going to go Rook A7 first yeah yeah
and okay so our Queen is out actually
this is something I really wanted to do
is I wanted to get the queen out of I
hate the Queen blockading the pawns I
mean Knights are the perfect blockaders
Rooks are awkward Bishops are good
blockaders but Queens are terrible now
the question is with the C7 Square
covered the immediate
D7 Rook d8 I'm not allowing Bishop C7
right because I've Got The Rook on A7
even this position is still because B3
Queen B3 check Queen B3 check the Knight
is hanging and then and then now Knight
E6 was my idea okay but uh am I giving
up two Rooks for the light pieces
a rook for the two pieces you know what
I mean Rook takes takes uh Rook takes D1
Queen takes D1 I would probably prefer
to take on D7 first and then on f8
because I think the queen on B3 is quite
strong okay so back here you want to
take on you want to include Rook takes
D7 Rook takes D7 Knight takes f8 black
to move Munch that Bishop I think the
problem is probably Rook G5 in this
position and trying to play against that
Knight on f8 this looks very very
scary well the two pieces are in
ascendency because in this case I don't
have an a pawn unless unless you will
only have one in about three moves time
right I canot rvel it by I can rescue it
rather by going Queen to E3 you can
rescue your yeah I can rescue my
Steed good Steed Queen E3 uh giving your
knight a a retreat this I must say it
looks very good for white because you
know I'm hoping uh that I would get some
counterplay against the white king but
no yeah this just one Checkmate threat
so Rook H1 being checkmates but now the
bishop just uh well she will find a SP
spot or right she seven I I like just to
give your king yeah it's it's
interesting because for the first time
today I'm trying to use my brain and
it's not cooperating because I know uh I
know that the machine doesn't play D7
right it actually enters into this
entire I I actually lie to you about
Rook D5 we absolutely correct about this
whole line it's forced uh after Rook dd7
uh both moves are equal uh starting with
Knight f8 or starting with let's let's
check this first because we were
discussing this position right it goes
very very specifically Rook E7 probably
only move to stop the knight from
getting to stop physically not not block
the diagonal just physically control all
the squares and it says black has enough
counter play and the variations are very
very outlandish like the the first line
on my screen currently is white goes A4
hinting that there's also this potential
passer on the a file and then the main
line the reason I'm showing this we this
will probably not happen but what I find
intensely funny is that the main line
here is ba Queen B8 and just H5
you want you want to give me checks give
me checks I don't know also H5 is
threatening H4 and Rook H1 Checkmate but
there's something weird uh about the
first round with the four uh Bishops of
opposite color but this is a second game
of the round where we're seeing a white
king potentially getting to H2 and to G3
as in the Ali Raza versus an cuz the
king could have got smoked out to G3 and
we could be seeing it here as well
that's and if you if you do it the other
way around uh it plays strictly the only
move Rook A8 here everything else loses
okay uh the point being that if you play
Queen D6 I will continue taking away
squares the threat now is to play King
G8 and then let me show let's say before
King G8 Knight D7 rook d8 and we have
actually picked up that Knight and you
correctly assessing it from AAR is just
going to be very very difficult and uh
Le in the me way when Queen s that's a
very which is similar it's it's a
similar Square to F5 but maybe slightly
more
controlled yeah I'm not allowing any
checks okay so once more Queen F7 Knight
C5 looks like a very attractive move the
Rook will drop back to A7 trying to
control the pathway of this Pawn up the
board uh Rook A7 and what do you this is
really well I mean a fully tense
position four moves for the time control
Fabby I like his position but okay at a
certain moment you're going to have to
play D7 why do you have to play D7 I
mean I mean can I just do the principle
of two weaknesses go B3 you know with
the idea B3 A4 and again that whole The
Rook does need to control C7 so I should
not I I don't think I should be tempted
by this line because Bishop C7 and I
think I'm in big trouble but B3 with the
idea of
A4 okay that looks like a fair uh
concept uh I don't feel like an exchange
up you know somehow I'm on the back foot
I don't know exactly why uh but it's uh
it's not that comfortable for leavon and
another thing that I wanted to point out
and
uh that the engine also points out the
big difference between quina 5 which was
the engine Su that played is we can play
Queen F3 and put another piece on a
really really horrible square and from
here we are more or less in complete
control so what's what's interesting to
me is that the engine often will just
play B2 before saying I don't actually
need a passer on the a file I am so
happy with the amount of control I exert
here that I will eventually create
threats I'm guessing on the king side
because it then plays like puts the
bishop on F4 starts pushing the H Pawn
up the board whereas for black I think
the future is pretty clear here we're
going to be passing right to the extent
that maybe we will at some point start
playing King h8 King G8 we're not going
to have any moves uh none of the Rooks
have any squares to go to you cannot
give up on C6 you can like this Rook
doesn't have any prospects anyway MH
pushing anything on the king side
probably hastens your demise frankly
because it gives additional targets it
gives squares for white to to occupy so
it plays H6 and then it starts shuffling
and for white you can put the Rook on D3
to make sure A3 is never hanging it
likes the idea of playing H4 H5 it puts
the bishop on F4 plays G3 King G2 you
can make you can make all kinds of
strengthening moves and eventually I
suspect it switches to attacking the
black king very often these positions
get decided by the strongest side which
is clearly white here not even trying to
cash in the center but saying all of
your pieces are so preoccupied with uh
controlling my my passer that the moment
I create one threat on the king side the
game will just over will be over uh
still watching uh the engine Shuffle
here it doesn't seem to create an
immediate decisive threat in the next
five to seven moves it just likes it
likes the position very very much but it
just improves it builds on it so slight
what what I think is likely to happen
here is that they will reach the time
control mhm and then Fabi will sit down
and ask himself exactly how he is
planning to uh get this to to a full
point from just being in a very
comfortable position well thank you for
that uh Peter I was just going to say
that our beloved and cherished
principles I've always said it and I'll
say it forever uh the knights improve
themselves as they are more protected
protect the Knight more and more and
more and suddenly the Knight is super
super strong so a move like B2 B4 we
don't really understand it the engine is
looking way way way down in the future
saying protect the night and it's not
like you would want to play B4 I'm more
like you I would want to play B3 and A4
and develop another all the way up the
board but the bottom line here is Fabby
has made a a fabulous exchange sacrifice
uh he's he's got uh he's given up um a
rook for Knight and pawn but as Peter's
been describing it it's basically oneway
traffic and leavon is not going to be a
happy camper defending this position
let's just jump to the other remaining
game again for what for those of you who
are joining us late uh Duda has uh
scratched today's game he's feeling
poorly and uh we hope that he will
remain in the tournament we do not know
that with a certainty as uh Yan is in as
at last enjoying um um matters as he's
Pawn up but uh Joe I think we' a social
media we do we do have a tweet that we'd
like to share with you this is from I
have a question from Camila Gomez asking
if there was still a wild card in the
candidates who would be our pick if they
had the power to choose and I'm that's a
good question is there a a wild I know
the
organizers in tournament in candidates
pass there was a wild card yeah not
anymore it's always been a very
controversial thing because it it helped
secure sponsors because sponsors had a
bit of a say not not final say but a bit
of a say in who they wanted to invite
and that that made organizing the
candidates simpler but obviously uh this
this being a world championship
cycle the feeling of not
wanting uh nons sportive factors to play
any role in deciding the final eight for
the candidates is also very easily
understood uh of the people I assume if
we are talking about wild cards we are
not really going to mention the names of
people who are still very much in the
running like exactly so it needs to be
somebody who cannot qualify by by normal
means I
mean Magnus but
okay going force him to
play yeah yeah uh I'm I'm I'm I'm being
uh I'm being told off uh very
strong
uh let me pass this over to you and I'll
think for a
wa um well again uh because uh first of
all nice question camil but because of
the fact that we do have players like
Anish players like Wesley uh fua who are
all in the running to qualify if I said
fua as a you know like a player who
didn't
qualify uh I would pick a player of that
nature uh somebody in the really really
top ELO ratings that somehow is on the
bubble and didn't make it and this is
what we're talking about uh Joy uh big
fight for the big fight for the rating
spot so whoever has the highest rating
on January the 1st 2024 will get that
spot into the 2024 candidates tournament
and at the minute fuja has a live rating
of 2762 but not far behind Anish giri
and Wesley so before uh uh before
today's game fuia had a slightly more a
slightly larger lead but he lost a
fraction of a point by making a draw
today CU he was the highest rated player
now what is what we're all talking about
of course is the world championship
cycle and this idea that you're trying
to find a challenger to uh the world
champion so okay we've got the world
champion dingler in he's all by himself
something I don't like but that's a
different issue so he's all by himself
so who's going to challenge ding Len
well you find the eight best players you
put them together in a tournament and
you say the one person who wins that
tournament the candidates tournament
will be our Challenger hence that's how
we get the Challenger in my in my
estimation you should put dingler in in
the candidates tournament you should
take the top two from the candidates to
play the world championship match I
don't think the world champion should
sit aside from the tournament I don't
don't think that that's such a
revolutionary are you kidding that's
what I proposed 20 years ago Dude
actually and I propos the top four yeah
and then semifinals you're talking about
a very long cycle well at the time it
was a threeyear cycle yeah yeah now it's
been become a 2year cycle and in time I
think it should be an annual cycle just
as the rapid and I I definitely wouldn't
disagree with that I think the shorter
the cycle the more people get to and in
in particular in threee in in Times Gone
by when it was a threeyear cycle there
were very famous examples of people who
picked it just the wrong time right and
never really fought for the title
because their best years came in between
when there was like no qualification
tournaments available whatsoever you and
then something we never answer Camila's
question I would pick fuja what can I
say if he doesn't qualify if he doesn't
qualify then I would Pi fuja but if he
does qualify in qualifies well actually
that's two that's two I need a wild card
okay so I would actually I was thinking
Lena Dominguez Lena yeah I I want
someone who hasn't had a shot at the
candidat at the candidates to be playing
there because you know Wesley's played
Richard's also played let's give someone
very very very deserving for those of
you who have missed it by the way uh for
me I it's an unfair thing but I I had to
laugh it was Leos pores lios pores was
an absolutely extraordinary chess player
from Hungary and I'm not kidding when I
say that uh spanning uh 30 years he was
a candidate I believe eight times now
stop and think about that that's just a
incredible to be at that level where
you're a candidate you're in the top
eight over a span of 30 years and during
during that span of time uh there was a
guy he was a force of nature he came out
of nowhere his name was Michael tall and
I damn it why do I have to why do I have
to deal with a guy Michael tall and then
came after tall tigan petan the absolute
antithesis of what we just saw with
Michael Tall he says where did this
genius come from then came Boris spasy
the natural player then came Bobby fiser
then came Gary kaspar Ani Cara and then
came Gary kaspar so there was lios por
watching One genius after another after
another upset him as he was going
through his candidates and it was sort
of like for for me he was one of those
players that just was born in an age uh
almost a kind of a golden era of Grace
he was inducted into the World Chess
Hall of Fame uh well a few we weeks ago
along uh with Susan pogar and the Great
Dane Dent Larson and it was beautiful
ceremony I just loved it Lov it very
very good to see players of his caliber
being acknowledged exactly and what do
we have well I was just taking a look at
the game between Nashi against Dominguez
extra point for white it is an extra
point for white and also the players are
move 39 but lener has just 1 minute and
20 seconds to make that final move
before he gets that 30 minute time added
the extra Pawn is not that uh not very
keen not thrilling it's not thrilling
well as a groom Feld defense player
you're used to being a pawn down and
having the the compensation and this is
just one of those cases compens oh yes
but he Peter Peter loves it because he's
recognizes yeah yeah so what's the
problem I'm up on down and I've got my
Dynamic plague me I've been doing this
my whole life I will I will take the
matters into my own hands here a little
bit because you didn't throw back to me
and I didn't actually answer the
question question I I wanted to go in a
sort of a direct different direction to
to Yanka I like ler a great deal he is a
fantastic player I I admired him for and
fought with him over over the last
couple of decades but for my wild card I
want to see more of the new generation
in in candidates yeah so if GES doesn't
qualify it's GES and and not be probably
next on the list because Prague is
already in PR is in so I I think I mean
we will see them in candidates in in in
in the future but all of them feel like
they're probably ready ready now so what
do you think about Vincent Vincent as
well I think he is still I actually
thought about this as I was composing my
answer because Vincent I think has just
had a very nice Europe European uh and
not including him in the list feels a
bit kind of charish but uh you still
have to I only have one spot right and I
think my current picking order excluding
Prague who got there by uh getting to
the final
I think my current picking order is
probably GES then Norbeck then Vincent
mhm yeah the youth he's fa I was having
that dilemma as well but then I kind of
remember just recalling who's on the
list it's pragna Nanda Hikaru Fabby and
uh well before I explain away my
reasoning let's pay attention to Len for
the 30 seconds to make one move I think
in this kind of things you just kind of
make them move like Queen to D6 more or
less just what the heck uh uh nothing
extraordinary needed here at this moment
uh just well he's keeping us entertained
just 10 seconds Rook A7 I like this move
stopping Rook to B7 yeah side side
stepping yeah stopping Rook B7 I have a
question for you both so if white were
to play Queen E5 which is the most
direct yes very good question yes and I
would be disinclined to trade this is
this is the point are you going to
correct White's porn structure I don't
want to I mean I don't think my losing
chances are are terrible no no seriously
I think that you have a desperately hard
time proving this position I know it
looks funny that I'm putting my knight
back but you imagine if I play H5 and
Knight H6 it's going to be very very
hard for you to prove your extra pawn
and I've helped you enormously by bring
your Pawn to
E5 it doesn't mean you're not going to
try there's also a very specific thing
here that the engine suggests I was kind
of shocked at how readily it takes on E5
here but part of the reason at least
might be the fact that after 97 I this
still but I wanted to show something
very specific after let's say rooke B5
here I think we can already play F6 and
the point is if if E6 we're just in time
to play Knight f8 and then we play I'm
going to have to interrupt you because
we think we should go to thep uh the
Leon's game yeah Leon's game because not
that many moves left but leavon just has
45 seconds on the clock and his position
is difficult he's not enjoying his uh
position one bit and he's just played
okay just a second hold on when we left
it we did see Queen F3 M we did see B4
we did see H6 Rook D3 and leavon is just
lashed out with F5
that's okay it's not terrible but it
does have consequences right Bishop can
come to E5 absolutely I think he's just
desperate and he's looking for something
to do because I think he is pretty much
correctly uh estimating that if he does
nothing for the next five moves white
will find improvements so at least he's
doing it when both of them are short on
time but Bishop E5 looks very compelling
yeah you have to you have to have a
reply to Rook E8 I suspect but the
engine does have a reply to Rook e que
G3 or que G3 is fine for some reason
also the engine suggests when taky six
is borderline winning but we'll get to
that if it happens cuz we should be
watching we should be watching the
screen so F6 F5 inviting Bishop E5 Joy
would you pounce uh with a move like
Bishop E5 abolutely because you'd want
to play F4 next right reinforce the
bishop I heard uh when you playing fast
and relying on your intuition often the
first move that you need to look up is
the move that is now available to you as
a consequence of your opponent's last
move so here F5 the E5 square is
available Bishop E5 is the first move to
right play exploiting your opponent's uh
previous move F5 does weaken the E5
Square Bishop E5 I mean seriously if it
was a Blitz game I couldn't stop myself
from playing that move because really
what I I desperately want to do as white
in this position is I want to actually
play
D7 and Bishop to C7 and if I could play
Bishop E5 and queen G3 so for example
I'm going to play a very bad move for
black king h8 queen G3 and now I've got
what I wanted which is that my Bishop is
going to be defended on the C7 Square so
D7 rook d8 and Bishop C7 is a dream come
true so for me the move Bishop E5 I
would find compelling not necessarily
because it exploits my opponent's last
moves but it does exactly what I want
which is uh building up on that diagonal
and by the way the G3 Square we can
imagine a rook Landing there I could go
like Queen F4 Bishop F4 played Bishop
F4 okay
intriguing it doesn't necessarily take
away the same concepts of Queen G3 yeah
Queen G3 is coming with some power there
because you do have Bishop takes H6
ideas as well one thing I wanted to add
is Leon is on 25 seconds now and
and the entire time Fabby was thinking
Leon was calculating Bishop B5 MH I'm
sure making making a different move is
quite valuable against somebody very
very low on time because they have to
suddenly change focus and start thinking
about problems they probably weren't
considering before 11 seconds and
G5 out that shouldn't be any good no
what's uh in my Brave in my uh time
let's put it that way uh the the idea
was just before the time control you
were supposed to avoid making pawn moves
because you can't take them back and F5
and G5 both are very consequential
you're just a you you you you you've you
pushed your Pawn shield in front of your
King You've exposed the king and my
first thought was there might have been
more than one way to undermine the move
G5 he went Bishop E5 right away Peter
yeah no Queen G3 Queen G6 Queen G6 on uh
second best move but position appears to
now be indefensible and it not it's not
really very much very much of a shock
yeah the engine already says that uh
this this Tin Can can be opened by
immediately playing H4 and H5 I like I
don't immediately understand why after
H5 you cannot take on H5 with the queen
but apparently D7 is now winning it's a
good thing7 is yeah it's a once again I
wasn't I wasn't on screen so I was still
talking right uh not to our viewers
which is not the way to talk but the
line the engine here shows is we go H4
H5 right very specifically to lure the
queen away from it seems theoretical
here but actually lure it away from the
C6 square and if this Pawn gets picked
up we continue ignoring the threat to
our own Queen GF creates no threats and
the big big difference is now we take on
C6 and the black position completely
collapses because we uh are now we will
help mating threats very soon combining
them with the very obvious threats of
promoting the dewn so H4 wins on the
spot uh this being move 41 mhm Fabby has
now an strictly speaking should actually
just get up get a drink of water sit
back down and calculate but if something
like Rook D1 doesn't spoil anything at
all and then we will find Improvement
because with as yasa said with the black
kingside structure now horribly
compromised
there will be improvements eventually
there's no way with correct play White
will not find a way to to enter the
black the right no this looks really
good and it's funny the first move that
caught my eye was a very strange one
which I wanted to play F4 I didn't
necessarily want to play H4 H5 but I
wanted to play F4 so the first move that
caught my eye was actually Queen D1 the
idea is yeah I might go to B3 check I
might go D7 and Bishop to D 6 and I
might play F4 and slide my Rook to G3
and uh shockingly shockingly this the
engine just says it's okay not okay no
black is I think still losing the game
but losing it much slower much slower
than uh than in the very Concrete in the
very concrete lines that we were showing
earlier I think it's almost impossible
for white to relinquish control here
without blundering something
exact whatever you choose to do here you
you will still be massively massively
better but uh I've been watching the
computer play this with white for the
past uh 10 minutes starting from
somewhere here and my impression is
shocking as it may seem finding a way in
is quite tricky and it weirdly remains
quite tricky even here if you allow
black some time to perhaps restructure
his pieces a bit better in particular in
your line I think the reason Queen D1 is
disliked so much by the engine is that
it allows The Rook to return to a decent
Square is no
longang so you probably should be
keeping the queen on this diagonal to
make sure that this Rook is completely
pinned uh to the protection of this all
important Pawn uh fabbi is of course
massively favored to to to win this from
here but he will still need to the the
old rule that I think was first
introduced to me uh by Mark
vetki long long time ago was that
against competent defense and in this
tournament you will not see people
defend incompetently right against
competent defense no matter how
overwhelming your position looks you
will at some point have to calculate
cleanly at least once right your
opponent will for you will not be able
to win the game by hand is what is meant
here just by making solid autopilot
moves you will not be able to win the
game so it feels like even here it's it
absolutely looks like white should be
winning sure but in order to to win
actually win the game you will have to
at some point sit down and find a very
precise concrete way to uh uh to get get
ahead yeah wonderful thank you for that
Peter as we prepare to go uh to break
with first of all we want to tell you
about our results so far yes and uh
we've had two results between Wesley so
and Maxim Vash lra that was a draw ala
fua and Anish giri that game also ended
peacefully and it was a fierce battle to
get that tremendous battle actually in
both games and there just to remind
everyone that the reason that the game
between Duda and Report has been grayed
out is because Duda is currently on well
and of course we wish him a speedy
recovery and we will keep you posted on
any updates there and uh just to get it
in there but reserve your places at the
jingle bar at the World Chess Hall of
Fame uh it's tends to be party central
in the Central West End go to uh World
chest Hall of Fame .org jingle uh to
find out how you can enjoy uh the
festivities I know we have a a chess
club jingle bar night as uh all of the
uh employees of the club get together
and celebrate the holidays so see if you
want to join us and then meanwhile as we
go on break uh Anastasia caught up with
Fabi Carana that was it so enjoy that
and we'll see you in a few
minutes
[Music]
Fabiana welcome back to St Louis your
home welcome back to grch St also we
started to speak about the candidates
about the main tournament one of the
main tournaments of 2024 so what do you
think in general about the State of
Affairs in the Chess World on the top
let's say with Magnus who is like drop
some points here there dingly ran who is
absent from for absent for so long like
what's going on in the in the last year
what are your thought yeah for sure it's
a very unusual situation uh I think that
Magnus he achieved everything that he
could want in chess in general um so he
probably didn't see any more value in
terms of playing of course there's
always money but maybe he doesn't uh
worry so much about the money anymore
and he was more thinking I don't need
this and I don't really want to go
through this process which I can
understand on some level of course
because the uh stress and the pressure
and all the everything that comes with
playing a world championship match or
candidates tournament it it does of
course take a lot of energy out of you
so uh at some point we have to make
these personal decisions do we want to
pursue success or do we want to take
care of our personal uh life more let's
say so this is just a personal decision
decision it seems like he uh has less
interest in classical chess as a whole I
think this is not a revelation he said
it himself that he wants to to focus
more on rapid chess Blitz chess maybe
some other forms of chest like chess 960
or uh or other things in terms of ding I
I really can't say so much because he's
less public than Magnus so we we don't
know his thoughts as much but he has
been remarkably absent I mean he hasn't
played anything or had like let's say
meaningful sort of um role in the Chess
World since he became world champion he
played one event the grand chess Tour
event in Bucharest
it was yeah it was very unsuccessful for
him and he didn't play any other events
he said that he will come back next year
that's what we can kind of maybe for the
world tip supermat maybe for that but he
said that he would come back in January
to play an event uh if so that that'll
be interesting to see his return I'm
also very interested to see how he plays
after a long
break um and yeah in terms of the next
match of course it'll be very
interesting whoever he faces um um yeah
I I think that we we're seeing a little
bit of a transition maybe in terms of
other players who are getting more
motivated magna's taking more of a step
back from classical chess thing being a
little bit of a wild card now actually
speaking about Magnus and the fact that
he doesn't want to play classical chest
that much um do you think it's a chance
for you actually to be on top and now
you're a second player in the in the
world and so do this Gap is not so big
anymore so would you try to actually to
be on the top I I've always tried
no I mean I I've I've always tried um
Magnus was always a a huge obstacle
let's say for every player who was
trying to become uh the best in the
world and at some point we were close
but he always had that bit of an edge on
me in terms of results and at some point
I was catching up a bit but then uh also
at some points falling behind because I
didn't have the consistency that he has
and I lost my motivation during the co
years completely uh this was I think uh
I wasted a lot of time during those
years so maybe it was my own fault but
also I think the world situation was a
little bit difficult and confusing and
the Chess World as well it wasn't
exactly clear what would happen uh in
the Chess World to chess tournaments to
the future of Chess or the world in
general so um yeah definitely lost a bit
of time and I think what what about now
it's just 30 something points no to me
it's it's less about the rating because
I understand ratings go up and down and
um yeah maybe Magnus lost a bit of
rating recently but um I'm not thinking
too much about the rating for me the
main goal is really the candidates
tournament and uh do performing well
there and Performing well in general so
um I think that Magnus has always taken
a pragmatic view of tournaments as in
he's he's trying to win the tournament
he's not trying to gain rating or
anything so uh I also feel like this is
the most important that um yeah it's
it's all about the tournaments and
playing well and uh and the results
usually come if you're in good shape yes
so this what I wish you I mean all the
best of luck in this in this tournament
thank you thank you
[Music]
thanks hello I'm women's Grand Master
regim Jan I will be creating content for
Grand store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.com .org
to claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h
.org St Louis the chess capital of the
United States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out qou
stl.com for a WI wide variety of gifts
for everyone to enjoy the St Louis chess
club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chest club.org
seducation hello I'm women's grandmas
ranoa I will take you behind the scenes
of the grand chest store follow us on
social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
pce sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of chest related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chest
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q bouti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy welcome back welcome
back waiting for the cute who that
guy take it over here yeah 4 hours into
the start of play and we already have
two results two games that have finished
in a draw between Wesley so and Maxine
vasra and a wild encounter between Ali
Resa fuja and Anish giri that did fizzle
out and just a quick reminder that the
game between Duda and Report was not
played because Duda is suffering well
from sickness and that game has had to
be scratched and we will keep everyone
posted on that but two games remaining
and two games that looking like they
could be finishing decisively well one
really feels that way the game of Fabby
especially really feels very good when
we left it we left at these parts uh the
players had just made the time control
and after the move Queen G6 the engine
was making a very compelling argument
for playing the moves H4 and H5 and as
Peter was showing us uh it required some
forceful calculation and it was pretty
Grim uh for Lon uh for me I thought that
the idea of Queen D1 and F4 was very
attractive uh After all you've just
black has just pushed the pawn shield in
front of his king and you know trying to
provoke uh
move um G5 takes F4 Bishop takes uh F4
and playing playing for Rook G3 I mean
visually it just feels like you know
Fab's in the driver's seat and I just
wanted to say once again I mean you know
players do have good years and Fabby has
just had a absolutely spectacularly
fabulous year Jo yeah I mean take it
away I mean look at this what has he won
he won the grand chest T classical event
in Romania to net
$100,000 and then came forth in Croatia
and uh what a very important result for
him to finish in third place at the
World Cup which means that Fabiano is
qualified to the 2024 candidates
tournament he's also US champion and
recently just won the St Louis rapid and
Blitz
$4,000 and also as you pointed out uh in
Norway he was leading the Norway
tournament all the way till the final
round he did lose the final round but he
took second so you know Norway ch and
then he recently the grand Swiss he's
playing
fabulously and it looks like he's going
to be the first winner first first
person to win or are you going to rain
on the parade I'm stand I'm standing
here smirking smirking the engine is uh
not because you know you're wrong and
I'm very smart but because I have I have
the the the engine uh saying things to
me after Queen D1 Rook da the engine is
suggesting it's time to go back to
moving slowly it plays G3 it starts kind
of climbing uh slowly
and F4 GF Leon actually shows very very
good recognition here because he says
allowing the G file to open yes it looks
like white will be using it but it also
gives moves to make for black Rook G7 is
potentially something that you want to
do if you if you chase this queen away
first of
all right this moment Bishop takes D6
work
and just to explain Bishop takes C5 is a
check and then everything falls but even
but even if this didn't exist and you
were forced to play queen6 The Rook just
needs to go back because there's with
the Knight so far away without the
Knight you can't really create amazing
threats on the king side and the pawn is
hanging so it goes Rook D3 back and
actually plays either Queen G6 or Rook
G7 and this is the least Advantage fabbi
has had for about I would say 10 moves
it's still better for white but it is
now you you get the feeling that with
with good play Black probably holds this
shockingly that is really a stunner was
was for me as well Queen D1 F4 gf4 the
current position if you will big
question by the way that we were
discussing off air could we get the the
same position back yes and apparently
the problem with this is my first
instinct was we can solve our problems
tactically by doing this cuz we can't
and queen takes C6 runs into B Bishop H2
check but sadly for black this instantly
loses to to what is called and this is
actually uh normally the captures you
miss are the minor captures where like
you can take with a big piece but you
take with a smaller piece and it's
stronger but here it's the other way
around normally you would very much like
to take the Rook with the bishop but you
take with the Rook just to make sure
that Bishop takes H2 doesn't exist
blocking this very nice tactical idea
and black is completely doomed but the
big difference is after Queen F3 The
Rook does not need to go back to C8 it
can go
here and for some reason D7 isn't
winning D7 Rook d8 you don't have Bishop
C7 the queen very importantly still
controls the C6 square and Bishop takes
C5 followed by Rook takes D7 is coming
very very quickly so white actually
needs to start playing precisely here
and after Rook E8 you are forced to move
away from attacking the C6 pawn and
black can play something like King H7
and this once again returning to what we
had of more 40 where none of the black
pieces had any any moves uh the decision
to remove the queen from F3 seems to
have been uh misjudged and after F4 GF
we can see now Fabby pausing because I'm
pretty sure he completely discounted GF
from for AAR I think he thought it
cannot possibly be any good to open the
G file when your queen and your king are
are going to get secured which which
which brings us up to the current
position if we go Queen F3 here Peter
because uh there is still
Bishop oh dear and it's
wow yeah and uh WR really hate to be the
bearer of of bad news but this is the
computer assessment I mean let's let's
just always remember that but I I wasn't
entirely convinced that a human can
defend this one perfectly Bishop takes
porn king H7 and can now the bishop goes
back to E5 E5 and then by the way there
there are squares for pieces Bishop
Bishop E5 is hang on is it's you guys
are real that trick to me many many
times and it's still in the air yeah
it's it still works even here oh gosh
it's very regrettable yeah um one of the
things that I do really like about
Bishop takes F4 King H7 Bishop
E5 is that you do take away the Rook G7
move you know after all and so you play
Rook F7 we have been getting murdered by
these discovered checks so if I go Rook
F7 do I have time Peter just to go I
don't care King H1 I think a five of
four is very important you're and now
suddenly I am generating legitimate
counterplay a four of3 is going to be an
annoying thing to keep an eye on at all
times no it really does feel that uh
with reasonably precise defense you have
very very decent drawing chances and
also I think for Leon uh I'm pretty sure
he he knew he was in a tremendous amount
of trouble so uh having gotten here he
will sort of defend with renewed Vigor
right because I'm sure as a very very
strong player he understands he was
given a new lease on life and right this
is not as hopeless and as as miserable
to play as it was just a few moves ago
so yeah Fabby uh it's commentator's
curse we just did this
fantastic I for some reason I'm very
skeptical Fabby greatest player ever
suddenly it feels like if okay you have
they have that horrible little trick on
the board Bishop takes Pawn always King
and if if one were to take care of the
king king H king1 now Rook G7 exists
shockingly even just putting the queen
on F6 and and staying in in this
formation with like Rook F7 coming
in the problem for white is everything
looks perfect but you still need to
deliver some kind of a killer blow to
win well can't I reload can't I reload
now with Queen F3 and taking on C6 cuz
there's no longer these checks
Pawn there's no check there's Queen A1
check this is why I was thinking you
might have to get really frisky and go
G3 and
H4 so we go uh wait a minute wait a
minute we we G3 and then
H4 and what we're going to hide our King
on H3 and put and put it here yeah maybe
maybe this is actually quite clever and
then maybe we have finally prepared to
to start attacking something the engine
says we can actually just
Shuffle it actually gives you two moves
to make here and sort of continues
shuffling and says threats I don't I
don't see any threats why is Queen F3
not
winning right probably some now not even
not even one move Bishop E5 apparently
unpins everything wow and and and
there's also Rook C7 which somehow works
I think this is a this is a time for us
to stop stop listening to what it says I
agree with you that in human persp like
when I saw Leon play gf4 honestly I came
to the board to double click on the move
and to see the evaluation bottom out
right my first impression was there is
no way this can work plus four but the
more the more I read the more I
understand that Leon actually assessed
it per perfectly properly and uh this is
the best chance he's had in the while to
actually save this game very very nice
recognition do you think leavon can turn
it
around you can over press with white
here you can also blunder some stupid
tactics as we've been doing time and
time again but unlikely unlikely Fabby
will do that knowing knowing Fabby this
year it's very very unlikely Fabby just
blunders something but you can overpress
you can maybe feel a bit AG grieved that
you are no longer winning I think all of
us have been there right you know that
you've had a fantastic position and then
suddenly it's no longer as fantastic as
it used to be and you just refuse to
accept that you can maybe not win this
game yeah no that's been the bane of my
chess career is this idea carry the
luggage of a winning game that I I
blundered away and I keep chasing this
Victory instead of recognizing that you
know like it's gone G I did that in my
last tournament really you had memory
and the worst thing is I knew a drawer
would secure my my team a victory and I
had the drawer in my pocket for some
reason Got A Rush of Blood to my head
and I just thought victory victory
victory you know you should try Yi don't
be a coward right
and well what did I do I ended up I'm
messing it all up and it was a r against
porns and my teammates are looking at me
go why are you playing like this and I'm
like I don't know how do those beautiful
teammates of yours Cano you they were
very nice they were very very supportive
they they did not look at me and go you
idiot those are not my teammates my
teammates no I'm very lucky with my
England teammates uh we have another
game uh the game between Yan and lanir
Yan has done everything he possibly
could he's actually won the pawn the D3
Pawn magically Abracadabra has gone to
the best Square where supported by and I
think he's got absolutely Zippo zero
chances of winning much uh his one his
one hope here and the reason I think the
game hasn't found a magical three-fold
yet is there is a queen on the long
diagonal if we imagine the same position
but I blunder the queen and you don't
take and we get here like just to just
to show the setup if black achieves this
and then just plans the Knight on D6 I
don't think the game continues because
there is just not a threat to be made
against this setup the the the fact that
for the time being the queen still
controls the long diagonal makes it a
bit awkward for black because uh you can
still imagine imagine things being you
know going slightly wrong
and your you really want all of your
pieces on dark squares and the King
being on G8 you have to watch the back
rank you have to watch some you know
mysterious threats but really just
Shuffle right but if you don't mind if
you take that move back Peter I mean I
think Joy will support me 100 fold on
this if the fight over the long diagonal
is so important why aren't you playing
Queen f8 and queen G7 didn't occur to me
uh actually looks very good I I was
looking at the same idea with the move
Rook D6 because it was just there to
support Queen F6 we're not worried about
Rook a che it was just played onto the
board Rook went back to A2 my problem
was I thought let's say white goes say
Rook C2 play Queen F6 and then white
takes and goes very very specifically
Bishop B4 here my Rook get trapped on F6
and I would like to play Knight D6 but
then I'm in this weird situation where
it has it's probably still a draw but I
don't like looking in this position me I
understand you I understand and if I
don't play 96 here I either have to
allow a rook ending which I definitely
do not want to allow or I put the Knight
on a war square and look I lost the game
apparently because I I didn't know that
but apparently I lost the game to Rook
C6 wow because the C Pawn actually costs
you The Rook here wow so that was the
one the one variation I wanted to show
which is once again an attempt to
demonstrate why there are still some
Gremlins in this position qu6 KN Bishop
E4 played in the meantime wanted to
point out just one basic thing uh it's
White's dream to put the White Queen on
F6 yes so you know I'm not a big fan of
Moves Like Queen f8 you know taking
the's going to kick your queen away with
Rook D6 if you tried to go yeah and then
but then the harmony disappears because
the queen can comes back to to E5 I was
going to say all right yeah then and
then we Dr Dr it Dro The Rook back D and
we reestablished the idea of but it does
feel that you know Rook A7 and wh's made
a whole lot of progress which might be
symbolic I I I I honestly think yeah I
also blunder Bishop takes H5 and it's
not blame Bishop takes
H uh it's a bad sign when you just
blundered second this is very confusing
Tak H just goes queen7 no just goes
Queen E7 and wins the pawn back uh all
right uh enough of this making making
fools out of us yeah what has happened
instead is uh lineer played Queen D6
okay uh Yan played Bishop B4 and lir
demonstrated that that Bishop Queen
takes D5 is not worrying him Rook A6
probably will follow the queen will
probably drop back uh to d8 and we will
continue shuffling uh but okay what
about what is going to be the answer to
Queen to
B1 Queen to B1 that's
Bishop G6 is your this is nice Bishop G6
but I will say you are still not really
threatening Bishop takes A5 because I'm
pretty sure that Rook ending is still is
still drawn queen5 Queen F5 so I can
play something like King G7 yeah it just
say but but the point what the Jo was
ready to pce the point was very very C
the point was said just a second I may
be playing against two grand Masters but
I know a good sacrifice when I see one
exactly and young played Rook A8 which
would have just won on the spot if not
for the fact that Knight G7
exists everything else everything else
now loses because not only will the
Rooks come off you will also have to
allow Bishop takes F5 and that Queen
ending is just dead loss but n G7 does
exist it will be found out of sheer
necessity and the equilibrium is still
very much very much maintained wow uh
let's go back to Fabby and the Von I
mean because we're we're commentators
we're in search somehow proving you
completely correct Faby is back to being
in in more control more control than
than he was a moment ago yeah because
Leon didn't play King H7 Leon played
Queen G7 Queen F6 which for some reason
is
weaker you can maybe sort of not that
obvious why not immediately obvious at
all uh could it be because
the comes to D7 yeah plays D7 it's
specifically D7 I think uh while it
while it's available there's also Queen
A2 check which pretty much forces Queen
F7 because otherwise 96 is very strong
and this way we establish uh this pin
allowing us to escape the the fork on
both of our Rooks and after Queen F7 we
can go back and then go D7 and the
Machine also plays Queen E2 and says
this is also quite strong I think if we
are to uh try to dissect this and try to
figure out why King H7 is strong wrer
than Rook G7 first of all it's not clear
that G7 is the best Square very often it
turns very well on F7 it doesn't run
into forks and so on controls more
squares and also not having to worry
about checks to the king I think is is
is is a very very useful uh detail so
I'm I'm actually a bit surprised leevon
played R7 as quickly as he has and the
current position in especially the
follow-up D7 that if you could put D7 on
the board because your first instinct is
you don't want to allow well I'm
threatening Bishop C7 you don't want to
allow Bishop takes C5 check followed by
Queen attacks the pawn uh and E Square I
think the issue here is specifically
that there's stuff falling on the other
side of the board as well so que6 uh
queen6 just picking a square yeah Bishop
takes H6 give me the pawn oh hang on
this is somehow suddenly a draw I miss
something yeah here we have to play R D6
here we have to play Rook D6 first okay
take the pawn with oh the Queen's
protected so Rook on G7 takes D7 yeah
you can do this but but but the engine
insists this Rook ending is after we
start with this one that one I can then
we pick up the yeah I think I think it's
believable uh whoa so after D7 I can't
play Queen E6 the Queen the queen needs
to go to the seventh okay go for and
then after Bishop takes H6 uh you have a
kind of an unpleasant choice between uh
this queen ending
which
is bad because he also lose the F5 F5
pawn it doesn't really feel like this
should be drawable they sometimes still
end up being
like Queen takes it's boming out yeah
the only way to try and make a draw is
to go for this and hope that you're
somehow not lost here in a race with the
cwn yeah with a with a much safer king
and the C Pawn also being a massive
massive Factor this pretty much always
lost agreed uh and and the other choice
would be to play play something like
Rook G6 to which the engine Returns the
bishop to frankly either Square how how
are we winning this
exactly ah it's you actually there is a
difference for some reason it's much
stronger to play Bishop B3 my guess is
in order to play Bishop D4
here nice very specifically we're
preserving the D7 Pawn here it's
currently not hanging black would very
much like for for their next move to be
Rook G7 and we are making sure that we
attack it again
and it cannot leave the G file because
you'll get M and if it stays on the G
file you no longer really like play
something like Bishop C3 and the pawn
will survive this another one of those
details where if I go after Bishop D4
Rook G7 Queen takes D7 is this another
one of those details where there's a
check in the position or something no we
this this feels like we're going to give
mate somewhere up the queen for two
Rooks but it's I'm I'm losing to Queen
E6 check wow wow D7 yeah that pawn is
leading a Charmed Life it uh I mean you
what you were saying there about Mark
dorety and the necessity at a certain
moment of calculating uh a forcing
sequence uh is proven you right7 he
began by Queen A2 check uh Le forcing
Queen F Leon needs to play Queen F7
otherwise Knight E6 game as you it seems
like we can get back or we can try to
find a better square queen2 is ly
candidate here in terms of finding a a
more useful Square the engine doesn't
hate it at all says we're now we're back
to the evaluations that you would assume
mean white is winning right but the win
doesn't seem forced anymore it's not
it's not like this is collapsing in the
next three moves it's just that we
managed as white to disrupt the
coordination between the black pieces
and after King H7 it even says we have
the time to play King H1 and there is no
longer any comfortable way to attack the
PA the pawn on D6 because uh this setup
is extremely sturdy and eventually we
will start threatening D7 one of the
things I think for me uh most especially
in my career as the computers have shown
us or demonstrated that there's so much
defensive resources in a position like
uh ages ago I would have looked at this
position and said well White's just
completely winning I mean just you know
this Pawn on D6 this uh protected past
Pawn well this p on D6 the weat king
it's just you you can't save it and then
the engines are finding incredible
resources in positions that you just
thought were gone and uh well leavon as
you said is actually in the best
position he's had in maybe 20 moves
Peter also the clock time is concerning
to me because I mean take a look at it
Fabian has only at one moment had like
15 minutes and yeah exactly V was down
to his last few it roles have reversed
as far as the clocks are
concerned yeah and in the other game
where I I'm keeping an eye on the other
one as well uh seeing as black has now
sort of lost control over the D6 square
and one way you absolutely lose this
position is if at some point white white
gets to play D5 D6 that probably ends
the game in most cases but the bishop is
hanging if you if you Retreat along this
diagonal of course the Knight will come
back to F5 right if you Retreat along
this diagonal you can play Rook d8 and
then restructure your position with
Knight d8 it seems like uh lineer is
perhaps uh uh not finding a way to
really uh get the blockading set up uh
correctly in place and sort of end the
game effectively but he is keeping
things under control Rook d8 is not even
the only move here you can play Queen C5
inste instead because Queen D5 check is
such a massive threat you cannot play D5
D6 so seems like uh uh this is still
more likely more likely a draw than uh a
a win for my fantasy pick but we do have
Bishop D3 Rook d8 on the board uh Peter
yeah obviously Yan will uh continue
looking for chances here it's a
completely risk-free process for him no
reason for him not to yeah not to
try and Rook A7 played yeah Rook A7
apparently Queen D6 is strictly the only
move now I'm wondering why Rook D7 is
losing Rook D7 ah after takes takes and
queen A8 check the threat of Queen C6 is
very very strong and black is suddenly
in legitimate trouble and I'm I suspect
knight8 just yeah it loses to
specifically to Bishop C2 one tempo
short because Bishop comes to A4 and
collects everything secures everything
along this diagonal that is pretty so no
you you you you feel like the whing
years played it after move 40 because
honestly somewhere around 40 I felt that
he is two moves away from completely
blockading everything properly and
shutting it down right you do feel like
it's possible Yan finds a chipo here
there's a w because we're seeing all of
these lines where I mean Rook D7 looks
pretty natural here because like Rooks
come off we go Knight Knight Knight d8
Knight D6 we make a draw yeah and then
after Queen A8 check you suddenly uh
realize that King H7 Queen C6 is
massively dangerous maybe lost right and
you would like to play 8 with it loses
on the spot and what your choices you
can play Queen E8 but uh once again the
engine suggests and this is surprising
to me but I guess it's because we've
also put the pawn on H5 the engine
actually suggests this end game is now
lost because we cannot stop the king
from coming to very very good squares
you just not in time to establish the
blockade right F6 so let's say we go
Knight D6 King F4 King f8 and yeah the
engine goes F3 and says I will now
create a second passer and this will
take Rook D7 on the board o
oh I don't think Yan will miss this I
think Yan will recognize though I hope I
hope Yan will recognize the opportunity
presented to him because I think if he
doesn't take this now it might never
come again
exactly that's one of the things that I
found uh competing against the world
champions and The Challengers for that
matter is when they are presented with
their opportunities they really do grab
them and uh uh ride them to Victory
whereas when you get your opportunities
you kind of like Miss the moment and a
stunning development in the other game I
like how you turn to me there abolutely
miss your
opportuni what happened there he he
traded of Queens what happened there
what he took on F seven that's a
verrassing and I think this game is
about this game is
about check and neppo may be feeling uh
his moment uh what happened in Fab's
games we we expected Queen D2 he was
shocking for us he traded Queens King
takes yeah he's played Knight D7 which
really feels like he's going to go back
to C5 and this game will end in a in a
draw because honestly you no longer
really have any luxury of waiting if you
if you don't repeat here black will
attack the the D6 Pawn from G6 why why
are we supposed to better with white is
H6 an issue Bishop takes H6 and we just
play an exchange Bishop takes D6 again
yes sir no how many times am I going to
fall for the same tactic Bishop takes D6
again I think worry I fell for it as
well even after both of you had given me
warnings and I feel like a James Bond
movie five times is not
enough oh my gosh he just threw away
threw it
I think maybe the clock maybe the clock
was a massive massive influence there
because we have it the game is finishing
there so let's stay let's stay with this
camera by Leon aronian for for sure oh
my goodness Leon can now claim so the
handshake is imminent
here yeah
wow uh and again the commentators curs
because we seriously we just put up a
graphic as we came back on screen to uh
remind our viewers just what an in in
incredible
2024 Le is like I didn't deserve this I
you helped me out here buddy that was
not a good game on my part you were
doing really really well a huge missed
opportunity let's jump back to uh Jan
and lanir yeah it's now it's now really
really critical for for lanir uh the
choice that I think still preserves some
drawing chances from the things we've
seen is probably
uh
queen8 yeah so if I go well again as you
pointed out the the the first and
foremost is the desirable Knight E8 so
that you could go King G7 and Knight D6
loses instantly to a very specific thing
and that thing only is Bishop C2 and as
you said it uh Peter you're just gearing
everything on the diagonal you're
winning you're you're winning on the
spot so there is no 98 you were about to
say queen8 yeah King let's let's show
King H7 though for a so after King H7
it's very very specific it feels again
uh Queen C6 okay and again we can't
trade queens and promote the pawn to C7
so we're probably that feels like you
probably lose exactly so we maybe you
wouldn't have lost if your pawns were on
dark squares on the king side but
they're not so they will become weak and
they will drop off no the engine
actually goes Queen G4 there all right
sorry somewhat uh somewhat shockingly I
honestly I don't understand what it says
it's trying to play Queen D1 get active
no or Knight F5 I really I really don't
understand this because it goes D6
Knight F5 and doesn't take on F5 wow I
just this I don't understand I would
have thought that this is an EAS the
line the line I can see on my screen
here is D7 okay Knight takes H4 okay
King
G1 okay Queen D1
check Bishop F1 Knight F3 check yeah and
now we have to take and promote yeah and
I wanted to ask you Yer yes in your
estimation how easily winning is this
it's not easily winning is it winning at
all I'm not I'm going to say it's not
winning by absolute
Force it's it's shocking when I had the
pawns yeah and uh no my my grandma's
opponent struggled to win this one with
an extra piece with one Pawn uh I Daniel
I was working with da da
nitki and he had this uh ending um
against
Buu uh
from yes and he struggled and he did not
win it and I was like dude come on you
got to be able to win it and then he
just sent me like Reams and reams of
analysis and I was forced to admit that
he didn't have a win this is not trivial
at all at all I think you remove one
more Pawn pair let's say you remove H5
and G3 off the board this might might
probably just be a draw exactly three
against two I would also lean toward
saying it's winning but it will take
work right it's uh and returning to this
line let's discuss the point that I just
stopped yeah so instead of D7 we can
obviously take on F5 Queen takes F5
happily and go into this queen ending
and then play D7 okay why isn't this
just utterly winning Queen D3 behind
yeah Queen D3 and if Queen C7 it starts
giving checks and then attacks the F2
Pawn right is the mechanism that black
tries to use to to hold this after King
H2 we play something like Queen D2 right
and uh this anytime we go to the H2
Square then we're happy to attack the F2
pawn and as you say you're welcome to
Queen but that's a Perpetual on the spot
yeah I'm I'm very curious that the
engine seems very insistent that the
extra piece position is a more winning
position out of these two because
uh feels like I should know whether this
is winning or not but I don't but it
looks like with the King on H7 and white
getting to play G7 with a queen on C6 it
has to be enough but I don't see how um
by the way that all comes from the
current position that lanir is
struggling with the current position is
should he play the move King H7 and go
into the variations that we've been
looking at or should he play the move
Queen E8 and this is
where uh I would have inted that Queen
E8 was the best move and getting into a
position where you get your knight to D6
that's what he played played that yeah
but the point says is completely lost
yeah the point that you were making as
the engine was saying white is simply
too fast he's threatening to play King
E5 drive away the blockader so that when
you get your king over there in order to
play King E7 and defend uh your good
lead
we make a second he hasn't taken I was I
was kind of wondering if he'll just play
C6
here big moment there did he miss
something Peter yeah Queen six is now
back to being objectively you know quote
unquote draw in such a way that I'm not
sure that if it's a draw uh from a human
perspective but this is a Miss but it's
understandable one thing I wanted uh to
show though because we were discussing
this and I wanted to consult my
allseeing eye if we talk about this line
that we were just discussing with uh
black being being prepared to give up
the Knight for the D Pawn after Bishop
F5 Queen F5 we're still winning as long
as we don't play
D7 D7 Queen D3 that's zeros stop zeros
no way to break out of that very very
persistent pattern of black playing
Queen D2 in this position gotta but if
you play something like Queen Queen F3
and then we end up we end up in this
position and then the king will slowly
like you get the king queen to D5 you
get the king over to C Queen F6 is that
I'm with you Joy why not Queen F6 yeah
draw apparently by the way did you see
that bar went super far to I love the
queen posting up on F6 I thought Queen
F6 Queen E7 D7 and nurse it's the same
mechanism what you should be avoiding
here apparently it's not obvious to me
either I'm not making any fun of of
anyone here this setup is very sturdy as
long as you keep the queen behind the
pawn on D7 where it cannot really get in
the way of you making progress like
after queen7 the best move is to just
put it on D5 and then and then we aim
the king towards like the B6 Square we
play Queen C6 we play D7 and the King
will find shelter somewhere around the
C8 square and the D Pawn Queens what you
shouldn't allow is something like this
where the king quite clearly will never
cross the defile now mhm and this
apparently just holds uh and on that
note we return to what happened in the
game because Yan uh you know you you
will say that he missed the win here but
I was I was thinking about that this is
not obvious obvious how obvious is this
that you are absolutely going to win
this position not not obvious cuz you
were talking about F3 but I guess F3 and
G4 yeah but I guess you can go F5 on
yeah in this position it goes King G5
King G5 and then it goes a four F5 it
just breaks open everything and that
apparently is enough and also very
importantly this might be the absolute
best Square on the board for this bishop
because it controls pretty much every
single square that this Knight can jump
from from from D6 is there any ideas of
going Bishop takes G6 I was thinking
exactly the same thing because that is
going to be four FS after the king of f
it just goes Bishop takes G6 here very
very happily yeah and uh that's all she
but but in general it wants to go F4 F5
Force GF win the H5 pawn and even though
the H Pawn is of the wrong color one
thing we need to remind our viewers is
that bishop and this Pawn will not win
against the bear King black doesn't have
resources to remove this much material
from the board so this would have TN the
black position apart and would have
probably just won quite quite easily but
yeah he goes Queen C6 and after Queen C6
there is even a choice uh the one I was
kind of shocked about the one I saw on
my screen and and thought to myself okay
this is not very human uh machine says
this is holdable Bishop C4 Knight
d8 whoa and after Queen C7 I'm guessing
quite specifically we are not trying to
preserve it on d8 we are just kind of
Happily allowing with Queen E4 Queen
takes C4 we're allowing the trade with
construction and that construction with
the queen on D5 will not be will not be
avoidable yeah so Queen takes d8 we go
Queen E4 check King let's say H2 we go
Queen takes C4 and unfortunately for
white you would like to play Queen A8 I
guess and not allow it to land on D5 but
this runs into Queen D4 attacking
both after watching you Peter I feel
like I need to go to my gymnasium and
work out on my
endgame gym yeah I have a feeling might
save us some points seriously uh and has
he spoiled it uh with this 6 against 24
once again we have to uh remind
ourselves there will be no more time
added this is the final time control F
year he will be in an eternal time
Eternal horrible time trouble in about I
guess 10 time because Yan is extremely
good yes at playing on on his opponent's
time Yan will no longer really think
deeply about anything if he has a choice
he will be constantly keeping keeping
lineer seated keeping lineer thinking on
on his own clock and ler will will be
playing an increment I'm guessing in
about 10 minutes time from here uh and
it's not fun because all of the
positions we're discussing they're no
longer automatically drawn they might be
drawn with best play like Queen E5 or
another option is this move King f8
although now King F1 somehow is winning
I don't understand any of this
specifically king of fun nothing else
well I wouldn't have guessed that no no
it's just I I definitely would not have
guessed so yeah
uh and it's really chess is so hard
because I'm we I am laughing at my own
ignorance and yet I have 50 years of
Chess knowledge and experience uh
backing me I would absolutely defer to
you in this but I have I have the magic
King F1 yeah I have I have the the the
magic one here no Peter you can't
playing King f8 because of King F1
exactly how are we missing such simple
stuff King played King f8 played so once
again we uh we get to a point where uh
there is
seemingly a very precise move which
shifts the the evaluation from F1 come
on that's not obious you know having
said that I'm reading the first line
what we're getting there black will have
to play something like Queen E5 okay and
now after D6 and Knight E6 black is not
getting as favorable a version of the
same position as he was getting before
uh so the line continues along the lines
of like this this and you no longer have
the same tactic for some reason I guess
because the d8 is hanging with cck so
you end up having to defend it passively
but
honestly maybe we oversold it a little
bit because plus two in a position like
this does not actually guarantee a win
not at all because because White's
position is so strong
that if there is a win normally the
engine after thinking about for 30
seconds
start down right I mean you've got ideas
of Queen D7 lining up a battery no it
just ignores it and sort of stays and
apparently we made a horrible mistake
after B B5 I have no idea why I'm it's
going to be that construction again
where the queen Gets behind the D6 B we
have to be very very like for some
reason the only move winning here is
Queen B6 with the intention of following
it up with Bishop A6 and putting it on
C8 and after you put it on C8 you can
eventually uh I guess play I don't know
I'm I'm struggling wow I can see that it
very much wants the bishop on C8 I I'm
not sure understand means that you
whenever you have a queen E4 check
you're not picking up a bishop uh it's a
safe Square it's a safe square one way
to describe it is it's a safe square but
the other problem really is the Knight
on D6 is dominated once the bishop gets
to C8 as it's no longer it's no longer
very good yeah right but but this is an
incredibly difficult ending to navigate
and uh the challenges for both players
uh um but what you really wanted to say
is most especially lanir who will be on
increment yeah I think general rule of
thumb is uh when the uh Stronger side
also has such an advantage on the clock
these positions tend to get lost more
often than they tend to get saved
because the constant pressure having to
find absolutely only decisions time and
time again eventually starts telling and
one mistake uh costs you the game but
arguably he's already made that one
mistake he already was mathematically
lost and it wasn't uh realized properly
by by Yan we'll see Joby uh this
potential result of yan winning forcibly
reminds me of the work we did prior to
our broadcast working with the stats and
explaining the decisive round one games
and why round one is so decisive and
whoever wins Ry ju goes on to win the
competition and how lanir was the only
undefeated player in the entire sville
C I just feel like all of those
statistics got th thrown out the window
what what just happened to us I mean
everything we Maurice Maurice is a is a
lean mean jinxing machine that must be
it because boy our our Preparatory work
for this year SFI cup was pretty
impressive right except for the
results we got we got way laid somewhere
king of eight king of eight yeah and and
having thought about it for a second the
engine is no longer saying King F1 is
the only move that wins at least Bishop
C2 is also Quin C5 check played by the
way so we can stop discussing
theoreticals Quin C5 check probably will
be yes it will be suggested that this is
a mistake but it's mainly a mistake
because after King G8 uh Queen C6 you
are no longer obliged to play King f8
which has we know is a mistake which he
will play right away which he probably
just Blitz out very very heily it's a
repetition yeah so but you sorry Queen
C6 King f8 Bishop C2 what was the idea
I'm not even sure what we're dodging I
have a feeling that we're passing here I
think we like this is an ideal setup
black cannot take on C6 black does not
have a good knight move as long as we
control the F5 Square okay and the moves
King F1 and Bishop C2 are just useful
passes which force black to move away
from this setup which is currently
holding but it will get shifted and he's
gone D6 instantly which I suspect okay
Queen A8 check strictly only move this
is findable I think uh this I think is
find yeah already played by by ler okay
already played and this
now with precise play you would have to
say that below one point Advantage for
white means precise play draws okay help
us out king H2 a very natural looking
move we kn6 only move but once again
very understandable where do you wanten
Queen E5 yeah Queen E5 is absolutely the
best square but you've Queen F3 yeah
Queen everything else loses but you've
allowed takes
G6
nobody invited you
to so what happens what happens if you
play King King G1 got to protect you
have to give this check I'm going to
give I am going to give you have to give
this check and now King G2 we can repeat
and if King H2 we go Knight E6 and E5 is
no longer available very very
importantly and after king queen D5 now
we finally have choices King even King
G7 holds Queen F6 holds Queen B2 holds
so as long as as as long as we don't
allow queen king G1 on the board as
expected yeah King G1 you have to give
the check but I think knowing how
dangerous Knight E6 Queen E5 looks you
probably do give the check I think ler
will not struggle with this
decision uh by the way to my eyes Bishop
takes G6 and D7 might just be a winning
threat so it's time to uh time to play
Queen A1 check yeah I mean there are
only really two legal moves in this
position one is Knight D6 one is Queen
A1 you get here you look at this
position for three seconds you think nah
no don't want that Bishop takes
G6 or or even this idea of Bishop 45 and
then things will start creaking and
falling apart agreed so que one check
expecting him to give the check five
minutes for uh theer yeah okay and there
we can see the players when I when
I with hindsight uh 2020 coming in and
thinking about the round two games and
you said to me one game one game is
going to be decisive of this round I
wouldn't have been picking this game
because this game was always in that uh
yes lanir was up a at one time but it
wasn't a big
factor um Yan was up upon Pon wasn't a
big factor I would have BET The mvl Game
or even the Anish game would have been
or as we just saw the leavon game would
have been the decisive games this would
have been the one to choose may have
been the last on the list it wouldn't
have been
unreasonable uh to to name this as the
last on the list because of how solid
ler has been in in singfield cups of
year years going by also he was the one
in his opening preparation he was a porn
up exactly so I was expecting that game
to perhaps fizzle out into a draw but
okay of all of the games Ki won on the
board and we ex we know from the engine
uh Queen A Wack and not letting white
get that setup with the queen on E5 the
bishop coming to E4 and Bishop coming to
D5 that's a winning
setup and therefore to stop white from
getting that setup Queen A1 check is
actually forced the only move King H2
Knight E6 and lenir can hold with again
engine like perfect
play not easy compared to some other
things we have seen today with with the
engine suggesting some is absolutely a
must Queen aan Che should be uh should
be easily explainable yeah yes he's
taking his time he is he now to three
minutes four minutes on the clock and
closing in on three yeah again uh our
time controls as we've explained through
all of our shows at the do you get two
time controls we're the players are now
going to be relying both players will be
relying on their increments uh to make
their moves they'll get 30 second bonus
for each move played and completed by
completed I mean pressing the clocks
we've seen some players lose on time
they made the
move then they went to press their clock
and they didn't do it in time oh no oh
yeah painful stuff painful and there we
see he's W for the queen queen A1 check
played exactly and it's the only move to
keep the game alive something very yeah
I I was about to say my clock went to
6:02 on lir he didn't get 3 minute bonus
but now it has fallen back to 3 minutes
I don't know exactly what happened there
little gremlins in the house King H2 uh
we're expecting otherwise if King G King
G2 is just simply going to be met with
Queen to A8 check exactly so King H2 and
Knight E6 and what's
the from from Black's setup what would
his best setup be uh one thing I wanted
to ask my my magic screen was uh let me
set up something which is entirely
hypothetical at the time but just I'm
curious so if after D6 D7 here I go 98
do I lose or not apparently no this is
what I wanted to ask the uh the engine
because this is the position of full
paity we're not going to attempt any
kind of a breakout we're just barely
keep keep ourselves alive but we bring
the we'll bring the queen over to F6 and
stay in this shape not really doing very
much playing let's say king f8 king G7
right and I I was wondering if if the
engine will say that this this position
of complete dominance can be actually
converted into a full point judging by
this the answer is just straight up no
so the idea is yes passive as this
position looks it's actually a Fortress
Yeah F7 is normally you attack the base
of the chain you know the old the old
canards base of the chain is extremely
well
protected this this one is very
difficult die on this hill I was going
to say this end game is actually going
to be very difficult to assess because
you know because the judgment will be
I've got it such a dominating position I
will eventually forces it one exactly
and it's the the difficulty is for lenia
actually
you can very easily imagine in this
position let's say white embarking on
white is completely safe to try to get
the king over to B5 and then start
offering some Queen trades M you know
trying to get the king off to C8 and
then probably you are winning uh so I
would not if I had this position over
the board with black I would feel I have
a decent shout but I would not be at all
convinced that this is as seemingly dead
equal as the engine is suggesting uh but
on the the other level it's not really
L's concern he's going to have to make
only moves for a while right if the only
moves lead him to have to assume this
posture with this bading Knight on d8
and no no pieces ever making any active
move for the rest of the game it is what
he will do because Alternatives will be
worse and he doesn't really need to
concern himself with the evaluation of
this position right he just needs to
play
it yeah my my my instinct would have
been at to try to avoid it but on the
other hand just as you're saying Peter
you're recognizing that the the the
weakness in the position F7 is so very
well defended with the Knight on d8 the
blockading Knight to begin with and uh
well the pawn on D7 looks great it won't
win the game on its own yeah looks like
a he's he's even repeating with King J
for now the question is do we lose with
we we do actually lose with 96 very
clever by Yan because the temptation to
go Knight E6 and not very yeah but then
suddenly after Queen C8 and Bishop C4
you are not actually in time to
establish establish the setup that you
want to establish so but no ler doesn't
really want is not going to break the
balance like
that yeah lar knows what's up as pal
Beno would say no
yoking no no joking no yoking oh okay
check check on Ki to one thing that
white must never do in this particular
position is put the King on H3 oh yeah
that would
be I know it's
basic but how many times have we fallen
for that kind of thing on Blitz oh oh oh
that would
be king H so close to6 Knight D6
probably strictly the only move King H2
and the big difference is as we've shown
earlier you cannot play Queen E5 because
Queen F3 is very very strong and that
makes all the difference and in fact
after Knight E6 the engine more or less
makes a forest draw here because it
actually in many cases will be offering
Queen trades I can see on my screen for
instance uh let's say we play Queen B6
here okay black plays Queen
D5 okay uh let's say Bishop F1 uh King
f8 and it actually starts playing Queen
C5 and queen D4 next move say I will be
able to attack this Pawn force it to D7
attack it again and pick it up before
you do anything on the king side so this
is now maybe just manageable move by
move and Knight E6 by the way on the
board and queen C4 blitzed out by Neo by
Yan Queen C4 Queen F3 only whoa okay
what happened uh the engine is
suggesting we have to play Queen F3 we
have have to give this check and in this
position we apparently only make a draw
with Knight yeah you you voluntarily
have to go into this quein ending which
honestly I don't know if it looks drawn
without the engine and by the way the
Knight F4 this is a Perpetual this is
not difficult this is not difficult what
what is difficult is recognizing that
you no longer have a
blockade without this trade and also
that this is not just completely lost
exactly and as we know with Queen on D7
it is completely lost but with the queen
on D3 the engine just shows clear zeros
here
wow this is not going to be easy Queen
C4 is a very very good practical Choice
other moves are still sort of okay the
engine goes King H7 and says I don't
lose Queen A7 Queen A7 no Queen F3 Queen
A7 no Queen A3 King G2 is now
winning because Queen A8 can be met by
Bishop E4 King G2 played
yeah and this is what we were talking
about earli about having to defend this
position even if it improves for a
certain period of time you still have to
continue playing well and it's just so
very difficult on low time by the way
once again my my I my mind's reeling I'm
sitting there saying why can't you just
get the The Fortress Knight to d8 Bishop
takes G6 is on is on tab so yeah this
situation suddenly you know we we've
been looking at fortresses based upon
the idea of Knight to d8 well this is
not one of them because Bishop takes G6
just happens that the
queen uh picks up the pawn the takes G6
picks up the pawn and just going to say
the big idea I guess is that the White
Queen can get to C6 with no problems so
if you go Queen to B7 then the bishop
will simp simply block that check
exactly now here's a question for
ourselves if we
do seize the defensive and we go queen7
it goes Queen D5 and the big difference
is uh the bishop is on D3 which is uh in
the other order in this order as well
this is no longer Perpetual with Knight
F4 and the threat I suspect is Queen E5
followed by Bishop D5 and then things
will start falling apart okay so once
again if I try to okay that's Bishop
takes G6 so that's just wrong first of
all it's difficult to make moves as as
we are demonstrating yes I I'm trying to
get a for the The Fortress with the
Knight on d8 I'm not succeeding okay I
go King H7 go ahead yeah we go Queen E55
go Queen E5 yeah Queen E5 followed by D5
so and then things start really cricking
exactly you've also got Queen F6 that's
my favorite move Queen F6 and queen D I
was I was aspiring actually for Queen C
I did blunder Queen C5 here Joy was
was Queen takes H5 also exists in no oh
stop it Queen takes H5 now that's a and
Lena down to 20 seconds on the clock and
oh my
gosh d d I'm just going to refresh my
board hold I don't think I think this
loses to to to the queen trade to the
mundane because in this particular
case uh our King is incredibly safe this
only winning move no our King is
incredibly fast in terms of getting to
G5 so we drive the Knight back to d8
King comes crawling King comes calling
the fastest is I'm I'm this is probably
still winning but the way the engine
wins it I I can see on my screen after
Queen D4 Knight D4 very importantly the
Knight is like it cannot attack the D6
pawn it cannot do anything so the engine
goes
F4 already starting to prepare for the
brakes on the king side it goes F4 and
then just goes King F2 King E3 King f8
King F2 King E8 King King E3 and you
really have no good squares whatsoever
if I if I walk into yeah 4 F5 is an
additional threat here which will win
many many upon end game I think the the
illustrative variation here is Knight C6
that looks good and after that I think I
win by playing Bishop B5 King D7 F5 oh
about to say you really just going into
a king upon end game and the correct
answer very specifically F five yeah and
only after King takes G6 I will take on
C6 and then I will take trade the pawns
and collect everything on the king side
good point so yeah problems everywhere
for for black now and the king is far
away from defense wow um so the queen
trade followed by F4 followed by King F2
is the is the smoothest and easiest F4
is not the only winning move but it's I
think it's very crisp and you don't want
to be looking down the position with F5
because pawns you're just not in time
you you you don't get there in time a 4
F5 King F2 King E3 and the Knight gets
driven to really passive squares and you
still have a weakness on G6 for white to
exploit later um I found myself drawn to
the poor decision of playing D7 probably
still wins yeah does it though I mean
because that's what I want to ask I mean
that I mean you would be you would be
looking at the most absolute forcing
moves uh and is it winning uh it's it's
going to create more of an issue for you
to win than the other moves but it it's
it's now dropping down it began at minus
one for black which seemed like a draw
but it's now close to close to plus
three for white so okay probably still
winning yes so I I mean I think that for
Napo uh Queen takes D followed by D7 is
the most forcing human but Queen takes
Knight takes F4 is very nice yeah I
think if you recognize just how quickly
you get to that Knight in the center and
how slowly it is uh you know how slowly
black is actually achieving any kind of
counterplay against the D6 Pawn you
don't really want to put it on D7 no it
speeds up Black's counterplay it
actually gives black a very good path
towards that pawn so I think it's
findable to play for the moment we play
D7 joy and the king comes to E7 it's
sort of like no why didn't I just let
the king go to to E8 so I could move the
Knight Play Bishop B5 check um so just
to confirm trading of the Queens is a
win it's a stone cold win only way to
win uh good enough though forcing yeah
but I mean there there aren't any other
choices either because otherwise you
just lose the pawn D6 okay honestly I
would argue uh to to a degree
that
the thing I feel like I have to
undermine my own sort of lifelong held
positions here lifelong because throw
your principles out the window yeah
because the one thing I always give as a
kind of a the one absolutely Universal
piece of good advice that is never wrong
and once again I have to quote the the
late great Mark DKI who uh said this
sort of it was an offhand remark in a in
a lecture which was about other things
uh was that if you only have one Le will
move in the position it doesn't matter
if you don't know what it leads to make
it do not burn time exactly think in the
next position exactly but lineer is on
seconds so what Yan what I assumed Yan
was doing here Was preparing the move
after the cupture so ler knows Queen
takes D4 is coming but he doesn't know
the next move exactly so you don't want
to show him the next move until you've
worked something out for the next five
or so and this is maybe the one
exception to I think generally a very
very sound rule you should be following
in almost every single case if you're
playing against somebody who is very
very long time you do want in Practical
terms to make it as uncomfortable for
him to plan as possible you know I so
need to compile this list of advices and
quite the scoundrel's Playbook exactly
well uh in the case of yan mus
especially I think uh Peter hit the nail
on had very very well he's like the
worst person to get in time trouble
against because he is so gifted at the
speed of which he plays the speed at
which he calculates and he will exploit
the time advantage and that's kind of
what he did he didn't trade Queens right
away even though it's the
only rightful move because he was still
undecided should he play D7 or F4 at
this moment once you understand F4 I
don't think you get off it I think you
just kind of realize I need F4 but I
don't think we fully answered Joy's
question which was like okay I do
understand you want to play F5 and bust
open my king site imagine I play F5 yeah
yeah King F2 King F2 King F7 let's say3
Knight goes back to C6 let's say uh
Bishop B5 is my guess Bishop B5 well my
Knight's
getting push around yeah it sure it's
being bullied you're being a bully KN A5
and now I'm I'm well he's gone D7 which
is a very understandable human human
exactly uh but F4 F5 let let's continue
analyzing this yeah after after Knight
A5 um yeah you're just going to go King
King D4 King E6 and I suspect Bishop E8
wins as the problem the because the G6
Pawn is yeah is
uh is the problem I'm going to and he's
he's gone for the line that we H
analyzed with the D7 and I agree that F4
was better and is the computer now still
saying easy win not easy but uh actually
after Bishop B5 KN
d8 this is now this is now showing as
close to zeros as it can yeah may not be
winning anymore Knight C6 Bishop B5
blunder kn6 he had to play F4 again F4
and that would had to play F4 again to
create this additional thing for black
to worry about Knight Knight to d8 and
so so if four here if King f8 we will
play uh we will play Bishop E4 first and
then F5 and black will once again start
getting torn apart it's just not fast
enough I will create the pass on the H
file and if a four a five we are sort of
back in in the territory that we were
just discussing uh yeah so we get
somewhere here and eventually like after
King 6 we continue passing and yeah the
engine basically says the engine
basically says we need to wait for you
to vacate the please don't hang on me
this this does it occasionally we may
have killed the the board view here
Peter what have you done it's your
natural electromagnetism you're going to
have to flash is yeah it really is
another game so we go we go back to your
board and I will I will Sol this uh
solve this in a moment okay so uh the
current position JY uh Bishop B5 Knight
to d8 King came to F3 and naturally
enough laner has now finally gone King
f8 King
E7 in our variations where we put the
pawn on F5 G6 became too weak now we can
keep the pawn on F7 exactly that makes
all the difference in the world and what
happens if the white
king let's go up the board right let's
go up the board I'm thinking I like this
plan of going F3 G4 and trying SL slowly
right King F3 King G5 I'm assuming I
have to play Knight E6 yeah I'm not I'm
not sure I can get as far as king G5 but
I can go
f so here's the current position King F3
King f8 King F4 has to be played natural
and then F3 F3 in this exact moment yes
okay then I hit you with the old Knight
check okay King moves E5 E5 E5 is it
possible to play F6 and then actually
win that pawn we might actually be
holding well we have to look at it F6
check the king I assume I win the pawn
regardless of where you go Knight C7
Knight B5 no Knight C7 is very strong I
think that's just a draw followed by
Knight that's just a draw yeah and if
you go King E4 instead of King D5 I have
Knight C5 Knight takes D7 and once again
some of these positions will be lost but
not this one instead of previous oop
excuse me mm F6 check King E4 Knight C5
check and again I get this
it looks like a nice uh King and pawn
end game but I suspect uh it's a draw
and after to
G4
G4 I'm taking and I you're running away
with the king king E7 yes and there's no
way you're going to and then my next
move is going to be actually should King
E7 is losing after
king4 because the king needs to be on H6
for white the the the ideal Square for
the white king here is H6 so after King
F4 it's very important that you stop
that particular path uh and then you go
King E7 and then we we we get to this
position where it seems like there's no
real way to preserve the pawn on D7 you
can try winning something for it but
black just attacks the bishop goes back
to E6 creates a threat of Knight C5 one
thing one thing I wanted to show
specifically is let's say in this
position if you go Knight C5 this might
be lost here exactly oh no oh I
can't yeah you should avoid promoting I
should avoid I should I should draw
arrows instead of promoting right uh
yeah this is this is now uh but then you
couldn't have showed the idea that after
King takes D King takes d8 we play King
E5 of6 and we collect the entire chain
and the black counter playay with the
Knight jumps will be covered by the
bishop so this actually is winning uh
the pawn base is F7 in that case well
that's where the Knight gets mistim and
King E4
or uh King E7 on the board by the way
that King E7 that was played shall we
say with alacrity
yes I know what I'm doing I'm getting
ready to play 96 black doesn't have too
much of a choice let's face it that's
exactly right uh why didn't he play King
F4 I thought he I thought he should be
making aine plan of going King H6 yes
you had to be stopped by 9 six check is
that yeah no well no I I think it's
actually a very idea to spot because you
think what is the king doing there on H6
right I mean but it's there and maybe
I'm I'm creating a passer with F3 G4
which is he G4 IDE did well I mean he'll
Ru the fact that he he could have done
this without putting the pawn on D7 he
should have left his Pawn on D6 uh
should Yan should have and he's played
the move F4 Peter Knight E6 probably the
only move that draws now only move very
specifically to be able to meet F5 with
G takes F5 and you cannot recapture
because you are running into a fork here
very important steal a draw white is
really not running any risks here
whatsoever but understood but but also
not winning and the King coming forward
with King E5 both F6 check and even the
very very passive move Knight G7
apparently holds now wow uh if you don't
play Knight A6 you are are in trouble
though because you will not he's played
it he has played it he understands and
he's giving uh Yan the chance to play F5
if he would like can I keep the position
somehow I think weirdly the threat here
is Knight
G7 Knight G7 is the threat I think if
you allow Knight
G7 King E5 then you have no then if then
F six check is fine then a six check
otherwise are you ready to promote the
now I can safely promotee now actually
we figured it out what have you done uh
not me K is is is pure magic we can we
can promote again Knight G7 probably
loses still yeah because uh d8 Queen
takes King takes d8 King F5 Knight King
of6 Knight to5 and even though we've
lost the pawn on G3 we're still winning
with Bishop D3 then Bishop take G6 and
we will end up only having the H Pawn
but the king is never getting with with
a king on F7 the the black king is never
crossing over to that side crucial so
uh yeah uh F4 Knight E6 seems like
there's really no no way forward because
Knight C5 is maybe not ah maybe Knight
C5 is even a threat I was going to say
we cannot really pass but my point was
if we go Knight C5 check here white will
play King e to E5 and we lose if we take
on D7 because the king will come to F6
one thing absolutely to be avoided here
I I don't know how to show this I guess
I will just blunder a bishop yes and
just ignore the fact that this is
hanging right this Pawn ending
is
lost right because white will play a
four or5 and then the entire structure
collapses but in this position in this
position we can always throw in F5 F7 F6
and then take on D7 and this Pawn ending
will always be a draw as I saw the
engine uh Peter if you go back just a
move to that's a nice touch yeah I saw
that as well yeah yeah Bishop takes D7
and this is
still not lost if you if you catch
yourself just in time and the Intero
here nice yeah so 496 seems like
honestly the worst is uh behind linear
Bishop C6 played you can give a check
right you can just give a check and then
take on D7 next move because King E5 we
always have F6 right there's really not
very much left to even solve Joy I feel
like we just got a master class in an
end game I mean I don't know what just
happened this but this game has just
been fantastic Queen and pawn and King
you know right getting the Queen the
queen in into that specific construct
that was fabulous draw the whole how to
win and break up the structure with F4
F5 not playing D7 not uh playing
D7 there was still a one moment to turn
back if we we if we come back to this
very critical position after D7 KN C6
yes starting with the for was cleaner
but you you you still had perhaps it's
currently showing that this is a draw it
was showing this is white win I I no
longer know which which version of these
two engines to trust but yeah uh this
was still a much better version because
the only way to make a draw here is to
play A5 and then you get into those
positions G6 will fall it's just that
currently it's claiming that it will
fall in such a way that black will get
enough counter plane response but yeah
in this position F4 is clean and
actually the engine was also saying F3
is completely winning just leave it on
D6 yes don't don't touch the pawn on the
dile and and get your king into the game
first and then uh you should be
completely fine by the way we have a
move from Len not Knight C5 King he play
King D6 he just wants to maintain the
balance because Knight C5 would change
the nature of the position well I think
he wants to play Knight C5 he's just
doing it without allowing King E5 this
is still fine I think so and
interestingly yes now that we've taken
away the E5 Square from the black king
the engine suggests we can even play F7
F5 check next move which I thought
wasn't really a very good idea but appar
for example Bishop to a bishop A4 is
playable because the fork isn't as good
hang on no now we can just take
right no he's just going to play Knight
C5 Knight D7 against anything that's
what he doesn't really need to think
anymore he's just going to play this but
can uh White be bold and go instead of
uh the mov that you played F5 F5 we
take and we take on D7 next move it's
just not going to be fast enough white
isn't losing here but white also isn't
winning okay I was hoping King F6 King
D7 it's just yeah this is very very
easily holdable for black you're not in
any trouble Knight anywhere get the king
closer to the corner there two or even
three are sometimes not enough two are
never enough
right Bishop A4 played and yeah I have a
feeling L is yeah he's not going going
to bother with any kind of F5 checks
here he's just he correctly understands
that the pawn ending is now fine and he
will go into it yeah Knight C5 check
blade King
D4 you know you play a move like Knight
takes D7 and the the the this enormous
sense of
relief almost a near Euphoria you've
taken away this pass Pond which for the
last 20 moves has been you know right in
your throat Knight takes D7 draw and it
I think it hinges you will still have to
make one more only move if white trades
uh on D7 and goes King E5 you absolutely
have to play King E7 and after F5 I
think you absolutely have to play F7 F6
check King F4 and and now you even have
a choice King F7 is a draw GF is a draw
but you also played bishop7 yeah but you
also have no choice here there's no way
like even on a second you you you can
only really play F6 check in position
there's no way you make any other move
it it's actually very funny I'm looking
at the camera's board and I'm looking at
your board when I look at your board
from where I'm sitting I'm seeing a very
nice clean board when I look at the
camera's view of your board it looks
like an old antique board that's been
you know 100 years in a closet and it's
cracked
wood F5 on the board yeah pretty much
any legal move here that doesn't IM
immediately lose draws like GX F5 is ill
advised pretty much everything else
makes a draw player of Lena's caliber
does not playte porn right and King E7
played yeah and Yan will not enjoy this
once you get back to the gets back to
the room King E4 King E5 E5 and VI a
different move order we got to the same
position and yeah not playing F6 check
here is difficult to imagine nope he's
done it F6 check just as
advertise yeah and how does one recover
from a game like this because Yan will
go back to the room he will check here
with the computer the computer will go
you miss the win and you just like no
then you just go out and to Forest spk
and you
scream why am I such an
idiot um that's that's that is the way
that is the way uh one of my favorite
favorites uh it was in um
Norway and uh Magnus would is at a press
conference and a very young boy in the
audience said you know like when did you
stop crying after our loss the young boy
said and Magnus said who said I stopped
crying was you never saw such a big
smile little boy I'm not the only one
yeah you can see the frustration sure
from Yan you know yeah
King to E6 because he will have sense
that he had a win on his hands and he
let it slip away G4 porn takes porn very
grandly H5 takes G4 and I'll make a be
line to the h8 square and uh well Lena
securing a draw but he was facing a lot
nine out of nine so far in our
tournament wow well what I'm seeing is
uh the Ty for first yes well actually
sort of no sort of no guys look and
there we go King against King and it is
a draw between Yan covering covering
your A very wise move there are some Le
leaders in the audience anger and
frustration there from Yan you you get
that gsh darn it kind of sense a little
little frustration but uh a nice save by
lineer sometimes she got to tip your hat
Lanier's back was to the wall and he
defended as best he could Peter it's not
it's not aimed at Lanier one thing I
want to say that it looks like Yan is
sort of upset at his opponent he's not's
he's only upset at himself precisely
yeah he is extremely extremely upset at
himself because he sets very high
standards for himself and he knows he
knows he let one go there ex he knows he
had a very very good shot and he missed
it right uh and they Ander also knows is
there as as you saw in the last shot
there they were discussing Define
details I'm pretty sure the also knows
he was lost right yeah uh the tournament
starting very very slowly I mean as
commentators of course we looking for
the results I mean
but we we nearly had some today and
today today people two people will feel
that they missed a very very good chance
of of being in the lead Fab Fab I think
less straightforward I think Yan will be
the more upset of the two because fb's
position was also completely winning but
it was completely winning in a very very
specific very
calculation heavy way whereas foran he
was one decision away from just had he
played a four he would have won by no
probably no longer thinks in that game
like he just goes on complete autopilot
and converts it so yeah it's a very
painful one for the young well we had
four tell us our standings uh with two
players not competing today that they
are tied for ninth and 10th but uh that
game has been rescheduled we hope please
Joy yeah and you can see with four draws
today well we see eight players with one
point but it might have been draws all
around but they certainly were
instructive draws we saw master classes
we saw resourceful saves we had a lot of
excitement over
spectrum and uh Peter uh final thoughts
for this event for round two for the
second day in a row we have to accept
responsibility show that graphic was a
blunder
of gigantic proportions because you
remember it was 48% for round one and 30
39% for round two by far the two highest
numbers on our graph so yeah it's it's
us it's us we know we're the problem
here uh on a more serious note very very
interesting round should have I think we
can even use the word should should have
featured two decisive games but as
things stand we wish youngish have do
the speediest recovery possible nine
draws otherwise round three tomorrow
same time exactly and joy thank you once
again it's so nice to have you in studio
here in this new studio and getting used
to it thank you everyone uh for joining
us tomorrow we have a Thanksgiving
dinner but we'll be at work and we hope
to uh see you here and uh well for round
three see you then thank you all for
watching
[Music]
a
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited